[Music]
la
oh
[Music]
e
n
[Music]
for
hello and welcome to round three of the
grand chest tour we are over in Norway
right now we see the players are about
to arrive for round three of it's been a
very exciting competition so far there
we have John MWI Hammer we've
got some other plays arriving early who
do you think who do you think is the guy
who arrives the earliest on
well it's definitely not Magnus Carlson
and he paid the price in round one for
not showing up early when the time
control was announced and well he
actually forfeited that game on time
that's right I'm Jennifer jiad I'm here
with Grandmaster Alejandra Ramirez we
also have Grandmaster morce Ashley and
yaser San over in Norway um round three
um it's just going to be another really
exciting and important round as we
progress in Norway and in the grand
chest tour let's take a look at the
standings after two rounds
well we've got a five-way tyer first
who's going to break through is it going
to be Nakamura Yi toala vashir l or
kowana meanwhile n still within Striking
Distance and we've also got Yan lud Vic
Hammer aonan greet shook we don't
usually see this Soul last from Magnus
Carlson will he
recover definitely a point of drama for
us it's going to be difficult he has has
a tough pairing every single round today
he's playing against Anish giri who's
never an easy opponent white or black
pieces a player that's very very well
prepared in the openings somebody that
crossed 2800 Live recently so we're
going to have to see how Magnus Carlson
deals with such a strong opponent today
after two losses and we've got
Grandmaster mauce Ashley with the key
pairings
today well Jen the thorough breads have
definitely shot out the gates you got
five players who are happy at this point
in the tournament with one and a half
points out of two and of course the
Shocker Magnus Carlson with zero points
that's not something we expected to see
but expect him to bounce back quite
quickly you know he wants to make sure
his fans understand why he is the world
champion but let's take a look at the
pairings as of today for round three we
have vishwanathan Anan the veteran in
the competition a five-time champion
himself having drawn two games showing
that he is one to reckon with hard to
beat and he'll be playing against the
Russian Alexander grischuk who had a
very spotty really tough round one loss
and Drew his game yesterday he'll see
whether or not he can somehow write the
ship and get back to even and in our
second matchup we have leavon aronian
also got off to a poor start losing his
first round game drawing yesterday
trying to stabilize things and now he
has a favorable pairing at least on
paper against John Lan Hammer who only
drew his game so far but he's got to be
happy given that he's the lowest rated
player in the competition and fighting
for Norway's flag as well well Maxim
Vash lra he's got to be thrilled he's
got a point and a half out of two
yesterday he came very close to losing
against Hammer but he managed to come up
with a beautiful idea to save himself
he'll be playing against vasilen toov
another player who was close to losing
but managed to have that very fortunate
win in round one against Carlson and he
was pressing yesterday against Nakamura
but unable able to break through both of
them at point and a half looking to
maintain their leadership status and the
aforementioned Magnus Carlson zero
points out of two hard to believe but
you know he will certainly be looking to
win today against a player he has not
defeated in classical competition Anish
giri giri with a point and a half the
youngest player in the competition
starting out wonderfully for him this
should be a fireworks matchup expect to
really see us focus on these two players
today and the final matchup we we will
also all have all eyes on this one
Nakamura against caruana the two
American players numbers one and two as
Carana is transferring Federation this
will be a rivalry for years to come so
this game will be the start of it
although they've played before it's the
beginning of the Great American rivalry
and certainly they want to show a great
start here at the Grand Prix and
Nakamura was interviewed Yesterday by
our very own yasa suran and he had some
comments about Magnus Carlson's poor
start it's amazing to us uh to see the
world champion two games two losses uh
just quick thoughts about magnus's form
and magnus's position in the tournament
um well he's clearly human that's that's
the first thing um I was I was actually
quite curious because he tends to bounce
back uh quite well when when he he loses
games but of course losing a game the
way he lost yesterday uh was going to
make it difficult and to make matters
worse he black I mean he didn't have an
easy pairing he black against Fabiana so
um it doesn't surprise me that much I
was really more Curious than anything to
see if he would somehow prove that he's
uh he's uh you know frankly uh more
mentally strong than anyone else but
turns out that he's just like the rest
of us when when some some kind of real
tragedy occurs um so yeah it's
unfortunate for him but I mean doesn't
doesn't really affect me anyway I'm just
going to keep keep doing what I'm doing
and uh hopefully all my chances when I
play him in some round I don't know
sixth round seventh round I don't even
know at this point thank you for sharing
your thoughts and good luck in the rest
of the tournament than you so of course
Nakamura really can't care that much
about Carlson right now he's got his own
problems his hands are full with the
number two play in the world Fabiano
Carana that should be a great matchup
starting in just a few minutes here no
way chess 2015
Jen yes we also have a Grandmaster gas
Sahan in Norway as round three kicks off
what's the atmosphere like over there
good morning St Louis uh the the mood
here in savenger Norway is one of shock
as the world chess champion Magnus
Carlson has lost two games the legend
grows as everybody starts to think can
Magnus Carlson make a comeback and here
in Norway I can tell you the crowds are
in a tizzy over his
chances big jumble of players at the top
uh five-way tie in the lead and the
other key matchup of course has got to
be between the two Americans Hikaru and
Fabby both of those players tie for
first but again everybody I mean
everybody wants to know how is Magnus
Carlson going to do today in a key
matchup against Anish Gary well we're
looking forward to an exciting round
here in Norway and we'll be with you
reporting throughout the day have a good
show great so you know one of the things
about nakamura's interview that I didn't
quite buy I don't know what I'm playing
carlan it didn't have that ring of truth
to it I think there are certain
tournaments that even though they're
Elite events you're playing certain
opponents that okay you know that
they're very strong they're high 2600s
but you'll deal with them when they come
whereas in this tournament I think
everybody's so strong you're only
looking one step ahead you're looking at
who am I playing tomorrow how am I going
to prepare how am I going to do in that
game and I think that he has a vague
idea when he's playing Carlson because
that's always in the back of his mind
because he had such a rotted record
against Carlon exactly he doesn't want
to and the reason I say that is just he
doesn't want to make it sound like he's
obsessed because I think that obsession
with you know his horrible score against
Carlson can actually backfire so to me
like when he says I don't even know when
I'm playing this guy like there's a lot
to unack there he is playing him in
round six by the way yeah he is playing
in round six and I believe he's black
against Carlson which is something that
is definitely in the back of his mind he
doesn't make know when it is but he
knows he's he knows he's black that's
maybe that's what it is yeah I feel like
he knows a bit more than he lets on in
that respect and that's understandable
because he does have to deal with that
psychological problem it can't just be a
coincidence no absolutely but you're
against Carana on the other hand he um
has had some pretty good results not at
the same field cup but other than that
so I feel that uh that pairing is
actually exciting for him especially him
getting the white pieces right when they
ask not Amura about his score with
Carlson one of his replies is always
well I have a great score against Karana
nobody talk about that yeah I remember
that at the singone cut that's exactly
what he said so we'll see if he can keep
it up it would be a huge win for
Nakamura if he can take down Karana in
this game he would say I'm definitely
definitely here to challenge Carlson to
challenge Carana to establish myself as
the number two maybe number three player
in the world and it would give him lead
in this event from a very early on he
would take care of Karan immediately so
we're going to have to see how this game
develops karon is definitely not going
to go full out bloody battle trying to
win he's going to just try to contain
he's happy with the draw with block
we're going to see how this game goes
yeah I'm pretty excited to see the
opening what do you what do you predict
there well I mean if Nakamura decides to
start with E4 then I just have no doubt
this will go into some kind of Berlin or
anti- Berlin position I can't see Karana
shying away from this kind of end games
uh he showed
masterfully understanding of this of
this positions but we're going to see
that Nakamura is going to start the game
with Knight F3 a very flexible move it's
still not clear where he's going to be
headed towards and karwana he has very
established openings unlike most grand
Masters he only likes a certain types of
position and those are groomfield
against D4 berlins against E5 and you
can see that Karan actually didn't play
his usual stuff he didn't go for an
early D5 which would go into a
groomfield he played C5 and already that
has Nakamura thinking what's going on
why did he not play what he usually
always plays and obviously what I
prepared
for that is kind of interesting yeah so
Nakamura carolana going on Waters that
we didn't expect right I don't think I
would have ever guess that Karana would
play a symmetrical English with Knight
F6 it's not something I've ever seen him
do although I may be mistaken he almost
always tries to go for the anti-g Grom
fills with black so perhaps he was
scared of certain variation or he found
another good way towards equality in
this kind of positions we're going to
see A4 Knights English and Nakamura will
develop on the king side with G3 and
there's several ways of playing this
with black but one of the most Comon is
to see simply keep the Symmetry and play
G6 as
well so Nakamura caros Carana um the
last time they played uh with these
colors in the singfield cup um nak Mo
played a D4 and her actually won that
game right and that game I remember was
a very strange opening decision because
as I mentioned he's so familiar with the
groomfield and he plays it all the time
and he actually played a slav in that
game if I remember correctly which is
something that was very uncharacteristic
of Karana but he surprised Nakamura
Nakamura pushed a little too hard in
that game he should have uh been content
with the slight advantage that he had
that he lost it maybe tried to draw at
some point he over pressed and Kara took
over the initiative but you're saying
that in reality Karana is usually trying
to play pretty solidly with black and
he's and is's satisfied with a drawish
or equal position right he's not the
type of player that will um shy away
from a drawish end game with black Say
Hey I was with the black pieces I'm okay
with trading everything off and going
for a draw but against such an elite
player obviously right and he doesn't
have the opportunity of playing players
below 2700 that often I mean maybe
Hammer this tournament maybe a couple in
Vian but usually he's playing against
the top dogs and he's not afraid of
having an opening preparation that leads
him straight into a draw however it's up
to White to avoid this preparation and
see how he can add certain amount of
Interest into the game oh yes that's
that's important and you know it's funny
that yesterday you were saying that
Fabiano and his coach have an uncanny
ability to predict the openings because
it does seem that though Fabiano
couldn't have necessarily thought that
Nakamura would play this he could have
played D4 he could have played E4 that
he's totally comfortable almost like
this was his top pick right and I wonder
if this was more of a general
preparation towards the tournament to
bring something new into table and he's
playing this positions which are not as
deeply analyzed as some of the other
symmetrical English or the groomfield
variations that he prefers so I like
that it's refreshing for his repertoire
uh he did play this once against topalo
in last year's singfield cup if I
remember correctly he played the move
Knight C7 and that was his first win of
the tournament trying to set up a maroxy
bind with the e E5 move following up so
the fact that he played G6 means he's
also switching that up and we'll see how
he continues in this opening uh Nakamura
has a couple of choices of how to play
this castles is still the most popular
move and early D4 leads to different
kinds of positions more along the paths
of a groomfield so we're going to have
to see exactly what happens let's also
take a look at another key game today
between Carlson and giri because um
that's going to be really important to
figure out if caring dig him out himself
out of this hole now it started out
actually as a sicilian yes this is a
sicilian with Bishop B5 check it's a way
of avoiding the main lines you don't
have to play D4 and get yourself into a
dragon or a nidor for chingan or
whatever it is that black wants to play
instead he plays Bishop B5 check and
black has three decent choices against
this all of the moose that cover chck
three really so wait what Knight C6
Knight C6 no there's only four legal
moves there's four legal moves three
different choices is not good well I
don't think anybody will interpose the
queen but Bishop D7 is uh the safer
route right it can be a bit dull it can
be quite dull actually but 97 was chosen
which is supposed to give black a little
bit more chances of activity and more
exciting for white too a little bit more
exciting for white it surprisingly
despite starting as a sicilian many in
many games goes towards um Spanish type
of Pawn structures and we're going to
see something that might happen in this
game and not it's not necessarily going
to but it just might show up over the
board the idea is that white after C3
and D4 wants to establish a strong Pawn
Center a very common motive in the
opening after Knight F6 the pawn on e4
is under attack it has to be defended by
the queen and A6 is played now here uh
White doesn't really want to take the
Knight as it gives away the pair of
Bishop advantage it's not something
that's very commonly done instead they
Retreat to either A4 sometimes they
Retreat to D3 either way the bishop goes
back to
C2 and after E6 uh black also had the
opportunity of playing E5 and we see
this Pawn structure very common in the
Spanish U very precisely the chorian
Spanish that has been played for well
since chess started however E6 retains a
little bit of flexibility for both
players uh I expect that Carlson will
play a very quick D4 at some point to
establish dominance in the center with
the pawns and that giri is going to be
attacking it from the sides with the
bishop on B7 or by breaking quickly with
D5 after D4 is shown on the board still
very rich position in in Uncharted
territories relatively Uncharted yeah
this compared to like the Roy Lopez
which you mentioned it resembles right
it resembles a Lopez but it isn't
exactly that it has certain aspects from
it in terms terms of Pawn structure in
terms of plants well of course there's
no Pawn on E5 so that changes things
exactly the fact that the pawn is on E6
instead of E5 changes a few things and
let me explain first if the pawn is on
E5 it's a little more vulnerable in
essence it ties down some of Black's
pieces into the defense because you
don't want to clarify the tension in the
center by ever taking on D4 also the
square F5 is weak and we see how this
Knight usually in the relo pass
Maneuvers all the way to G3 or E3 to
Target this Square on F5 however because
the pawn is on E6 this plan is probably
not nearly as strong well instead we
want to try to find an opportune moment
to play E5 ourselves exactly so now we
go to what are the drawbacks for black
in this position and some of the
drawbacks include the fact that E5 is
possible for white kicking out the
knight from F6 as well as the fact that
well black just doesn't have as much
space he doesn't have as much control
over the center so we're going to have
to see how giri deals with his lack of
space in this position he decided to
play Bishop B7 which is of course a very
natural developing move increasing the
pressure on e4 and I expect Magnus will
either Castle or play Knight bd2 there's
an off chance he'll play a very quick A4
to weaken the uh Queens side position
but I don't see that happening so fast
and inde did he did Castle so Castle was
replied with Bishop E7 almost instantly
feels like giri is familiar with the
position another another kind of
difference is that in the word Lopez you
almost always Retreat your Bishop to B3
because you have that long diagonal
whereas here of course we see it Retreat
to C2 so well partially the reason that
the bishop retreats to B3 in the real LZ
is that you're not giving a choice
because uh the pawn didn't move to C3
quick enough uh before the bishop was
kicked out so true but even if you did
have the choice usually you try to keep
it on be C3 as long as possible actually
not in some lines where you are allowed
to play C3 early you do Retreat it to C2
almost immediately I can think of the
variations with the quick Knight G7
where white does play a quick C3 as well
and after A6 Bishop A4 B5 the bishop
does retreat all the way back to C2
known as the Spanish Bishop it has
incredible potenti on this diagonal and
we've got some thoughts from Maurice on
another game uh the key battle between
the two
Americans well actually Jen I've been
just scoping all the games and unlike
yesterday today we see a lot of
theoretical battles you guys showed that
one game with Carlson and giri that
started off in a a sicilian could have
gone main line but as we know that that
Carlson doesn't really like to go
Mainline too much but aside from that
game every other game seems to be in
theoretical Waters if you take a look at
this one caruana against Nakamura this
might be the the least theoretical of
all of them still we're we are in a main
line or at least a standard position
with the C4 C5 symmetrical English
that's one game that's of Interest also
another English that's pretty standard
position as well is this game between
aonian and Hammer they're just getting
out remember yesterday how after 10
moves it was maybe an hour used in some
cases or in total time aggregate time in
this case players are just blitzing to
get to positions and this one starting
off quite solidly as as well another
theoretical position this one between
grishuk and Anna we know grishuk is a
time pressure hog but check this out 15
Moves In in AES nikov pretty Mainline
snov as a matter of fact with the
exchange on Bishop F6 and they've played
15 moves already and only a few minutes
to use for both sides and another one
starting to look like a bond burner in
the Moran Vin Vash gra and velin topalov
12 quick moves played already we see a
funky Pawn structure trade here on E6 we
expect to see the trade back but the
Players yesterday they ass cheed the
idea of the main lines but today it's
Fighting Chess and they're looking to
keep it exciting here in round two of
Norway chess 2015 guys yeah it's
interesting that we have such
theoretical battles and in such
different scenarios two English um that
resemble reverse Sicilians
a sicilian with Bishop B5 a which
is such a dangerous opening for both
sides and especially this grz game that
is already so theoretically advanced in
the main Line's fingo position I'm
actually a little surprised that Anan is
thinking I haven't seen this in a long
time this kind of brings back childhood
memories for me from when I used to play
this fnof and I abandon it after some
time since I just couldn't keep up with
all the growing Theory maybe a little
bit of laziness on my part
but after D6 Bishop G5 A6 Knight A3 B5
was played and this the scenarios have
become very very common but the move
here that's theoretically most important
is C4 that overtook C3 about a decade
ago as the most popular response for
white trying to close down the situation
on the queen side after B4 Knight C2 and
trying to use the the fact that the
position is close to improve his pieces
try to trade this bishop for this bishop
in order to establish this Knight on D5
forever however the move C3 is
considered to be a little bit sharper it
goes towards some positions that open up
very quickly and I think it suits Anan
Style just a little bit more Bishop G5
is one of the more common ideas in order
for this bishop to have control over
this diagonal which also guards the E3
Square which becomes very IR relevant in
later stages right when the Knight comes
to C2 maybe the Knight comes to E3 it
can be taken off the board also The
Bishop's not in danger of being taken
which frees up the queen and know in
just in general the bishop is much
better placed on G5 Knight C2 was played
and now there's two major choices you
can either Castle which was the old main
line but that had some problems with u
white going crazy on the king side with
very quick H4 idea
that were quite dangerous for a while
and I think that gz played Rook B8 which
is considered to be a little safer and
after A4 Pawn takes A4 Rook takes uh
Rook takes A4 is not played immediately
because this Pawn is hanging on B2 so
first Knight CB4 is played Knight takes
B4 and instead of taking with the Knight
which seems a little bit more natural
players have been taking with the pawn
on B4 just maintaining that Knight on D5
just maintaining the Knight on D5
maintaining the tension keeping the B
file closed uh we know that we're going
to regain this Pawn on A4 very quickly
as the only natural way of Defending it
would be Bishop D7 leaving A6 for grabs
exactly the A6 Pawn well that's not a
very good diagonal
but but yeah the bishop would come to A6
and capture the pawn and white regains
his material parody but probably with a
slight the superior position even though
black has the pair of Bishops sometimes
you're left wondering what exactly is
the role of the bishop on G5 in the game
if it cannot trade itself for any
piece so a really rich opening in store
here right I assume that grishuk has a
lot of ideas in this position he's one
of the few players that still plays this
fesov once in a while uh gin of course
plays this fashion C quite regularly uh
rajabov was one of the great Experts of
this fashion C back in the day uh
although I don't think that I've seen
him play it as often recently I think
he's been favoring double King Pawn
openings
so tell us more about why you quit your
your your beloved SES was the theory or
were there like a particular unpleasant
position well I always thought that it
was very theoretical and although that
style worked for some time when I came
to the US and I started going to college
and well I couldn't really keep up with
all the theory that was establishing
itself every single day basically in the
top tournaments I decided that okay this
is too sharp for for me I need something
a little bit safer that I can play in
open tournaments without having
a well young talented kid between the
ages of 12 and 15 that has studied all
of the new games and just crushes me out
of the opening I decided to go for
something safer but on that h on the
other hand uh I always thought that the
fet cuff was very rich and I do enjoy
watching fov games even though perhaps I
cannot play it myself anymore yeah the
imbalances I I think that's a good point
um actually speaking of Roger Bob he
just asked who who are you not so sure
how to take that I guess Grandmaster
Alejandra RZ nice to meet you all it's
great that he's watching right it's it's
good actually I mean everybody's eyes is
on this tournament on the grand chest
tour and it's clear that even though
rajabov could be playing this tournament
if it was held in another year he was
easily top 10 for a long time well right
now he has to watch from the sidelines
well hello to you we got Ashley with
some thoughts as
well well you guys are talking about
rich games you got to take a look at
this one between these two players Maxim
Vash grav and vesselin toov started out
a and already you see this
expansion of black on this side White
Castle black king still stuck in the
middle of the board for the moment D
takes E6 F takes C6 and now Bishop
dropping back to C2 the move Bishop D6
developing and now immedi mediately
Knight G5 hanging this Pawn on H2 and
going after this E6 Pawn there's some
tactics there but avoiding anything not
capturing here because the bishop might
get trapped Knight f8 guarding the pawn
and now the move F4 threatening a fork
on E5 let me ignore you now of course
The Rook is lined up with this queen so
the queen would be exposed if the E5
move happen so Queen to E1 was played
instead of Queen E2 which looks a little
bit more natural Queen E1 the fork is
back again with e five we have an
extremely sharp position that has broken
out already after only 16 moves and they
have actually blitzed to this point but
white has made this move Queen E1 and
black is slowing down this is certainly
a game we're going to have to keep our
eye on because it is so rich so exciting
and toala there deep in thought trying
to figure out this wrinkle with Queen E1
crazy game has broken out and crazy
theory of teams have broken out on a lot
of the boards
guys W just looking at that game it
makes my head spin there's so so many
tactics and so many weird things going
on both sides Kings already exposed such
a sharp position it seems like both
players development even though they
have some good pieces like for example
toal's Knight on G5 is sorry Maxim
vasher L graph Knight on G5 is very
active it's very annoying it's already
pressuring a weak pawn and his Pawns in
the center already creating a lot of
threats man you got to look at toal's
Bishops already pointing towards the
king said makes me a little bit worried
if I was white but it seems like well
the Frenchman must have some idea some
very concrete opening preparation here
because he's playing very very quickly
this is not a position where a top
grandmas would only use five minutes to
get to if he wasn't absolutely sure of
what he's doing right so this last move
Queeny won just getting out of the way
of the
discovery it does make sense why E1 well
that's a good question you would think
first of putting it maybe on E2 might
make a little bit more sense in order to
maybe pressure this structure later with
A4 so let's look at the advantages of
playing the queen to E1 let's see first
of all I could go to the king side which
looks a little illogical to me as I
don't have that many uh thre well at
least the E2 Square open for the Knight
on C3 you're saying that perhaps he was
worried after playing the move Queen E2
that if I spook this Knight with May B
before it wouldn't have a logical place
to go to well but I don't even know if
E2 is is that logical I mean I think we
in a way we prefer to go to uh um D1 to
E3 D1 I love this maneuver D1 E3 and
maybe later to C4 or even the other way
around go Knight A4 so I mean B4 doesn't
look like a very attractive move
honestly it doesn't it seems like it
kicks out the Knight but if he moves it
pretty much anywhere then this wouldn't
be an issue I it just seems very
weakening so the question becomes what
is the advantage of putting the queen on
E1 there must be some deep idea behind
this that eludes me at the moment yeah
maybe we'll figure it out maybe there's
some variations later down the line
where the queen on C7 gets defected and
we can we can play for B4 our our Pawn
gets to our Queen gets to A5 I think
it's just going to be something very
deep though one of the difficult
yeah absolutely and going back to your
point it's the Moran is a difficult
opening to explain and the reason is
that there are so many concrete factors
and so many concrete ideas so early in
the position that sometimes general
rules just go out the window like for
example why is this castled queen site
when you already threw all your pawns
forward it seems completely illogical
but there are very concrete reasons that
this just had to happen it's a very
sharp position and the better prepared
player will definitely have the edge
well rajab has has joined the
conversation again and he says of course
he knows who you are Ramirez it's just
that he usually doesn't see you wearing
such a nice suit I try I try I have to
keep up and we've got a grand master Mor
sley with some more thoughts on this
beginning round where we have uh
thrilling
openings we do have thrilling openings
but I hate to throw cold water in
anyone's excitement because there seems
to be one game where peace has broken
out pretty rapidly and it is the game
between the two Americans well Fabiano
soon to be officially American once
again playing against Hikaru Nakamura
and this position they have here uh
maybe described mildly as a snoozefest
because the the knights have been traded
off a pair of Bishops have been traded
off just to show you how it happened
here uh it happened kind of in a funky
way after the move Bishop to D7 there
was lots of stuff on the board and then
suddenly they move Knight to D4 but of
course there a discovery of the bishop
on the queen so the queen had to move
Queen D6 and now this trade Knight C6
Bishop C6 Bishop C6 Queen C6 and now
Rook to C1 and he could have taken on B2
right away but he decided to play the
move Queen A6 and now threatening the a
pawn threatening the B Pawn it doesn't
look as though there's many tactics here
and black structure is as solid as a
rock of Gibralter no way it seems that
he should lose this game and if he gets
to play the move B6 for example if
there's any defense on this side I don't
see white playing for a win at all these
players May have to play a lot of moves
I don't know what what rules are in
effect here if there's a 40 move rule 30
move rule I don't know what it might be
but I don't care how many moves you play
here with these two world class players
I can't imagine any other result than a
draw well honestly that's a boon for
Fabiano Carana if uh if that if that
ends up materializing I think that he's
going to be very happy with the result
good opening preparation again he
probably caught Nakamura in something
that he was not so familiar with and and
this massive Beast trade everywhere just
lends itself to a draw and we were
talking so much yesterday about tension
correct about how we wanted to keep the
tension keep the tension yeah that was
the theme of the round but I think that
Nakamura just didn't find a good way of
doing so he decided that he was in
danger probably of being worse if he
allowed black to establish B6 and really
take that little space advantage that
black has right now and consolidate it
maybe even worried about a Queen H5 and
well he decided let's trade off some
pieces let's relieve the pressure and
unless he gains something immediately
from playing Rook C1 it doesn't seem
like he has any hopes for an advantage
to very clever move Queen A6 puts the
queen out of Hammer's way since the Rook
will no longer be targeting it through
an x-ray and allows to move B6 on the
next uh turn to defend the pawn on C5
and it attacks A2 while keeping the
tension with Bishop takes B2 which means
that white has to somehow either defend
both of his pawns which he can do with
for example Queen B3 or let one go which
just establishes further simplifications
and more and more the game does seem to
be taking a drawish turn well again
great preparation by Fabiano Karana who
I don't think of him as soon to be
American he's an American citizen he's
always been
us yes I suppose so he's of course I
play for Italy but he did play he an
American citizen so I think I think in
some sense it feels
inevitable I think a lot of players
thought that as soon as uh talks or
rumors started that he was being sought
after by the US Federation and well
makes sense in a way because it's like
when he when he was reaching that super
grandm level he had to play more but now
that you're Elite you don't really he
doesn't play as many tournaments so it's
not as crucial for him to live in Europe
I right but I think he's still going to
be living in Europe right or is he
moving back to I'm sure he'll have a
place here I mean I don't know all the
logistical details but I'm just saying
that like becoming number two in the
world it makes it makes a lot of sense
for him to to live in the United States
again because I think that's where he
feels at
home right it we'll see actually uh
chess has expanded greatly and I
remember a time it was not that long ago
uh where if you were a top Elite player
you basically moved to Europe uh there
were all the top tournaments were there
all the great uh ladis was there vion
was there anything that was a great
tournament was held in Europe and
suddenly we've seen actually uh some of
the top players move out of Europe
because it's a global game anyways
there's tournaments all around the world
why do I have to focus on just Europe
let me go back to my home country and
establish a more comfortable life fish
Anan used to live in Europe and he moved
back to in Spain that's correct and he
moved back to India actually the first
time I had the pleasure of meeting Anan
I was very surprised he had a very thick
Spanish Spanish accent and I was like a
little taking a back oh his Spanish is
very very good though it's very very
good but you can instantly tell which
region he's from and that was what was
surprising for
me and we got a Maurice some thoughts on
the grea game oh speaking of an on they
are playing this game a theoretical
battle and in this position Guk played
the move A5 he played A6 to A5 seemingly
sacrificing a pawn but not quite the
point being that of course if you take
with the pawn The Rook is already
trained down this line and if the Rook
were to take here then instantly a
tactic would come back Brook takes
before knocking the legs from under this
Rook if you capture here Queen takes and
suddenly black is in the driver's seat
winning the game Big Advantage it's
almost impossible to defend that night
so after the move A5 a little bit funky
Anan replied instantly with the move a
four now remember we talked about the
fact that grischuk is a time pressure
hog in his first game he played against
giri it was completely ridiculous that
position he got himself in he had just a
few moves and uh to he had just a few
minutes to play a lot of moves and he
was not able to hold the balance and
went down in flames yesterday he also
got into heavy time pressure against uh
against aonian and managed to get out of
that one as well well now he's facing
another player who's quite a serious
player and he took quite a while after
that last move by unon H4 to play a move
which looks to my eyes as completely
natural you could have played in five
seconds H4 attacking your Bishop he and
he just dropped the bishop back I don't
get it how do you explain this Alejandro
H4 y your Bishop's under attack where
else are you going to put it than on the
Square anyway he took quite a bit of
time it seemed around 10 12 minutes I
think maybe even a little bit longer
than that to make this move Bishop to AG
six which just seem entirely natural
we'll see how he manages his time as the
game proceeds guys time pressure hog
where did this expression come from I
actually have no idea I've been hearing
it since I moved to America but I don't
know exactly where it comes from time
pressure hog it sounds sound I always I
always heard time pressure addict or
things like that but time pressure hog
we certainly don't call any female chess
players time pressure Haws oh make sure
not to do that in
commentary however I think Guk basically
is about of much of a let's go with time
trouble addict as as it gets he always
manages to get into time trouble and I
don't know how even in the most
theoretical of openings here he's r at
the elite level it's very rare for the
elite level it's just basically him that
you're like this guy this guy has time
trouble just don't worry about the first
three hours he's not going to make a
move then he'll be in time trouble he
has to make 40 moves well the addition
uh for many people rises from the rush
that you get because you're like this
out of- body experience when you're in a
chest position it's intense and you have
very little time left it it really just
it's it's like a it's like a drought
that's true you lose your sense of time
and obviously obviously and in times
seems like it stretches out basically I
think that grischuk has perfected
playing under time travel but that
doesn't excuse him for getting into it
it's not that he doesn't lose gains
because of time travel because he does
and the problem is that sometimes he
just double triple quadruple checks
thinks a little too much and as Maurice
pointed out in this particular position
even though he might be worried that
Anan has some kind of preparation even
though it's clear that the Indian player
has some ideas in this situation I mean
your Bishop's under attack you can't
really realistically move it back to F6
or E7 as it's a not doing anything B it
was already there see it's under attack
by the knight in certain variations so
that doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense to put it on F4 because I kick it
out with G3 and I gain a free Temple
there's no reason white doesn't want to
play G3 so that only leaves uh Bishop H6
and Bishop H4 and since Bishop H4
blunders a piece to the very cute idea
Queen H5 where the rook and the queen
suddenly become a Ming
idea uh that basically tells us well
Bishop H6 is Absol forc just go ahead
and play it and let Anand show his
cards which we do have a new move in
this position Maurice can you update
us well we know the force of having
great preparation and we see the players
when they Blitz moves we saw Fabiano do
it when he's got you in his his uh
sights in some position he prepared he
doesn't sit there and monkey around he
just goes wham wham wham look at this I
am well prepared you better watch out
because you might fall for a trap well
here in this position we saw the move H4
gisher gave pause he thought for about
12 minutes or so on this move and
finally played Bishop H6 and Anan said
bam and put B5 down instantly and then
GIS shuk more or less thought for a
second and played the move Bishop to D7
and Anan said bam immediately again KN
se3 he's letting gisik know quite
clearly I know this position it's been
on my kitchen table I've worked with it
with my seconds and you better watch out
because I have a deeply late plan
waiting for you and I'm going to make
sure you feel the pressure on every
single move don't mess around don't mess
up don't play a small mistake because I
got you in my sights and that's what's
happening on this board another board
the same thing seems to be happening is
this one between Vash grav and topalov
after this move Queen E1 topalov went
into a think started looking at it
decided you know what I'm going to play
the move E5 I know you got to think
about taking on E5 maybe Queen F2 what
are you going to do here Vash came back
to the table and Bam played F5
immediately and after ag6 dropped the
night back instantly as well so two
players on two boards are definitely
feeling the pressure as black as the
players with white are showing very
clearly I'm well prepared I'm relaxed
look at Vash lrav he looks like uh he's
sipping tea in a cafe in Paris somewhere
so relaxed right now and certainly topov
wants to make sure that he doesn't make
any mistakes and fall for any tricks as
this game proceeds guys actually want to
take a quick look at the yanan grer game
because we have a new move and it's a
move that I thought of instantly even
though it doesn't make sense whoa what
this E5 it's something that comes back
from my natural fesik of childhood
instinct is to play this kind of breaks
well any Sicilian if you can get D5 in
party and D5 is probably the hardest
move you would think to get into the
speing of I mean imagine just in this
position I tell you yeah next move it's
going to be a D5 Break by black well you
probably thinks I'm crazy well the Crux
of the S off for white is getting that
stronghold on D5 the expense of two
Bishops ex so now after Knight C3 D5 was
played a very strong move that
sacrificed his a pawn but it's saying
hey I'm getting R rid of my weakness on
D6 so this Pawn on D6 no longer weak if
you take with the
queen uh I'm able to exploit this
position of the queen in several
variations I can even try to trade off
the Queens in order to bring
my Rook Into The Fray notice how this
bishop suddenly comes alive and this
bishop D2 check is very real threat as
well as with Bishop B3 Bishop c yeah
Bishop D2 check and yeah this is very
ugly and then if King E2 we have Bishop
B3 and another possibility which looks
even stranger is that sometimes
especially after I trade the Queens this
bishop can actually jump to C1 a square
that's not usually undefended in in
White's camp but hey it's bothering that
pawn on B2 and defending it is not
exactly trivial fascinating battle so if
you had to describe the fnab in one word
how would you describe it for the brave
definitely that's not one word well
brave brave it's it's a brave uh defense
and going into it also requires a
certain amount of Bravery you have to be
careful so many moves where just one
little strategical blunder and which
looks like a natural move will just cost
you the game so I always love the
complexity of this feso but I always
thought you have to be very brave for
certain of the variations in which
especially whites or Black's King comes
under attack and another point of uh
this D5 move is actually to create an
attack on the white king as soon as
possible I'm not going to be surprised
that if Anand does take on D5 with pawn
and he did that Black's going to try to
get rid of this Pawn on E5 by all means
necessary wipe it off the board WIP it
off the board not allowed to do that
you're not but he's going to try in
order to establish some kind of threats
on an unced king that's even more
difficult to Castle because you played
that intermediate move H4 that's right
that changed the character of the
position that can backfire so one word
description of this fashion C you picked
Brave let's see a video where the
players Norway chz give one-word
descriptions of their
opponents one word this is hard actually
one word for him um uh strong
brilliant
consistency
consistency psychological
cocky
unorthodox eccentric
craftiness
perfectionist
fast
slow uh talented Legend solid world
champion
young
young cheeky guy
bold
bravery creative
creative
tricky a good
guy that was amazing that was great I
think giri wins that I think hammer and
I have the same definition one
word yeah Hammer it's a tie between
hammer and Gary that was really fun yeah
some of gir's responses were pretty
funny it's funny how players perceive
each other in different ways didn't
Carana say fast for GIS
CH it's like really really this guy the
one that's always in time
pressure yeah
impressive yeah great little pie
Maurice yes that was indeed humorous and
it's funny one one says creative and the
other says clever so which one uh is I
guess is how you look at the Players but
taking a look at this game with gisik
and Anan this game again that theory you
saw the move D5 it was a bold move
absolutely and Anan instantly responded
with e takes D5 and walked away from the
board you know you play a move like D5
inside your thinking yeah look you know
you you think youve prepared so well I'm
going to play this great move strong
move sacrific ual move variations to
calculate and Anan goes come on please I
was ready with that for that one too and
he just took right away on D5 and walked
away so that means grishuk really
understands quite well that Anan has the
next 10 moves mapped out that he knows
exactly this position that he's seen it
before and he is ready for any
counterplay that black has so GIS is
definitely up against the wall right now
in that game we go back to that other
theoretical battle after night of F3
played instantly there were different
moves to play first moves on the
computer's mind King B8 or C4 but the
third move Knight 8 D7 played
immediately also by topalov forcing his
opponent to think for the very first
time in the game so he might have
finally gotten a chance to get his right
foot in the opening battle there a game
we have ignored we should get back to
guys is this game with giri and Carlson
Carlson has this impressive setup with
the Pawns in the middle of the board he
was able to maneuver get his pieces on
the squares and now Bishop E3 key Point
here is that the move E5 is not playable
for very obvious reasons the main reason
just being this capture on F3 and now
this Pawn is hanging also The Rook is
eyeballing the bishop on C2 so you can't
leave with the queen so that means you
have to take ug an ugly Style with the
pawn and then even after that the guy
can sacrifice this Knight I say
sacrifice is temporary one because after
Queen takes the bishop is hanging so if
you want to regain material you have to
go for this line and now take but this
is ugly look at this Pawn structure
black is going to be solid bringing the
king back into the game and moves like
Bishop to B4 for example immediately
tickle white and so black is absolutely
fine in this line so so Carlson played
much more solidly with the move Bishop
to E3 and the question is even though
these two pawns look great can they get
anywhere can they ever push simple moves
like Knight to B6 just ignoring the
structure and looking at Knight to C4
are possible these this shows that black
has a decent position the engine are
saying black is completely fine here but
again he's playing against Magnus
Carlson so he has to be careful so we'll
see how this game proceeds as these two
young players Carlson looking to get a
win he needs a win if he's going to get
back in this tournament but gir looking
quite confident
guys hey but Gary is the one who called
Magnus coake wellow that's
true but those two are friends I think I
think there's a kind of a friendly
rivalry situation between all the top
players at some point yeah I I would
believe that but true friends you think
not too many but probably a few it's
hard to become true friends when you
know a true friend knows so much about
you and that could be used against you
over the board some kind of
psychological problem some kind of
situation in your life I don't know if
they want to reveal that much to players
that you're going to be seeing in so
many different countries and so many
different scenarios so we do have some
some uh some tweets coming in the hash
Norway as uh one that really amused me
is apparently karnick is in Norway or
maybe he did a Skype interview but uh he
told uh Dirk Yan from doing chess that
Magnus shouldn't play the Berlin because
he doesn't understand it well that's uh
easy to say after yesterday right well
we had talked about the fact that at
least from what I've seen karon is a
much better Berlin player than then
Carlson and we had said that on the
broadcast so I'm not surprised that the
one person that is responsible for
everybody playing the Berlin comes in
and says exactly what he thinks about
Carlson's proficiency you make him sound
like such a villain well the one guy he
was the one did it all well if it wasn't
for karnick I don't think the burlin
would have Skyrocket in in popularity
the way that it did well K beating Gary
Kasparov and we're going to take a quick
break and we'll come back to more for
round three the grand
chest
[Music]
hi I'm Mike maeni I've been part of some
great clubs and now I'm part of
another the chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis right here in the
chess capital of the us our world renown
Center is dedicated to teaching playing
and promoting the sport because chess
has been proven to enhance academic
performance our Scholastic outreach
program now works with over a 100
Schools so whether you've played for
years or never before come experience
all the chess has to
[Music]
offer
you could fly to
[Music]
Venice or
Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the
world but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor St
louis.com
[Music]
welcome back to doorway chest 2050 the
first time of the grand chest store we
just saw a commercial for the beauty of
St Louis how great of a city this is um
definitely take that to heart you guys
and consider coming out for the
sinkfield cup which is the second event
or the grand chest store and that's
going to be in late August yes
absolutely it's going to be a fantastic
event it's going to be probably only
slightly stronger than Norway as I
believe the wild card from the US is
probably going to be slightly higher
rated than hammer but it's going to be
with the same nine strong players that
are participating in the entire Grand
chest tour and it's a sizzle atmosphere
here in the Central West End when you
have the singfield cup oh absolutely the
entire street is filled with chest
basically yeah it's a real fun
time so um what game strikes you in this
in this around as being the most rich I
mean note that we've got all the top
scores playing each other right so
Nakamura and carolana that doesn't seem
yet so juicy right but we unfortunately
no it does seem like this game is headed
towards a very dull position we're not
going to say that this is immediately a
draw but it's dull and it's solid and
there's not much going on and these guys
W make a lot of mistakes they don't make
a lot of mistakes especially in
positions where not that much is
happening it's not a position where a
lot of pressure is being put on or
there's a lot of complicated tactics
strategical imbalances nothing like that
the worst thing that's happening in this
position is this queen on A6 is slightly
off place and once that's fixed I don't
even know if uh Caron has any problems
at all well we'll see how this one goes
um you know I mentioned that Gary and
Carlson were kind of friendly Nakamura
on the other hand doesn't seem to mince
words when he talks about some of his
arrivals he definitely says what he
thinks which is not necessarily A Bad
Thing and well he's shown over the years
that he can play with any of the top
players except of course for his
negative record against Carlson and he
shows it over the board over and over
again despite the fact that I've seen
him grow as a chess player in many
different direction
goes from this very aggressive um I must
win every game type of situations to
well as long as I don't lose I'm
okay that's right so n with lots of
different gears and certainly a
potential Contender for the world
championship he's been showing that he
can take a a spot in the top five for a
really long time he's been lingering
there for years now right that's correct
he's definitely been at least in the top
10 for the last five years or so and top
five more for the last couple years I
think he dipped once or twice but
usually he's in the top five he's very
close if not in there absolutely and
well even though that game between
Nakamura and Karan is probably not going
to be as interesting as we had hoped uh
we do have a couple of battles that are
going to be in my opinion great I think
this Anan game against grischuk is
shaping up to be very interesting
grischuk played the move king h8 after a
somewhat long think and he didn't play
what to me is the obvious move and the
obvious move here was to continue the
plan that I was telling you earlier to
just make this E Pawn disappear and just
move it forward say hey please take
me it's a cheeky move in a way the
Knight cannot really take the pawn
because it leaves the defense over B5 so
you have to take with the Rook the
problem is that after you take with the
rook and I attack this Rook I'm not
entirely sure if I should do it with the
pawn or perhaps with the bishop on to F5
this rook's actually feeling very
uncomfortable but but if it leaves the E
file and goes back to its spot then
after I play rookie a check I have some
pressure on the E file that's quite
annoying suddenly the Bishops are very
active and black gets a huge amount of
initiative on the other hand it is two
pawns that you're sacrificing and from a
psychological point of view it's very
clear that a nan would have prepared
that I have no doubt in my mind that aan
would have at least looked at the move
E4 if he took on D5 so quickly instead
of that chis decided to play a quieter
move King a sh which has a couple of
ideas first the move F5 becomes a little
bit more tempting to play since it
doesn't open the
diagonal towards the king and it's also
in a way a slightly waiting move trying
to figure out where white is going to
develop this bishop on F1 and perhaps
adjust the plans
accordingly so we got a really rich game
for us in store in this one and another
one I think that's going to be fantastic
it's going to be difficult for both
sides to to play it's very sharp already
whites up upon but he has to deal with a
lot of weaknesses another R game which
involves two of our tournament leaders
bashra and vessel in topav now if
nagamura in Carana don't create a
decisive result this is where our
potential is to have a clear leader in
the event and you're not giving any hope
of giri beating Carlson Carlson going 03
at the start of the
tournament that would be uh that would
be too tragic for so many Norwegian and
I don't know if they could handle it I
don't think they could handle it either
but we're going to have to see how these
couple of games go but absolutely I
think that the mvl game against topalo
is likely to see a clear leader emerge I
I think so just because the position is
so rich and so sharp that it's difficult
to get into one of these drawish
positions I mean if this is a draw it's
going to be a fighting draw it's going
to be some kind of Perpetual check or
everything's hanging and massive
exchanges happened but I don't see that
in any way shape or form happening in
the near future both kings are on
opposite flanks and that always
indicates a very sharp struggle where
material balance is less important than
King safety and we're going to have to
see how the uh Advanced position of the
pawns for both sides in front of their
kings will be punished by their opponent
currently Black's focusing on targeting
this weak E4 Pawn so I'm not I would not
be surprised if topalo chuses move C4 in
order to bring this knight from D7 to C5
attack E4 and maybe even establish a
pass Pawn by forcing white to trade into
the Knight that would eventually land on
D3 meanwhile mvl he needs to figure out
how to develop his pieces he has a
couple of issues he would like to play
the bishop to E3 in many lines but he
has to be careful that this Pawn on e4
isn't hanging especially after I bring
my knight into C5 however he does also
want to open up the C file and and the
problem with playing B3 is that it makes
it so much easier for the Frenchman to
go B3 at a certain point and say hey I'm
opening up your king even further are
you sure you want to do
this so yeah that game looks like it was
going to be a party indeed it's
definitely going to be interesting uh
mvl just played the move King H1 just a
little bit quieter it's again saying to
Black show me what your cards are I want
to see exactly how you're going to
proceed before I commit myself yeah so
we going to have to keep a close eye and
see how toala decides to proceed here
right I don't expect too many moves to
be played quickly simply because it's
such a sharp and difficult position for
both Sid 19 moves so they made 19 moves
but about 17 of them were Theory right
so I expect them to slow down a little
bit take a breather see what's going on
in the position make sure that all of
the next moves are precise as we
mentioned any imprecision here might
cause dearly well that's what happens
when you play so much Theory it gives
you the luxury of having more time for
the rest of your RS abely absolutely
something that Chris chook Desires in
every single game and luckily for him he
played about I don't know 17 18 moves of
theory and he'll have plenty of time to
think for his following 22 moves yeah
it's just a way of making the first time
control shorter if you will I mean
longer yes absolutely it it CU instead
of having two hours for 40 moves or in
certain openings maybe 35 36 you now got
uh well there's no time control there so
like yeah come in bring me my second
time control right off the bat that
happens very rarely but it does happen
once in a while and we're going to see
uh Carlson against gidy in this position
if you told I it's really looking like a
Roy Lopez right if you told me that this
was a Roy Lopez I'll would be like sure
well except that the green the E5 thing
is green the E thing is green well let's
update the game the D5 uh Mo was played
now it does look like a Reload exactly
and this happens often and this is
something that I always tell a lot of my
students stop memorizing your openings
uh try to start understanding positions
because you never know when something
weird is going to happen and you just
transpose into a known structure in this
case not so important to know exactly
what the next move is nobody really
cares that what's important here is
understanding what the pawn structures
are about where your pieces belong what
your plans are why you chose this
specific uh position over another type
of relopez uh structure and all these
ideas are much more important than
saying uh the computer thinks G6 is
0.00001 better than I don't know Knight
G4 let's remind viewers about the
tournament structure here for the grand
chest tour for those of you who are just
tuning in so this tournament format it's
three tournaments Norway is the kickoff
and we got the S cup then London chess
classic nine players have agreed to
participate in all three of the grand
chess tour events and we've got a 10th
player as a wild card for each one
drawing of the lots for Norway chest
were determined by a blitz tournament
with which Maxi bashra won um and you'll
obviously see that he chose five whites
here in rway jazz but the parents will
be reversed at the S field
P now let's take a look at the prize
Farm $75,000 for first in each Grand
chest Tour event but there's also bonus
prizes for coming out on top in the
grand chest to rankings so another
$75,000 up for grabs for the top Point
score of the grand chest T combined but
how are those points calculated well you
get 13 points coming clear first all the
way down for one point for getting
10 so it's interesting it's not just
about adding up your score for each each
tournament instead it's about adding up
the points based on your placement right
and that is a that's an important
distinction because if you have somebody
like Fabiano Carana who just steamrolled
the singfield cup he would still only
get 13 points right it's a little bit of
a different system but I think it makes
a little bit more sense when you're in a
chest tour and maybe just the Ambiance
is different it wasn't leaning towards
one player just steamrolling everybody
and taking the tour without a lot of
fight I like the system much better than
a scoring just based on the points I
agree because it adds that other element
to it absolutely and well speaking of
people that need their grand tour points
uh there's a lot of catching up to do
for certain players and we're going to
have to look at Leon aronian who he
wants to be up there he wants to prove
again he's in the top of the top of the
Chess World but his results have been a
little lackluster in recent well the
entire recent year I would say we have
him being white against I love I love
John L's uh one word description of of
Aran a good
guy one two three what's the difference
he is a really good guy though you can
you can't blame him for choosing this
phrase at least um aronian favors a lot
of the times to open with English style
setups which is exactly what he did in
this case and we're going to have a
position that's known as as a reverse
Sicilian more normally we see this
position with opposite colors uh and the
bishop not on G2 but because of the
extra Tempo black doesn't have the
choice of going for a very quick
Yugoslav attack or something very sharp
instead they Retreat the Knight to B6
and they play a little bit saf
this position has been seen quite a few
times uh the move Knight D5 is
interesting notice how this Knight has
actually moved four times uh Knight
F6 sorry about
that Knight jumps to
F6 to B6 and then it ends up
establishing itself on D5 anyway so
after Bishop D2 F6 was placed simply
solidifying the pawn on E5 Queen C2
Knight B6 again removing the knight from
D5 saying to a Rian just well prove to
me what you're going to do against my
slight space Advantage granted by The
Pawn on E5 and R is like all right I'll
develop my initiative on the queen side
B4 Knight D4 was played one of the
softer spots in this structure for white
absolutely have to take this Knight and
after Pawn takes D4 uh aronian play the
move Knight A4 with actually some
threats he's threatening to take on B 7
immediately with the bishop and he's
also threatening to establish his Knight
on C5 in certain occasions uh John L
Hammer decided hey let's tra some pieces
let's relieve the pressure over this
diagonal Play Bishop D5 and you know
trying to remove that very strong Bishop
on G2 yes that Mak seems to make quite a
bit of
sense there are my question right now
would be what happens if I play the move
Knight takes B6 is what I'm looking at
right now there is the problem that if I
capture on G2 and I capture on A8 you
probably do have to take my
Rook I take your bishop and then
surprisingly there is nobody to take the
Knight on A8 because if I take it with
the queen I play Queen take C7 which
looks devastating and if you try to be a
little more patient by first playing C6
in order to say that this Knight is
trapped on A8 I'm worried that something
along the lines of Queen A4 check will
be problem hitting the pawn on D4 and
Black's going to be ending up a pawn
down anyway so after Knight takes B6 it
doesn't seem like Bishop takes G2 is a
very wise idea that leaves me with
capturing the uh the Knight immediately
however if I take with the a pawn which
is the more natural recapture after
Bishop takes D5 Queen takes D5 I have
the move Queen takes C7 again just
basically winning a pawn that would
leave you only with a relatively ugly
move Pawn Pawn takes B6 and while this
Pawn structure here it's already a
little bit of a concession it does allow
black to establish some kind of Rook on
C8 and maybe fight for the file but I'm
not exactly thrilled about having this
Pawn structure be so weakened on the
queen side uh John L Hammer is going to
have to rely on some of his piece
activity to keep white away from a
strong
Advantage I would rather be wide in this
position for sure and aronian he did
take on B6 asking the question precisely
how exactly are you going to capture my
pieces
now and Maurice your thoughts on the
openings as they uh Shape Up in round
three well one game that has me totally
transfixed I have to admit I've been
analyzing this position for quite some
time I can't understand it I just don't
know what's going on at all and I know
the players are going to be challenged
to figure it out themselves the problem
here is that black is looking for
counter play in the middle of the board
that is topalov but V Vash gra has to
figure out how exactly since we're
opposite side castles how exactly does
he deal with these pawns on this side
it's hard to figure out which pushes to
make for one thing your knight has to
get some security because it's the one
helping to guard this pawn and black
could come after it very quickly it's
also not so easy to bring this bishop
into the game because if you go to E3
you you self block this Pawn right here
the Queen's defense so B4 will be a
problem knocking the legs out from under
the pawn by chasing the Knight so what
move to make here for white I don't
really know exactly how to proceed so
the question then is let's say black
makes a waiting move an improving move
like King to B8 he could play another
key move Rook h8 as well which is what
he played in the game but let's say he
just waits around keeps his position
solid what should white do so I've been
trying to figure out myself I asked the
engine the engine comes up with
different kind of ideas one key move
being the move B3 now this of course
stops C4 makes it less obvious to play
this move but let's keep playing another
waiting move in this position like
Knight to B6 there's not quite a waiting
move it actually has a critical point
this move but again how does white
proceed exactly remember B4 is always on
tap if you're not careful for this Pawn
so we play the move A3 making sure B4
you can deter it for the long term if it
ever gets on the board and now the
strange move Knight to C8 you might
wonder what the purpose of this move is
well the point is if Bishop E3 now an
natural move the move Knight to A7 and
suddenly there was this you thought you
were just playing King B8 as a waiting
move the Knight is now maneuvering
itself to the D4 Square white will have
to respect this idea any simple move
like Rook C1 Knight C6 lands on the
board black has repositioned this night
to a great Square now it's headed for D4
and white hasn't said much in this
position so this one is a rich
alternative going back again after King
to h8 the move Rook h8 was actually
played in the game this is this is
another situation it's still the same
thing what do you plan to do from this
position sorry it's here that he played
Rook h8 what are you plan to do in this
position as white it's just not so
obvious I mentioned again if Bishop to
E3 the move B4 really questions you and
asks you what you're going to do about
this Pawn clearly weakening the king
somewhat The Rook might come over or A3
might happen but it's a really rich
uncertain position with this weird Pawn
structure for both sides this Pawn on F5
stopping the pawn storm on this side but
with the pawns already down black has to
be very careful if Black's counter plays
on this side but he's advancing pawns on
that side in order to get the central
break the central pressure he's going to
weaken himself in order to get something
so maybe white can wait very difficult
to understand guys exploring and
exploring we know the players are going
to spend a lot of time despite having
moved so quickly early in the game
they're going to spend a lot of try time
trying to work out the nuances in this
very rich complex position
thank you and uh yes we do have a couple
very exciting games in store today for
round three and that's all you really
need right it's okay if like one game's
a little drier no I agree and I think
the excitement that's going to be
brought by the games that are actually
interesting will more than make up for
it that's right and we are going to I
think see a clear leader after this
round that's my prediction it's a good
prediction I can believe it it does seem
like it's going to go towards a decisive
game in this mvf theal of game now we
have some exciting news we've got
Grandmaster yaser sarahan
who is going to be interviewing siio Dan
to's manager as we go on a break so
enjoy that you guys and hello to yaser
and
siia hello St Louis and welcome back to
Norway once again I'm here with Sylvio
Denoff and I want to pick sylvio's mind
for a completely different reason than
what's happening on the chess board
rather Sylvio was the architect of the
grand Grand Slam chest Sylvio tell us a
little bit about the Grand Slam chest T
how it came into your mind and what
happened well if you remember we start
our super tournament in sopia a great
tournament you were there invited many
years I think in a row and uh in 2006 in
the second year it came to my mind uh
what we should do for the professional
chess because uh let's face it F
everybody's complaining blah blah blah
whatever you want but f is nonprofit
organization f is
not responsible for professional chess
in a way yes but in general they're
responsible for all kind of Chess so we
can Scholastics veteran prison chess
everything yes and this is a lot this is
a lot so we cannot blame them that
professional chess is not doing well so
if we we want to do something about it
is to create professional tour
Professional Organization like tennis
like golf because everybody know few
people know that the first wimon there
was uh 50 viewers uh in life 50 no more
and now what
is uh and Okay I uh um organized a
meeting in sofhia with the biggest
tournament MH and I tell them okay let's
do it like professionals let's unite our
uh our efforts and organize it Grand
Slam so you had a grand slam of Chess
you brought together the top uh
tournaments in the world including your
own mtel which had the Sophia roles as
well yes it was m lares v in that time
and we are looking for uh in the
beginning was three of us uh and then we
are looking for big final right which
ended up being the which ended up being
the they they were very interested and
they organized great uh final with the
winners of all the the other tournaments
and the prize font was amazing for that
time was 400,000 for six players which
would may even still be the record today
in terms of the biggest prize fund for
uh a single comp tournament competition
not World Championship matches sorry yes
probably yes I I don't know the figures
exactly but I get definitely competitive
yes then uh uh
naning uh a tournament from China join
joined the Grand Slam join the Grand
Slam which also great
tournament uh and really really big with
a very big price font also and then
Mexico was uh very interested to enter
so we need to pick up all the continents
if it's possible and to make big uh gr
the idea was six
tournaments and the winners are playing
final mhm so we doing really well until
one moment so you're fantastically in
this moment and you ran four Cycles yes
2006 2006 2006 uh 2007 8 and I think
nine was the last one okay so
everything's going perfectly you're
growing you've got tournaments around
the world from China Mexico's coming
Europe everybody's happy something went
wrong what happened no I can tell you
more I even went to Seattle uh my
hometown your own town to to meet with
Eric Anderson which uh the guy was very
interested and he he told me look we are
definitely interesting we want to enter
in the Grand Slam and will be tournament
in Seattle every year with huge price
one so it was you know fantastic so you
have Europe the best tournaments in
Europe and you have China you have uh
America Seattle and Mexico was you know
in Latin America so it's and the fin
with big FR front in B this was the
idea so when went uh what went wrong
many many things happened first the
crisis hit us the crisis the financial
crisis 2008 yeah 2008 we all remember
that this crisis started and hit us very
uh many of the tournament they had uh
big problems financial problems but uh
not only this one uh not only this one
uh we couldn't reach agreement between
ourselves we are too green let's say and
everybody was thinking that his
tournament is the best okay let's say V
can claiming we have the tradition 70
years old we are very special lares they
were claiming oh we are lares Wim of
Chess Kasparov is here all the time you
know and this kind of stuff uh and which
was make very difficult to to reach
certain agreement between the parties
you know easy things like dressing C
dress cat easy things to put what's the
problem with the dress card some of the
tournament was against seriously yes
let's say uh lares was against
to to put um
unification dress Cod for everybody you
know and uh Sophia Rose also sopia R are
brilliant you know play play to the
Finish what's the problem here yeah you
see the games every days really exciting
great battles and the players are forced
to play to the Finish it's wonderful
yeah if you have
this limit of 30 or 40 moves it will be
different you you understand what I mean
exactly or if you don't have sop your Ro
it will be
disaster again agreed yeah you have uh
draws on 20 moves or 25 moves clear
position you understand right you're a
professional and I think uh we couldn't
uh reach agreements on many things
which was because we
were everybody had their own
self-interest or something like this
yeah first of all this and that's nobody
was was seeing the big picture everybody
was seeing the small picture his
tournaments his interest you know his
trademark you understand uh but nobody
was thinking about development about
going going growing you know and of
course I think one of the biggest
mistake was not to not
to to fight for the general sponsor to
sell this package to sell this gr
package to some big company to have a
title sponsor yeah title sponsors big
one and this was we fail because nobody
was working on that because we were
fighting between each other for small
things M because everybody was thinking
he's the best and he's the most
important if I I was going to ask you a
key question you're seeing now the grand
chest tour it's the first year they have
three tournaments they already announced
uh Jakarta um quick question what would
be your advice to the organizers of this
Grand Chester be United don't fight for
small things fight
uh take a look for the big picture not
in the small picture don't be so don't
be ego involved don't be uh selfish you
know don't think about your tournament
you're the best just think about grow
growing including new tournaments and
finding very
important big big big
sponsor big company serious company who
hold all the all the package and grow
and don't fight for small things don't
discuss small things just Just Be Be
Clever thank you CIO thank you very very
much back to you in St Louis
[Music]
this
e
[Music]
for
e
oh
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the Grand
chest tour we are at Norway chess
2015 great to hear from yasur and Sylvia
um and now back to the game
games we've got a a couple of really
interesting battles today including a
non's game against Guk but what about
Carls and giri well this game has just
baffled me I do not understand the last
few moves from giri uh he decided that
after the closing of the position he
would establish a strong Knight on C5
all right so far so good Magnus
retreated his Bishop uh to C2 basically
because he wanted to preserve the pair
of Bishops however after the move B4
which is a very nice move with the idea
of not allowing this Knight to get
kicked out of C5 uh Carlson decided I'm
going to do it anyway A3 all very
logical all very logical with the idea
that if you take I'm going to go B4 and
then take on A3
later and giri play the move B3 and this
is a little confusing to me because here
Carlson said well thank you for the pawn
bishop takes C5 and that was the
defender of the B3 Pawn if you take on
C2 which Gary did not do Bishop B6 yeah
this pin on the diagonal is absolutely
lethal that's just an extra exchange and
I will be able to capture your past but
weak Pawn on C2 pretty much next move so
the question becomes what kind of
compensation does giri think he have in
this position after Queen B6 Bishop C4
Rook e C8 Bishop D3 was played
safeguarding the bishop and I can see
that giri actually has plenty of
positional compensation in certain ways
for example his pieces his major pieces
are very active on the queen side
controlling the important squares and
controlling the file which is going to
be even more reinforced when I put my
Bishop on H6 making sure that there's
never going to be a rook coming into C1
and even though he does also have the
pair of Bishops the positions a little
bit too close for that to matter so I
don't know he does have some
compensation but is it enough for a pawn
my instinct say not quite not quite
enough for a pawn maybe close but not
quite there yeah so why why go for this
then I didn't black have other
acceptable options absolutely he had
plenty of acceptable options listing
them would take us a long time seriously
there was just a lot of good moves that
he could have played instead of
establishing the Knight on C5 and going
B4 he could have played uh you know not
play B4 in this position he could have
played after B4 A3 just take on A3 and
Retreat the Knight on the next move he
had a lot of things to do it's not like
he was forced into this he just did this
voluntarily perhaps he liked the the
nature of the positions here where he
has a little bit more initiative rather
than getting pushed back but still an
odd Choice by Anish yurian we stay tuned
to see if Magnus gets his uh his first
score of the tor
well he's up a PA I mean if he's not
going to do it now when is he going to
do it he needs to make sure that this
positions where he's slightly better he
needs to defend uncomfortably and but
eventually this Pawn is going to matter
are the types of positions he actually
converts it's going to be difficult for
me to believe that Magnus Carlson will
recover in this tournament if he doesn't
win this
game and Maurice your
thoughts well if Magnus Carlson is up a
pawn he has no weaknesses in his
position and he has no time pressure
issues and he doesn't win well then
something's rotten in the state of
Norway at least uh that would just be
crazy if that happened in this game I
predict a win for Magnus I would be
stunned if you didn't win that game but
this these games I'm still looking at a
couple of other games that are so rich
remember we saw these moves get blitzed
out the one between Vash lra and topalov
and now hunkering hankering down is V
vasila gra the move F5 was played
earlier rookie 8 now on the board and
his preparation is out the window he's
in new territory now and remember I was
saying I was analyzing trying to figure
out what to do next with white and I was
analyzing with a computer as well just
suggesting ideas there's nothing
concrete here that the engines come up
with there's nothing I could fashion for
white this these pawns don't seem proper
to advance at any easy stage anyway for
a while how do you develop the Queens
side prop properly where do these pieces
go Alejandra you pointed out this
interesting maneuver Knight B8 to C6 to
D4 could happen in the position as well
so white is C certainly unclear about
what to do next this is a totally crazy
position now another position that's
wild is this one the one with Anan and
gisu the move F5 did get played and G3
followed up black can play some
interesting ideas here the move F4 is
certainly a move to consider the idea of
trading on G G3 opening the foul getting
the bishop into the E3 Square very
Dynamic idea and if you try to shut it
down with G4 well guess what could land
and move F3 could land on the board
quite easily deflecting this Bishop from
the defense of this Pawn establishing a
pawn in a position and looking to bring
your Bishop into a good square if you
take here by the way there's some crazy
moves like the move Bishop to C1 the
engines come up with Bishop C1 like out
of nowhere the point being that Queen C1
is meant by Rook takes F3 and black
feels very comfortable here White's
pawns are all over the place and black
is looking to bring pressure along this
line the B5 Pawn is hanging black has a
lot of activities not easy to Castle the
king is not safe wild chaotic play could
break out on that board so two boards
really super interesting structures at
work in the meantime kmer Waters can be
seen here in the game with Ravon aronian
and John Ludwig Hammer aonian looks like
he's definitely got a little bit of an
edge with this Pawn structure being
fractured as well so some sharp games if
you add the Magnus game in it only the
game between the two Americans seems
like it's going to certainly pet her out
into a draw but these other games look
crazy look like a lot of fun we'll be
following them quite closely here in
this round guys it's funny that even
though Magnus Carlson is up upon
actually my favorite position out of any
in the games today is probably a tie
between aronian very solid slight
advantage that he has against Hammer
that he loves playing he loves nurturing
this kind of positions and winning in
very technical style and in the game uh
mvl against toala I really really like
Black's chances it's not necessarily
true that Black's better but to me it's
more natural to come up with nice
maneuver and interesting ideas for black
than it is to establish White's position
in any way shape or form well we did
find some insight into why queen1 might
have been played with the White's last
move 20 Bishop
D2 I guess there might be some cheapos
along this diagonal where a skewer might
happen Against The Rook but man that's a
little far-fetched at the moment I don't
know why the Bishop's on D2 let's
remember that this Knight that's
currently on C3 doesn't have that many
good squares to go to it doesn't want to
retreat to D1 or E2 I don't see how it
improves itself it would like to go to
A4 but for now there's Pawn on the way
and Knight D5 is always going to be
impossible as black has more than enough
control right and note that this bishop
A5 Cheapo as you call it um wouldn't
even work in that variation because the
Knight and can simply interpose in
B6 right I mean if white does establish
the bishop on A5 even if you do play
Knight B6 it seems like it's a little
victory for the Frenchman right but not
if we have have to lose a pawn along the
way by playing Knight
D5 that's true that's that's a good
point the Knight D5 wouldn't be
sufficient compensation just to
establish a bishop on A5 so we're going
to have to see how mvl really tries to
treat this position the bishop on D2 to
me seems a little awkward and I already
I'm liking Black's chances in this POS
in this game yeah the Knight on C3 is
awkward that's a problem we really need
like we want to kind of play B4 or
Bishop A5 or A4 and a lot of our plans
are disrupted by this Knight on C3 right
it doesn't seem as harmonious as I would
like it it's an important Bastion of
White's position because it establishes
defense over the E4 Pawn but it itself
is kind of on the way the bishop on D2
wants to go to A5 The Rook wants to come
to C1 and attack on the C file and it
just seems like the Knight
well thank you for your service but come
on move to G3 or somewhere where you're
doing the same thing but you're not in
the way of the pieces maybe he's
thinking about sacrificing at some well
at some point trying to play the move
B4 um with the idea of
95 I think at some point mvl is going to
have to sacrifice something so your idea
of B4 is definitely something that will
enter his mind the problem is how to do
it in the way that he gets compensation
I don't see any logical followup for
white that doesn't involve a sacrifice
of something that's right so something
with B4 Knight D5 opening up the files
on you know the bishop on C2 will be
taboo for the moment because of Rook C1
that kind of thing but because of that
toala might choose to make a a typical
move that you would make when you Queen
High Castle which is to play King B8
just to get his King off of the line of
fire we had seeing this idea of King B8
as Maurice was mentioning of course King
B8 doesn't allow me to establish this
Knight as quickly as I wanted on D4
which is one of the ideas I thought was
very logical in the position even though
the computer doesn't come up with it
then maybe the idea of playing Knight D5
is more feasible but even here you can't
black on B6 anymore right but even here
this looks um a little dubious taking on
D5 taking on D5 and ideas of E4 really
make me worried for White's position I
think that this initiative that I gain
with the Bishops on the king side might
be a little bit too much I don't think
the tactics work out for you if you play
Bishop A5 no not even close so this
looks bad if this doesn't work I like
that move Knight B6 sorry Knight B8
gunning for us Knight C6 also taking
control over the A5 Square temporarily
and trying to establish the Knight on a
superb Square on D4 in the Geary game
between Carlson and gir we do have a
couple of more moves as I think I
mentioned a little while ago giri did
play the move G6 with the idea of
establishing a bishop on H6 just
securing the fact that he has control
over the file and it's going to be
annoying for Carlson to find moves but
if somebody can come up with ideas in a
position that looks absolutely dry that
would be Carson and if you give him an
extra Pawn to do so I think he's going
to at least try to pressure giri somehow
he's going to first remove uh Black's
pieces from the Queens head that are so
Runing how he does that exactly well
we're going to have to see his technique
for
it and uh
Maurice yeah I've been looking at that
game as well Alejandro and I'm looking
at the C4 Square it looks like this
maneuver of course KN F1 is perfect
forget about this side of the board and
Knight had nothing to do with over there
but it looks like a Transit point to the
C4 square and that seems like it's not
so hard to accomplish I mean if you just
put the Knight on D2 this Pawn cannot be
captured because obviously Rook a B1 uh
picks off this bishop that's a done deal
but what can black do to stop an idea of
a knight landing on this Square now my
thought was bankco style
compensation Bishop usually has this
great diagonal for the bko this bishop
here trading itself for for a night
doesn't seem that impressive impressive
but the engine say against A5 trying to
hold black course trying to hold white
down white can still play this move B4
because again this trade doesn't work
because of the bishop hanging on B7 so
that tactical moment is a problem so
that means after you take on B4 The Rook
can go somewhere it could maybe C3 let's
not be too aggressive and drop it back
and now the Knight goes to
C4 this position I'm not sure about
because now the bishop is guarding this
The Rook is guarding this bishop so
maybe not as strong a position but when
you look suddenly this move and the
queen is starting to look a little funky
or maybe maybe another move here uh
after Queen takes B4 maybe the other
Rook I'm not sure I'm looking at
variations and it's it's uncertain maybe
he could have just held the pawn instead
but the point is that right here this
the fact that this Knight can get to
C4 guarding the pawn at least maybe
advancing Maybe maybe now you look you
see where black is thinking of his
compensation that this Pawn on A5 could
restrain white somehow but you feel like
he's just a step away from just being
down a clean Pawn that this file won't
matter so much especially if this
becomes the dominant factor and if a
knight lands on C4 for sure the file
means nothing at all and I feel like
white will just take maybe four moves
four or five moves by Magnus Carlson to
prove that he's just up a pawn and that
he's going to win his first game guys
well a bold prediction definitely but a
pawn is a pawn Magnus went away a
different approach to getting the Knight
on to C4 he went through E3 instead giri
didn't bother on taking the Knight which
she could have on E3 he decided he
wanted to keep his Bishop there so he
didn't swap the bishop for the Knight
and instead he played a very quick A5 so
I'm going to go ahead and assume that he
has a good idea prepared against the
move Knight C
4 but that looks pretty logical to me
you put the Knight on C4 if I play the
move Queen B3 I'm slightly worried again
about the ideas of bringing this knight
from F3 to D2 this queen well it's not
very comfortable it probably has to
Black probably has to trade on D2 I take
with the Knight and again this ideas of
Queen takes B2 are still no longer
possible because as Maurice has shown us
over and over this Rook can come to B1
uh skewer the queen to the bishop and
that seems lethal therefore the queen
should Retreat as if the bishop wasn't a
problem enough being hemmed in and not
being able to to move right it's not
sufficient that it's a bad Bishop it's
also on the way of me actually doing
something because I have to protect it
you're right this bishop is a
liability well and that's why a lot of
the times in the Roy Lopez although I
know this wasn't Roy LZ it looks like on
but uh when white does play D5 a lot of
times it's in variations with the bishop
on B7 because the bishop really would
prefer to be on C8 in these lines or D7
just anywhere where it's at least not
being targeted by your opponent
absolutely I think that in this kind of
positions the bishop on B7 is Black's
worst piece and it's going to show
because it gives Magnus just about
enough time to try to get a knight to C4
and if he manages to staish this Knight
on C4 it's going to be very difficult
for giri to prove that he actually has
some compensation even in certain
scenarios where the queen side is simply
liquidated and uh giri manages to
recover a pawn suddenly a knight on C4
is a very strong piece it attacks the
pawn on D6 allows the Rooks to come in I
think that Carlson might find a way to
solidify his position and
establish a
pawn majority on the queen side that
should be
enough and we've got Maurice with some
thoughts in another game no actually I
want to seeck with this game this is
pretty critical because the moment is
now for Magnus to be able to play this
move C four so if we back up to uh This
Moment sorry here the move A5 B4 is
definitely on tap I mean again we see
that the trade and trade cannot play
Queen takes because of Rook to B1 so
what else can he do if he drops his Rook
back then suddenly a move like B5 is in
effect and the pawn is now on B5 it's
not it's not back at B2 sweating it's
sitting on B5 and there no easy tactics
for BL to prove anything at all it's
just a defended Pawn this bishop looks
completely ridiculous what is black
going to do so after this move Knight E3
A5 B4 takes takes he could also try to
move uh Rook to
C3 in this position and now he could
consider B5 again but I think B5 is
probably a problem after Bishop takes on
E3 and now we see some tactics starting
to emerge on this line might be a little
scary for white uh having to take with
the queen or take with the pawn you see
the pin is starting to be a real issue
here so instead of that after Rook to C3
the move Knight to C4 is again playable
testing black will he take the pawn well
he could think about taking the pawn and
I'll take a look at this line Rook ab1
I'd like to win a piece bam suddenly a
queen sacrifice like out of nowhere if
you take here Rook takes now Rook takes
B4 and when you look at this position it
looks quite odd the imbalance you've got
a a rook a rook and Bishop for queen
here with the structure all on one side
is this better for white significantly
better for white is the queen enough to
win the game this would be a really
interesting position for giri to play
and say to Magnus I don't think you can
win this position although this weak
Pawn on D6 does give you pause I mean
maybe this bishop can guard it and make
it very difficult for the queen to show
the weakness we know that when you have
a queen against a rook and Bishop it's
extremely important that the queen finds
weaknesses and here it's not that
obvious so this is a critical position
for Magnus to analyze if he looks at the
move B4 right now maybe he'll just
decide to be a bit more patient but no
question he's studying this move as it
is definitely on tap in the position
guys that's a fascinating line Maurice
thank you and yeah in addition to
needing weaknesses when you have the
queen you also really need uh an unsafe
King to kind of work away at you at
least need something to Target the
problem is the queen doesn't create much
by itself it needs to be already
attacking something that was weakened by
other pieces in this case in that
variation that Maurice was showing us I
just think black's too solid with only
one weakness on D6 and even the capacity
and certain variations of bringing this
bishop around but he has made a move it
look like it was towards the the queen
side did he play B4 he did play B4 all
right so we might see a queen sacrifice
in this position if for example after
Pawn takes B4 Pawn takes B4 the
variation we're looking at here is Rook
C3 correct Knight which looks like the
most logical move to me if I cannot take
on B4 Knight C4 and then well it seems
like my arm's been twist I have to play
this I just have to play Queen takes
before before I cannot imagine that I
can Retreat and claim any real
compensation if the Knight goes to A5
that's right and now and now we get this
forcing line where you have this forcing
line rather than giving up the bishop on
B7 you take take on C4
and now let's analyze a little bit
because I'm not forced to take this
queen right I'm assuming there's
something wrong with taking my rook in
this
position I would play Queen takes C4 I
think is forced yeah Queen takes C4 and
then after takes C4 Rook takes C4 Rook
takes B7 E4 hangs in the end of this
variation and I guess in this position
black should have enough resources to
somehow hold the draw there's a problem
with D5 Pawn being two we again we're
very solid and we've picked up a pawn
right this doesn't seem like it's
something giri should be too worried
about so perhaps it is better to take
the queen even though I still think that
in this position uh black should be okay
I mean I don't think that white has the
pieces he would want to have the bishop
on D3 is not a very good piece it's
already hemmed in by his own pawns uh
there's no dark Square control from
White which is a big problem especially
if we're trying to Target D6 right and
this bishop I mean worst case scenario
it goes back to f8 and it defends D6 for
the rest of its life best case scenario
it finds a way to maneuver into C5 where
it defends the pawn on D6 and attacks a
very weakened F2 so I mean don't count
out Black's activity whereas White's
plans I mean they don't come to me as
naturally I can't even think of a plan
for why exactly I mean maybe we'll throw
in H4 but yeah I don't he doesn't really
lead anything no I don't I don't see too
much here for white I mean of course
it's white that has the chances of
winning I don't see black actually
forcing it's all totally forced let's go
back it's not totally forced it does
look likely though but maybe that end
maybe that other end game The Exchange
down one leaves more potentials look at
that again sure after Bishop takes C4
you mean yes Queen takes C4 seems forced
I imagine that I should take on C4 let's
try taking on B7
first uh let's see I have to take on
after now after taking on E2 and
throwing in a check on C1 we're also
going to well you have Knight you don't
really have Knight E1 because then we
have this bishop D2 which is Bishop D2 I
can play King F1 I was thinking I was
going to win E4 back but obviously this
is under way better circumstances for
you right so this is that be pretty bad
actually a little bit of finicia here
for let try again right so the question
becomes after Queen takes C4 uh Rook
takes B7 immediately what is Rook takes
B7 immediately before we were looking at
Queen C4 Rook C4 Rook B7 and then Knight
E4 and it seems like Black's doing
pretty well so it just goes to show that
everybody is prone to this like looking
all the most forcing moves right yes so
this one seems a bit better
but I don't see any way of recovering
the pawn immediately I mean there is
obviously some pressure in this position
but there might be some trick I'm just
missing it well maybe the problem is you
just can't defend E4 because if we take
on we lose time but if we just take on
E2 and then play Rook C4 how are you
defending it mm very cold blooded but
it's possible especially because the
Rook on E2 now doesn't guard the first
rank which might cost white a Tempo so
after Rook C4 I simply recover the pawn
on the next move again which is similar
to the very similar to the same
variation we looked at absolutely and
hey if I get the E4 Pawn D5 is going to
be weak I think it might be also okay
for
giddy yeah this looks okay and uh
Maurice your thoughts where which line
do you think Magnus will
choose well I don't think Magnus has the
real problem I think giri has the real
problem here Magnus is saying I'm up a
pawn you're going to have to get it back
or prove some kind of compensation
actually compensation now means
sacrificing something the queen or an
exchange something in the position so
it's all on giri now to find all those
variations and Magnus can just sit back
and say so which one do I think I can
win maybe he can't win any of them but
take a look at one that may be promising
for him after this line after the trade
a B4 takes takes and Rook C3 Knight C4
so we're looking at the move Queen takes
B4 and the engine woring away there's
different ways to play here but the one
I think might be the best one is Rook e
to
B1 and after the sacrifice take take on
C4 trade down and take on B7 this way
now that looks like it gives away the
pawn immediately but the problem is F7
in this line in the other line when The
Rook was on E1 F7 wasn't a Target at all
in this position it is if the Rook gets
down here to A7 suddenly the seventh
rank is exposed so H4 now and the
argument starts the plan is to play
double Rooks grab this pawn and then
it's going to be total harassment
forever so the line being given is
Knight back to F6 preparing to attack
this Pawn also some tricky mating ideas
so G3 very solid keeping everything
under control and again looking after
Rook A7 that's a real threat now you
can't touch this Pawn because the rook's
dropping down so it looks like you have
to hight tail it back with Rook to C8
the Rooks double and guard the pawn that
changed the whole activity of Black's
position in a second but maybe it's not
enough Rook A6 is a line to look at here
Knight takes D5 Rook takes D6 and now
suddenly that G3 move becomes a big
factor cuz the Knight cannot go to F4
the knight in fact has to go into the
position to C3 but even now after Knight
takes E5 this looks very attractive for
white despite the pawns all being on one
side there seems to be some challenges
here for black maybe he can still hold
in some variation this is not the only
line obviously but that move Rook fb1
could be it and it turns out that giri
did not play Rook to C3 instead Gary
backed up in the game and played the
move Rook to C7 that that looks scary
does allow B5 now guys B5 is playable
without Rook on C3 and those possible
tactics and that's what I had said when
I said that's what I meant when I said
it's not really magnus's problem it's
more gir's problem to prove that he has
the compensation but if he can't do
anything after the move B5 right now
he's going to go down guys right it does
seem like B5 is a very strong move
because the blockade here is made by a
queen and a notoriously bad blockader
and the reason is that it's so powerful
that as soon as I attack it it must move
and therefore ripping apart the blockade
is not difficult to do it's going to be
interesting to see what giri has planned
uh to play after B5 he has several
choices he could start trying to uh
basically beg for a draw after Bishop
takes E3 trades off some pieces and try
to hold an endgame he could maybe try to
establish this Knight into a better
position by playing Knight D7 but it
doesn't matter what he does I definitely
think that Carlson has the much much
better chances basically a riskless
position in which he's pushing for a
win well that's exciting news for
Carlson fans well that's true we haven't
had much Pleasant news so far it's been
a difficult tournament for the norian
but hey it seems like he has a good
position here and he will definitely try
to push against Anish gidy um let's
check in on uh NBL all right seems like
we have a couple moves mvl and toala all
right so in the mvl topalo game after
the bishop D2 Queen C6 was played which
uh attacks the pawn on e4 right away it
doesn't give mvl any chance to take it
slowly it's B4 right I don't think B4 is
a threat because if well is it I was
thinking that B4 wasn't possible because
of Bishop A4 but I might just be able to
move back with my queen and there
there's still some problems on the pawn
anyway it seems like mvl thought there
was no issue Rook D1 was played and I
guess B4 is just not a very desirable
move sometimes you can even sacrifice a
pawn yeah also now with a rook on D1 we
have the Knight D5 idea looks a lot more
powerful definitely and after I take
take Queen takes Queen takes D5 I can
establish a discover here with Bishop
takes B4 or maybe even if I'm feeling
really frisky frisky yes Bishop takes
H6 we're going to take a look instead of
after this toal play Knight B6 move
that's very very nice in this position
specifically because I do have chances
of going to C4 and I'm covering the D5
Square again so now B4 seems to be a
threat it's going to be difficult for
mvl to find a move that protects against
everything yes this does look unpleasant
indeed for mvl yes
a struggle here for beash is vessel and
Topo looks to uh I think obje distance
from humanism bonent right I think
objectively this position must have
chances for both sides and I think that
if White's able to repeal some of the
incoming
threats that that'll be okay but I think
from a practical point of view Black's a
little bit better I agree it's very
difficult to play for right so let's go
over to Norway with Grandmaster yaser
saon who has a special guest for
us hello St Louis back here in Norway
I'm with JJ the tournament director of
Norway chess JJ nice meet you here on
the show you uh we want to talk a little
bit about how the tournament came into
being by the way I'm taking your night
and JJ no crying no tears it's not
permitted in chess there's no crying I
actually planned this yesterday oh you
did okay iMed recapt now tell us a bit
about the tournament how how did it come
into your mind that you well to make an
elite tournament it's not me who who
let's say came up with this idea it's um
a guy called shadan uh he's not a chess
player actually but his son is uh uh a
promising chess player and uh he thought
why don't we have um a super tournament
in Norway and then um I met him uh in
Oslo uh sometime in
20 uh in December 2011 MH where he
presented this idea to me uh I was at
that time also president of the Mion
Chess Federation so it was uh let's say
relevant for him to talk to me and I was
very U surprised to hear this uh that's
say dream yeah and and I must admit I I
still considered it a dream after I've
left the meeting MH but I was very
intrigued and uh I said yes uh I would
be happy to to help him with this and um
so it started the rest is history as
they say more less and of course um of
course what was crucial to the success
of the event without question is
magnus's participation that really helps
yes I think without Magnus um this would
have been uh fairly impossible okay one
of the things from me JJ that I'm
uh jealous about is the fact that here
in Norway you have Norwegian television
for hours at a time hours at a time
streaming the games live with Incredible
number of commentaries and all kinds of
things this is stunning how how did you
do that well I didn't do that either I
think well
[Laughter]
I think uh Magnus uh deserves
99 something for credit for that as well
um I think it was during the first world
championship match um television decided
to broadcast the
whole every game in the whole time and
that was a remarkable success uh more
than No 1 million Norwegian people
watched this at the same time at one
moment how many people live in Norway 5
million so you're saying 20% of the
population followed the television
program my goodness in America that
would mean 64 million people it's
incredible there's your potential wow
and obviously with the success of that
it would lead me to my next question is
Norway chess 2015 you're missing a title
sponsor yeah yes but I hope that this
sponsor will come for the Norway Jess
2016 of course that would be very nice
in the television as well as the
newspaper coverage here also which is
phenomenal I mean okay Magna starts with
a loss and it was front page news in in
the way he lost and it was a shock and
then the second loss and now everybody
is talking here can he the legend of
Magnus can only grow if he makes a
recovery that would be incredible as
well yeah well Magnus is uh very good in
coming back or anything think yes in
true so I think that um of course the
interest now will be uh it's like a race
where uh one of the guys lacked behind
from the start but now he's starting to
chase the others right and so if he
manages to win the tournament people
would be uh extremely happy at this when
norion would be no question about it and
your overview of the grand chest tour
itself what is your what would you say
is your vision that you share with the
other organizers where are we evolving
no I I think that uh all three of us has
a dream to uh bring chess even higher up
um both in status uh among sponsorships
amongst television companies or internet
companies to bring out chess to the the
people as much and as good as possible
Wonderful by the way since you didn't
move I'm making two moves in a row
no as chess
Grandmasters you take my pone I'm not
used to receiving gifts you see and I'm
not used to giving
them what are you
doing uh I'm not here to embarrass JJ so
I'll let you guys get back to your show
ah look at this you want to trade Queens
huh let's just take a look at the
position and count the P yes but you
know I have a
compensation ooh I need that don't
you you're right Yas is going down I
don't know man I have a bad record
against yaser I wouldn't bet against
him so we have some interesting
developments actually in some of the
games uh we're going to first take a
look at the longest thing of the round
the tournament so far maybe the
tournament I don't really want to be
keeping track of this one but of course
there is no doubt about who that honor I
guess belongs to it is definitely
Alexander Guk who took about 45 minutes
to come up with the move Queen B6 who
was it that called him slow in the one
word descriptions I think that was Gary
right it was it was Gary yeah yeah you
know uh Magnus called him perfectionist
a perfectionist which is kind of like a
euphemism for all right well then you
could you could take it that way he's
definitely a hard worker over the board
he might just be working a little too
hard well yeah I think that's what
Magnus meant Queen B6 is an interesting
move with the other idea we had
mentioned was F4 G4 and F3 with with
crazy complications it's not exactly
position where you shouldn't take your
time you should definitely analyze a lot
of variations but but over almost an
hour yeah 45 minutes though you should
never ever ever do that there's no
reason to take that much time well
unless your Gritz truck and then Queen
B6 was played and of course the move
makes sense it adds pressure on to the
B5 Pawn this diagonal B6 to G1 will be
annoying for white Black's uh pressure
will be annoying for the king that's
eventually going to land on G1 so the
move makes a lot of sense just probably
there wasn't any need to think about it
for this long it's probably an okay move
I would think that F4 is more forcing
and it's something that I would have
preferred to play but Queen B6 also
looks like a powerful idea here in this
position another strange move that I
definitely did not foresee was that in
the mvl game we were mentioning how
Knight D5 really wasn't possible anymore
and well guess what he played he did
play Knight D5 he did play Knight is
working out well it doesn't work uh I
think at all the problems in this
position are well first of all he did
take with Knight takes D5 on the B side
e takes D5 and now I don't think I can
take the pawn immediately I think
there's some issues if I take with the
Knight then Bishop B4 perhaps the
blockade here is a little Annoying the
pins a little Annoying Bishop A5 ideas
are annoying but one of the biggest
problems with making a sacrifice and
calculating it accurately is that not
only do you have to calculate all the
lines with the sacrifice but you also
have to calculate what if they just
reject your sacrifice and in this case
it's not so much that I'm rejecting the
sacrifice it's like your Pawn is weak
I'm going to take it later don't don't
rush me I got this the problem is that
after Queen D7 there's no good followup
here for um mvl there are some real
threats here E4 for example is very
powerful when the pawn establishes
itself on e4 the Knight on F3 is kicked
I can even try to make progress by
pushing so Bishop A5 leads to nothing
because of just Bishop C7 right the
bishop A5 move doesn't lead anywhere
because Bishop C7 blocks and now after
Bishop takes C7 you can simply take with
the queen I think taking with the
everything is protected everything's
protected E5 is protected E4 is being
threatened this oppent is doomed um it
seems like an extra Pond to me for
topalo some minor positional
compensation but I don't buy it I think
that after Queen D7 MBL is in some
problems absolutely and in speaking of
people that are in problems I think giri
will be giving us quite a long think
here as he to
B5 that's right so we're seeing some uh
some really dominant positions here as
we get into the thick of the first time
control we'll the pressers continue to
you know press the position and um and
win their games or will all sorts of
craziness happen I think there's going
to be a series of decisive games we
haven't even looked at the Nakamura game
in a while simply because there's so
much interest in three of them right we
thought that was dry from the Geto it is
still dry uh but I think that livening
up a bit it's livening up in the other
boards at least that's right all right
well um stay tuned round three of the
grand chest tour Norway chest 2015 we've
got lots of Rich positions today and
stay with us as we approach the second
time
[Music]
draw
n
[Music]
e
n
[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the world
chest tour we've got Norway chess 2015
on tap round three um Magnus cron our
world chess champion against an gur can
he get on the scoreboard in the grand
chest
tour we are going to keep a close eye on
this game but first massive drama that's
going on in Maxim Basher lra's game
against toala is white just going down
drama that's very nice this seems like a
tragedy for the French player this is
very very bad position and it turned
ugly in just a couple of moves we left
off the position after this Knight D5
move which we thought well this doesn't
really make sense I don't think that he
has to take the pawn immediately he's
going to retreat to D7 and he did and in
this position the pawn on D5 seems
doomed I expected Maxim to try to create
some kind of positional bind some kind
of positional compensation open up the
Queen side do something in order to
justify the fact that your Pawn on on D5
will fall sooner rather than later and
instead he played this move Bishop A5
and Not only was Bishop C7 a good move
here but talo found this nice resource
E4 and the problem for white you don't
have time to take this Rook on d8
because after I take your knight on F3
everything's hanging that's right we're
goingon to get the bishop on d8 and the
Knight on F3 right because there's a
pressure on the queen on E1 not to
mention that even the positional
compensation granted by Pawn takes G2
would be tremendous over they would be
just completely winning black would have
the material and the
compensation so in this case after E4
Maxim almost immediately just retreated
the Knight to G1 but this is the current
position on the board with conviction
Knight G1 Knight G1 that piece is
absolutely
terrible white species aren't doing
anything and this is the main problem uh
his only threatening piece is this
bishop on A5 but after the simple Bishop
C7 preventing the Bishop from taking the
Rook I just don't see a move for black
in this for white in this position black
has very obvious ideas you want to play
E3 you want to capture this Pawn on D5
there's pressure down this diagonal at
some point what where's where's White's
plan I I don't see it I don't get it
there is no way to open up the queen
side successfully in the next few moves
if this Knight was on E6 I would think
that the position might be a little bit
more interesting but uh it's a little
far away from there well great start for
the grand chess tour for maxim bashier
lra but perhaps coming crashing down
today man also a very nice start from
topalo I think that even though he got
extremely lucky on the first round he
did played rather well yesterday I liked
his chances against Nakamura putting a
little bit of pressure here and there
but today it's it's basically like he
was gifted another point I don't
understand any of his moves look at his
posture here you don't usually see him
look like this he's looking at the sky
wishing maybe there was another position
he was playing up there I know I think I
think he's looking for a thunderbolt
just to land on him as he doesn't have
to play this position anymore it's that
bad you don't have any material deficit
but God your pieces are awful and your
structure is bad and your king is less
safe than your opponents he be nice I am
being nice I mean I I haven't did I say
we haven't got Maurice on it yet man
Maurice can rip apart the position even
further but I don't see any hope here
for for
maxim no a sad day for the Frenchman
Maurice what else is is blowing up
today well yeah we want to get out of
this position because it looks
completely ridiculous Knight to D5 was a
joke and now he's just getting rolled
and he should be I mean what kind of
move is that Knight
D5 but the game continues topalo on the
other hand you know you think about the
game H he won against Magnus total gift
like oh my couldn't be a better gift an
easier gift but here's another one just
a straight gift like uh 95 here take my
Pawn get get get a good position open up
the game in your favor everything is
going his way so far in this tournament
that draw he had yesterday was also a
game he was pressing trying to win but
of course Nakamura played very well the
other boards not much as happening in
fact and not much has transpired this
game with Magnus he did play a little
bit cool calm with the move H3 stopping
any knight from going to the G4 square
and then after this maneuver Queen C5
and Bishop H6 uh he puts Queen on B2 he
said I'm going to get behind this pawn
queen C5 Queen B6 doesn't leave a good
impression so again we think that Magnus
should be able to press this home but
the one thing he does have in his favor
does black is he has a dark Square
blockade at least for the moment it's
not so easy to disrupt this defense as
Queen sitting on B6 this Knight can
always be traded that means you're going
to need this Knight to get to C4 and
with some solidity in order to push this
queen away so there's some maneuvering
he does have to do there is some
technique he needs to press this home
for the moment it's clear he's up a pawn
but it's not obvious how to break the
dark Square blockade just yet another
board that showed a nice move happened
but I'm not sure it's a big Advantage is
this game between aronian and Hammer in
this position the queens were traded and
it's all about the pawn structure look
at White's Pawn structure a picture of
Harmony while if you look at the black
pawn structure you just want to gag well
if you see that you understand why G4
was played that was a nice move making
sure that Black's Pawn structure remains
terrible for a long time now this king
is thinking about going to G2 to F3 to
E4 at some point will that be enough to
win I'm liking White's chances although
the engines are saying that the game's
pretty close I I I would have thought no
busted it's actually giving triple zeros
here that the position is exactly equal
I can't imagine that being the case here
I believe white is much better uh in
this position looking for a win in this
game between Guk and Anan Guk spent some
time to play Queen B6 he didn't spend as
much time to play this move Rook to d8
after unon castled it does look as
though black has compensation because
he's going to play F4 at some point and
it looks very flexible for him it's one
of those positions where yes you have a
pawn yes your position's pretty good but
can you improve it in any way and again
it's that dark Square blockade we saw
this happen in the game with uh giri
there's the queen on B6 Pawn on B5 well
we switched to the other game with
grischuk there's that Queen on B6 Pawn
on B5 and in in both games black has a
bishop on H6 how curious is that we can
see it we go back just to show you again
there's that Bishop on 86 a dark Square
uh dominant piece and uh in this game
we're looking at now if I can find it
there it is again the bishop on 86 so
curious coincidence here Queen on B6
Pawn on B5 pass Bishop on 86 in both
cases and dark Square blockade trying to
make sure that the the white pieces
don't push that extra Pawn home so
interesting games in all of these
positions we'll see how white proceeds
to try to win in a couple of the
contests
guys definitely very interesting
situations that we have and I like that
dynamism with the blockades in different
games even though the queen does
different things they both have this
Pawn on B5 under lock and some pressure
down the diagonal A7 G1 so I like the
Symmetry between the games of Anan Guk
and Carlson
gidy yeah let's take a look at a non
game okay sure this is one of the has
finally moved he did play Queen B6 an an
castled because well at some point he
had to safeguard his King and then the
move Rook bd8 came into play a very
logical move that targets the pawn on D5
it's a pawn that is only really defended
by the Knight on C3 because I'm always
going to have the option of playing
Bishop E6 taking advantage of this spin
in order to further pressure the pawn
the question is of course that uh how am
I going to put or kick out the knight
from C3 that doesn't seem possible at
the moment so the pawn on D5 feels
pretty safe what Rook bd8 does challenge
Anan to do is as Maurice pointed out try
to come up with a way of improving your
position some of your position I mean it
lacks harmony with the rest for example
this Rook on A4 isn't really playing
well with the other Rook on F1 you would
like to coordinate them somehow but it's
not so obvious how you're going to do so
where are you going to put your queen
what is your Bishop on E2 going to be
doing besides defending the pawn on B5
there's a lot of incognito here about
peace placement I think and it's
something that an's going to have to be
solving in the next few moves and I
think partially what grischuk was
thinking about for 45 minutes was not so
much a specific moves but which approach
he wanted to take into the game whether
he wanted to force uh very tactical
complications soon or if he wanted to
just establish a position in which white
was up a pawn but he had the
compensation and it was up to White to
prove his Advantage now white just made
the move King
G2 King G2 looks in some ways natural it
does allow him to not be pinned down the
diagonal on the other hand I'm always
worried to have a king on G2 when the
light sored Bishop is on D7 there's
could be some F4 is in the air as well
right especially with F4 in the air
there are some tactical ideas in this
position I think that GIS chuk still is
okay so we're going to have to keep an
eye on how this be very exciting as this
continues you know uh G we mentioned it
again and again time pressure but only
16 moves left to make here 35 minutes oh
yeah for him this is an eternity so
he'll be he'll be
fine he might just think 25 minutes in
this move and then you have to eat words
Maurice some news in chala's game yes it
looks like the pawn is going to
disappear pretty quickly mvl did A
variation that just doesn't look that
impressive the move Bishop to C7 he
played the move D6 in response the pawn
looks dead right it's going to die why
not die this way well the problem is
after Bishop takes which happened in the
game Queen takes on A5 we're now
awaiting too's move but which move would
anybody play in this position just with
a flick of the wrist E3 I mean that's
just beasty and that move looks crushing
the threat of E2 in the position and if
you it looks like you have to high tail
it a move like Knight to E2 you might
call it a blockading piece is just a
terrible piece and the move Queen C6
threatening a one move mate and all your
position is just falling apart Rook to
F3 to stop the mate just runs into Rook
takes D6 Pawn's gone Pawn on E3 mating
attack it's all over but the crying mvl
is going to lose this game if topalov
just plays some normal moves and uh he
did it and he did play it and now 92 is
on the board this is just over and
topalov is relaxed and looking there he
knows he's got this one not much to
think about it's he in fact he was ready
to play the move you could tell he was
ready to play that killer move Queen C6
and he has played it again andv is very
close to resigning this game we're going
to see a decisive result quite quickly
here in this round uh and he has
resigned and he has resigned of course
terrible position for him horrible game
on his part guys really really bad game
he'll be disgusted at himself now how
can you not be the way that he lost
today was just without a fight it was
basically 17 moves of preparation he got
a position that we didn't think was that
Pleasant to begin with he played a
couple of bad moves after it and he lost
the game 10 moves after his preparation
was done poor Max and velin toab now
guaranteed at least a tie for first
going two and half out of three that is
not something I would have predicted had
after he got his first round position in
his first round position that's correct
I thought the Carlson would take that
game at least get a draw and then okay
you have two tough opponents in the next
couple of rounds scoring two out of two
would not have been easy but here he
made made it look like the simplest
thing in the world to beat maim vashir
lra and good chances for him to be in
the clear lead we as you see girri is
suffering and the only other people that
can catch up with him are not we a
Carana yeah has that game gotten more
exitting we've neglected for some time
let's take a look all right um two
American Heroes here okay that was
enough let's go to another
game there's hey there's a rook on F4
there's a rook on exciting indeed if
this bishop moves Kar gets checkmated of
course there's absolutely no reason
to to move the bishop at this looks
pretty dry I don't see anything being
EST you don't see any chances here no
and you can tell from the last move
which was Rook C2 and if you ask me what
Rook C2 they're just shuffling things
around it probably looks like it I don't
see any way of making progress can white
play for B4 in this position if you get
B4 in good for you you still haven't
accomplished anything the problem is
that unlike most most English setups
where B4 liberates your pieces there are
no pieces to liberate you already traded
them all off so once you play B4 you
don't have enough pieces remaining to
actually do any kind of attack on the
queen side yeah I see what you're saying
what if we play for
G4 well first of all if he if you wanted
to play for G4 you would have done it
right away second it's just a weakening
move on the king side because after you
play G4 I mean you have an idea of
playing G5 which is not particularly
subtle I have the feeling K would see it
and this is a blitz move it's perhaps a
bullet move I would be more accurate and
after Queen D5 uh Queen trade then G5
doesn't this is just a weakness not just
it's just a weakness because you put a
Pawn on H4 that cannot be defended by
another Pawn a pawn that's very Advanced
on G5 blocking your own Bishop so this
seems more like Hope Chest than anything
else uh although I would play it on a
bullet game you're right about that one
Rook C2 was was played in order so that
Queen D5 takes takes I don't have to
worry about a bishop taking on B2 so
perhaps I here I can go B4 but as I said
even that position I'm not too scared of
there must be some way of equalizing
here with black without too many
problems but anyone's pressing his
white
um I mean it's just equal in my opinion
I don't think anybody will be pressing
this
position and another game Maurice Ashley
got it well something is not quite right
in the game between Magnus Carlson and
Anish giri you know there's a principle
in chess that when you have the two
Bishops against a bishop and a knight
one of the advantages is that more often
than not you can trade your Bishop for a
knight at some point to trade away your
two Bishop's Advantage for some
initiative it's usually easier for a
bishop to take a knight than a knight to
take a bishop obviously because the the
bishop is a free ranging piece he can
always run away from the Knight while
the Knight when it's pinned down by a
bishop which often happens sometimes
just has to be traded and can't avoid
being traded and in this position giri
has a very interesting sequence that
might highlight that Advantage remember
we talked about his Bishop on the board
well it's been eyeballing this night for
some time now and it's this moment where
he might be able to play this move
Bishop takes on
E3 if Rook takes which seems the most
logical cohesive move the engine saying
fe3 might be better which of course
looks really ugly to human eyes
but Rook takes E3 Knight to F4 now and
this Knight is on a good s you might
wonder well why did he Trade It Off In
This Moment well he's trying to eyeball
this Pawn making it less uh have less
security because the bishop is hanging
what's the most natural move here Bishop
to F1 and now suddenly the move F5
remember you couldn't play this move
because a knight was sitting here a
second ago which is why you needed to
trade it but now after F5 suddenly the
legs have been kicked out under this D
pawn and it's not so easy to figure out
how to defend it for example a move like
Knight G5 I just take and this Pawn is
hanging after Knight takes of course
there is Knight takes on D5 well it's
not really a fort because he can be
pinned and the king gets out of the pin
and you might say well is black worse
here I don't think black is much worse
the engines are saying yeah well maybe
after this move it starts to get
interesting and now the tactics flare up
with Rook to C4 and all kind of
craziness is breaking loose maybe this
is still better for white but this
variation is really tricky and he could
take this moment to trade because
otherwise he might just get sat on in
the position so you might see this
happen Bishop E3 Knight F4 F5 in the
position and you can bet giri is
eyeballing this option very closely
because otherwise he might again get
ground down by this world champion guys
and I like this idea with Bishop E3
followed by F5 very much and I think
that's precisely the reason that ft C3
makes so much
sense in essence you have a secondary
Pawn on the E file that you can maybe
push later to E4 if F5 ever happens in
order to reinforce the center yet again
even though the pawn on E3 looks very
ugly visually the idea is that after I
move the king off the diagonal and put
it on H2 this Knight on H5 is going to
suffer it could go to F4 immediately but
in this line after I play Bishop F1
notice that I cannot take the Knight
because of the pin and in the next move
I simply move my king away I'm kind of
left wondering ing well where's this
Knight on F4 going to go I think that F
takes C3 would be the most powerful move
in that position and I can see why the
engines want to take with the pawn it
does remind me of a pawn structure that
we saw here in the US championship
between uh Sam Shanklin and Wesley so in
that case Wesley won a game based on
this Pawn structure and a blunder by
Shanklin late in the game but of course
a big difference here is that this Pawn
on B5 is a big Menace giving a white
advant
Vantage um one game we haven't seen in a
little while um aonan vers Hammer aonan
Hammer is quite interesting and I was
very surprised when Maurice mentioned
that the engines think yeah Black's okay
to me visually this looks horrible for
black his pawns are a mess white
controls the C file there's a very clear
plan for white that is to attack the D4
Pawn bring the king in it seems a lot
easier to play this position with white
so the question becomes why why engines
why do you think this is okay for black
and the more you analyze it the more you
realize they're just cold blooded
Defenders what they want to do is
solidify their position and say I'm okay
you don't have any real targets after F5
which I think was a very important move
in this position there's a couple of
problems for aonian in making progress
if I take on F5 then after King F6 I'm
going to be able to recuperate this Pawn
without any real problems and suddenly
the activation of the king means that
White's own King will have its
difficulties entering the battlefield
the issue here is if I simply play H3
after King G2 King F3 again my king is
not going to go anywhere because this
Pawn has established itself as a barrier
for the white king it cannot pass it
cannot attack the D4 Pawn so Aon is
going to have to come up with something
slightly clever in order to make
progress and yet another important point
of the move F uh F5 is that it allows
the bishop to go to F6 in order to
defend the pawn on D4 if it's ever
necessary it was mentioned a very very
long time ago the one weakness is not
enough for a win and it seems like
besides the D4 PA Aron is going to have
to Target something else just that
something else isn't coming to my mind
just yet so will Hammer's defensive
skills be up to it today what do you
think I think that he's going to have to
try to prove uh that he's a a defensive
caliber of these guys and that's not
something that's particularly easy to
do
Maurice well it turns out actually as
you look at this position with Carlson
uh and and uh giri that maybe bishop E3
is actually forced maybe there's no
other move to play the problem after
Queen B4 that Carlson has basically
stared his opponent in the face and said
guess where this night is going I'm
going to C4 once this happens your
position collapses completely for one
thing after Knight C4 let's make a
random move totally random like Bishop
G7 after Knight to C4 what are you going
to do about your D6 Pawn Queen's under
attack it has nowhere to go Queen C5
would be the only move to guard the PA
actually just the only move for the
queen period and now Queen takes Queen
this Pawn is hanging are you going to
play this position this is over this is
over dominant night two pass pawns upper
Pawn Rook A7 everybody coming in forget
it you can't play this move at all so
that means after Queen B4 Magnus has
made a cold blooded threat Knight C4 you
might have to sack The Exchange in that
position just to keep the game going and
that's going to be bad so Knight C4 is
on tap there is no other move Bishop E3
must be played we expect to see giri
play this move and go for that position
you talked about Alejandro I like more
and more what you're talking about with
fe3 except the bad Pawn structure but
control some key squares and then this
other horsey is going to come around to
the C4 Square so this idea by Magnus
might actually be pressing giri quite a
bit to prove to him hey what you got
your pieces are scattered the only thing
you've got is these two Rooks but these
miners are nothing I'm up a pawn of my
Knight's headed to C4 this may be a
significant Advantage for white after
all and giri looks like he's in a lot of
trouble even after the trade on E3 it
certainly feels like ge's failed to
prove any real compensation and he's
going to be forced to defend a very
uncomfortable position he's down a pawn
and he has to just try to prevent white
from making progress instead of putting
pressure in the position as he was doing
when he just sacrificed the pawn when he
had those major pieces on the queen side
currently it's white that's moving his
pieces to the queen side that he's using
his Pawn on B5 to establish a lot of
space so it seems like giri's plan
whatever it was when he sacrificed the
Pawn has clearly failed and now he has
to defend passively which is not
something that's going to be fun being
down upon
Pawn no not at all so unpleasant
position here for giri um meanwhile
toala already at the lead of the grand
chest tour and Norway chess 2015 and has
moved up to number three on the live
chess rank games with his victory that
means he passes Nakamura I believe
that's right because kowana um jumped up
to number two from yesterday's win right
and I expect Karana Nakamura to retain
their ratings I believe they don't
change with a draw against each other
since they are so close therefore tapalo
would be in the Life rating list number
three in the world and I don't think
anybody can catch him right not in this
game at least not in this game um if
Anan wins Anan is currently at
28036 and that would be insufficient yes
catch he would catch Naka but not toal I
believe so and let's take a quick look
at how that game is progressing because
even though uh Anan has an extra Pawn
it's definitely not as clear as Carlson
and he has some weaknesses in this
position I really like uh Gris shuk's
last move played Bishop to C8 and it's a
move that allows him to reroute this
bishop into a very threatening uh
position and it puts a question mark on
the previous move that from manand he
played the move King G2 and he's like
dude I'm going to put my Bishop in the
same diagonal what are you going going
to do about it and suddenly this spin
would become really uncomfortable that
Bishop on D7 that maybe was not the best
piece is coming to B7 to establish
itself as a powerful attacker down this
diagonal and meanwhile again the the
time pressure is an issue here for
grea it's not so bad right now we still
have uh 16 moves to make but at 34
minutes I think G is going to be quite
comfortable and now needs to start
putting some pressure over the board if
he wants to create anything it seems
like uh even though Hammer might be
slightly slightly worse and gir is
definitely under some pressure everybody
else seems to be in an okay position so
we have some interesting Rook Maneuvers
here by nakamora in the game against
carolana I know you keep saying how dry
it is but I I have faith that something
interesting is going to happen in this
game yes misguided faith is is dangerous
and in this case after the move Rook F3
which was the last move played what is
that move why Rook F3 why not was there
a threat well uh Bishop maybe he wants
to maybe he wants to just make make
space for his Bishop so then he can play
Bishop G5 so that could be a little
threat I guess Bishop G5 could be a
little bit of a threat even then I'm not
entirely sure that there would be much
uh but because you you're saying you
could just play King G7 I could probably
just play King G7 or defend the bishop
in pretty much any manner and even the
double Pawns in that position want to be
a big deal although that would give us a
little something to chew on you know we
could play Bishop takes F6 and H5
and claim that life is better for us
than you well the problem here is that
it's not so easy for white to coordinate
his Rooks he's not going to have any
chance once he puts his Rook to F3 it's
hard that's one of the deficits of it
right right even though karon is not
threatening anything I mean Nakamura
isn't showing any plan to make his own
position so how else to defend against
Bishop G5 well I was thinking maybe the
move Rook D5 was possible I don't see
why this would be a bad move uh you
could play Bishop G5 and takes if you
take on G5 I cannot take immediately but
I could you play6 simply and this looks
really good for black this G5 Pawn
suddenly a little bit weak yeah so Rook
E5 looks like a good move right and if
you get clever with E4 I'm sure that I
have several Alternatives in this
position but even the simple Retreat the
bishop takes and queen E5 seems to even
give black a very pleasant position
after I recover the pawn on D5 I don't
see why I wouldn't I don't see why I
would be afraid of this even though I'm
down the exchange this Pawn on D3 is
just way too weak this bishop is
powerful on B2 so you're writing off
nakamura's chances here what about but
what's going on in his head do you think
he thinks he has some chances here or
you think he's frustrated I think no no
he's not frustrated he's a very
practical IC player I think he's right
now seeing the position like it's about
equal I'm going to create some threats
here and there I probably expect Kara to
play well if he plays well great we'll
draw if he doesn't play well great I'll
put some pressure all right so let's see
how that materializes and we are going
to take a quick
break
I'm I'm Mike maeni whether you play
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis right here in the chess capital
of the US from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over a 100 Schools our
Center across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame and the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to
offer
2014 was a great year for chess chess 24
brought you live interactive broadcasts
from Top tournaments a Play Zone where
you can take on opponents from all
around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your Chess By solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos chess 24 on mobiles
and tablets most features are free but
limited for registered members chess 24
is offering a special premium membership
for just $999 per month or $99 per year
see you at chess24.com
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor
louis.com
[Music]
and we do have a front runner at the
Grand chest tour and it's a surprise
part that's right a player that
established himself as a elite for years
and years and years and still shows that
he can play at the top level of Chess a
very aggressive player uh he's taken
very different route to his games in
every single round so far in the grand
chess tour but hey he has two and a half
out of three he's the leader and he's
done an amazing
job there are of course a lot of
interesting games still going on but but
it does seem like the other people that
currently have one and a half out of two
and could potentially catch besseling
talo it doesn't seem likely that they
will do so uh first mvl well man he had
a tough loss against toala himself so
yeah he can't get to two and a half
that'll be pretty difficult that's how
that's how chess Works uh Nakamura and
and Carlson and sorry and Carana seem to
be going towards a relatively dry
position and even though blunders do
happen in chess even though the the top
level we expect this game the very top
level right we expect this to go into a
draw and the only other player would be
Anish giri but he seems to be suffering
rather than looking for a win as he
plays Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces that's right so it looks like our
front runner will be topal up after this
round Maurice let's not speak too soon
guys something big has happened on the
game between Nakamura uh and karwana in
this position we saw Nakamura play this
weird move Rook to F3 kind of boxing his
rook in well he had a point the move
Rook to to D5 was played very strong
very solid by Fabiano and now Bishop G5
is on the board Bishop to G5 really
amping up the tension in the position
Bishop takes G5 is playable uh has not
yet been played in fact was not played
Bishop takes G5 was playable followed by
the move E4 as you mentioned Alejandro
this was possible the engines are saying
in this line instead of the simple
Bishop F6 take on H4 rip that pawn off
and this move just makes the game wild
of course taking on H4 would be possible
allowing Queen takes F7 check that seems
completely unnecessary in this position
after King moves the engines are saying
this is an equal position one of those
you got to be kidding why do we play
like this positions well instead of
going to that line at all after Bishop
to
G5 Carana quickly played Queen to D6
allowing Nakamura in this position to
trade on F6 and in this line the Ines
are saying that black is the one who is
better in this position interesting
allowing his Pawn structure to be
compromised on this side but he does get
an attack down the E file suddenly his
Pawn might end up on the F5 square and
then everything can just exit stage
right well my right his left for black
and then go down that eile and look for
some play so the game has changed
complexion dramatically we may indeed
see a decisive result in this position
after after all guys well I think that
karan's position would be slightly
preferable if he does take on F6 but
again he's not forced to do so I
wouldn't be completely surprised if he
simply moves the bishop back and the
status cool is there to retain but okay
he put the bishop on G5 I guess he'll
take because you put it on G5 right uh
that being said after Bishop takes F6
Pawn takes F6 I would rather be black a
little bit simply because you get some
pressure down the file and the Rooks are
much better coord ordinated for black
than for white but then uh black has the
same problem that white had recently
which is how to make progress in this
position okay so I threaten a couple of
Pawns here and there he's going to
defend them and then what am I going to
do I still think this is going to go
towards a drawish position but I do
agree that if I have to be given a
choice I would take the black pieces and
Bishop takes F6 e takes F6 has a curve
okay so we do have that on the board and
I would rather be black but not by very
much
on speaking of moves that well seems
like they had to be played uh in the
Carlson against gidy game gidy did go
ahead and take on E3 which we were
talking about seemed forced uh to do so
because of the threat of Knight C4
coming into play and we expect here that
Carlson takes actually with the
unnatural looking F takes E3 crippling
his own Pawn structure in order to gain
control over the F4 square and in order
to not allow a knight in to establish
itself in such a powerful position so
that's what we're expecting here but has
he played it yet he hasn't played it
he's thinking about it but it it seems
like the variations that start with
knight uh Rook E3 Knight F4 are so bad
for white compared to just doing taking
with the pawn that he'll make that
choice yeah yeah I would be surprised if
he takes with the Rook it would be based
on some kind of miscalculation or
misevaluation it's definitely to me that
taking with the pawn is
superior okay these types of moments are
pretty important though like which which
piece do you recapture
with yeah this is going to be a
difficult uh situation for Carlson but I
think that after a couple minutes
thought he'll realize which one's the
best one he'll just make sure that uh
his analysis is correct and he'll take
with the pawn what about for
nonprofessionals what what do you think
uh guidelines they need for situations
like that it seems sometimes people just
choose one based on emotion or based
on like habit and and don't give enough
thought to situations like this cuz it's
so relevant to the complexion of the
game well I think that sometimes chess
players are guided a little too much by
Instinct because your instinct here is
to preserve your Pawn structure you are
taught almost by muscle memory that you
have to keep your Pawn structure well
intact PA double pawns are bad
especially the pawn E3 is under pressure
but here you have have to see the bigger
picture and understand that chess is not
just about a pawn here and a pawn there
it's about the activity of all the
pieces the safety of the king the pawn
structure and there's all these elements
that go together and knowing positions
knowing ideas allows you to make more
informed positions in this case well he
took with the rook and everything that I
was going to say just went out the
window but uh the Knight on H5 I mean I
think had to be controlled I really
don't like taking with the
Rook mauce
well I have to tell you I was looking at
this position and I'm the kind of guy
who I'm always active first and that's
what I think about in this position I
wondered you know what you're stopping
me from playing F5 or aren't you now the
engine say don't play this move but then
as soon as I play it they help me out
and it turns out that the move may have
been possible still this move F5 take a
look if you take on F5 now Knight to F4
and the position goes completely in
saying this Knight on F4 is suddenly
creating some kind of compensation
because it's hitting D5 a rook is
thinking about coming into C3 this E3
Pawn might become weak now the engines
are saying yeah right whatever we don't
believe it Bishop back to B1 key move
you got to find this very special move
being able to guard the pawn in F5 also
prepare to go to A2 just in case
guarding everything and now Rook to C5
the B5 is hanging D5 is hanging this
kind of funky struct tactics everything
is exploding but it's still supposed to
be fine for white we would expect the
world champion to find this kind of
variation but it's messy it's not like
it's one of those easy ones to play so
maybe he noticed this line and it
confused him a bit and he said I don't
need to go there why not stay solid and
instead he just decided to play this
super solid move instead with Rook takes
on E3 now we do know that after Rook
takes Bishop takes E3 Rook takes E3 he
does have some compensation does black
with Knight at four but instead he
played the move Rook to C3 allowing this
move Rook to E1 now the engines don't
like that one either they preferred
Queen A5 in that position but it seems
as though white is still okay and the
time the moment may have just passed
right by when black could have played
really well for Knight F4 and F5 again
so we'll have to ask the players after
the game is over if they had considered
these lines but for now at least it
looks like white is still in control at
least by a little bit
guys I am slightly baffled did he just
quickly play Rook A1 to
E1 what what is this yeah that looks
right that Rook is simply defending the
other Rook but it just all looks so
awkward how are you supposed to make
progress with the Rooks on the E file I
thought it was white that was trying to
make something happen of course Queen A5
made so much sense I understand that
you're getting away from some of this
Knight F4 tricks but but putting after
Rook C3 putting this Rook behind the
other looks so incredibly passive yeah
speaking of a natural Rose this looks
weird I'm ass sure that Carlson has some
plan and maybe he wants to later Retreat
the bishop to F1 and be able to take
with the Rook so as to not damage his
Pawn structure but man is that move Rook
A1
strange and we've got Grandmaster y
sowan with the leader of the grand
Chester so far veln
TOA okay do we start now we're about to
hello St Louis and we're with our
tournament leader uh vesselin topolov
first of all vesselin congratulations on
today's game oh thank you uh it was a
pleasant surprise what my opponent did
it it felt too smooth I mean he uh
Maxine has a good reputation as a very
well prepared player but it seemed that
in his preparation he really didn't have
a feeling for the game and you won
incredibly smoothly uh yeah I think I
believe he misplayed the idea to place
the bishop and to try to to put it on
this diagonal A5 A5 which I believe was
a mistake and uh the whole concept was
wrong and of course he also did it in a
very unfortunate moment and it was very
quickly over you know yeah yeah so it it
was I was a bit surprised that uh the
the win today but you know the way it's
not about the win but the way it
happened yeah well when it uh when it's
snowballing so very nicely two and a
half points out of three you're feeling
very good about the tournament situation
well definitely yeah I you know uh I'm
not playing much in the last month
so I first rounds uh was a little bit
worried about your for Magnus complet me
completely outplayed me in a I think
believe equal position and then against
hikara I missed fantastic chances to to
win or almost to win you know and uh
today you know of course it was I played
better but it's also true that I didn't
have to find many difficult moves yeah
but all your moves were good moves too
well uh there are theoretical moves and
then just developing so and of course I
kind of only had to calculate a couple
of not too too difficult lines right
well again congratulations keep up your
success thank you thank you very much
than that is our tournament leader
vesselin topof with two and a half
points out of three lamenting that maybe
it might have been three out of three
but nonetheless he looks to be in great
shape and now all eyes are going to be
turning to magnus's game against Anish
because Agnus if he's going to get out
of the cell he's got to do it today and
to catch up to this guy if uh vesselin
gets hot this tournament could be over
in the first half back to you in St
Louis unlikely that with these guys that
tour's going to be over in the first
half but we said that at the sinkfield
cup didn't we yeah and that was very
clearly over by the first half you were
wrong about that
Maurice yeah I got my doubts about that
you know we talked about giri in round
one he won the game but it looked a
little shaky he didn't seem quite
accurate with his moves he had easier
wins and usually when you have that
situation you want to prove that you're
on form you want to play the crispiest
moves moves you want to you want to say
look I hit you the right way I finish it
off I'm going home when you don't do
that you wonder if the guy's really
playing well and now we see giri was not
playing that well and much worse against
well at least was worse against Carlson
Carlson himself is not playing that well
so he's making life a little bit more
difficult for himself with a couple of
moves that we've seen so far another guy
though we a game we've got to look at is
this one between Anan and grischuk this
game is Just categorically crazy we saw
the the other game we said was wild this
one got even Wilder in this position
gisu played very patient chess and
played Bishop C8 didn't Advance too soon
just put his pieces on the great squares
he's looking to put his Bishop on the B7
square and Anan suddenly decided you
know what I'm going to play F4 f F4 man
I would not have even conceived of that
move with my king looking like this with
a pawn already on H4 this looks
suspicious to me at least to see this
move clearly he could actually take and
shatter the structure but maintaining
the tension is grischuk he played the
move cool calm Rook F to E8 and now the
engines are saying slightly better for
white but they're materialists they like
pawns white is up a pawn but slightly
better for white is not one Pawn better
it's just slightly better look at this
this file could open a rook at land on
E3 there could be some doubling the
bishop could still go to B7 I like black
I'd much rather be black no matter what
the engines say here so I think that
Anan is going to have to look real
careful if he's going to avoid losing
this game which is the last thing he
wants to do and he has started to spend
some time on the clock he had a whole
bunch of minutes that has now dissipated
that have now dissipated completely and
he has to study this and one wonder how
do you play as white there's no simple
natural way to improve the position guys
well the last time we actually take a
look at a game in which well the
computer said white was okay maybe a
little bit better but we like playing
with black from a practical point of
view well that was the mvl game against
apalo and we saw how that worked out for
white in that position we're going to go
have to see if Anan is able to actually
come up with something in a position
that I think is actually quite
unpleasant after the move F4 so maybe
going to have to go back to play in the
speciic after this game maybe it'll
inspire me right we are going to take a
break and apparently it's pory R here in
St Louis but we wouldn't know because
we're in the basement enjoying Norway
chess
2015 stay with us we'll be back
[Music]
soon
for
[Music]
I
e
[Music]
l
for
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
welcome back to the 2015 Grand Chester
we got big news carlan has just
sacrificed a pieace against an gur so
let's go straight to that game we're
still trying to figure out what's going
on uh we left the game before the break
uh here in this position and Anish G
went ahead and ripped apart the center
with a move F5 something we had
established as a typical idea of the
structure but we didn't think it worked
in this particular scenario after Pawn
takes F5 Knight F4 Magnus Carlson had a
strong choice between Bishop B1 which we
thought was the most accurate move in
the position and when he played Bishop
E4 also a very strong move the problem
here was that after Rook 3 C5 Magnus
Carlson just destroyed this the king
side notice how D5 is hanging B5 is
hanging it seems like there are some
problems in the position here for black
uh sorry for white and his weak pawns
but after Pawn takes G6 H takes
G6 Caron thought about it for a bit and
he did it with power Bishop takes G6
okay so let's take a look at the lines
after Knight takes G6 now notice that
gir did take on B5 but let's look at
first at Knight G6 and I guess I'll
would be very scared about playing this
because of Queen G4 and now the problem
is any light square that you go to in
order to protect the Knight on G6 we
have Knight G5 right if you play first
king G7 then Knight H4 I think is just
completely winning immediately yeah no
way to connect with that Knight on G6
there 's no good way of Defending that
Knight but if you go to F7 I think
Knight G5 check looks absolutely
decisive in that case after Bishop takes
G6 black has to ignore the threats but
I'm not so sure how to do that uh the
first things that jump to my mind are
the moves either Rook C4 to try to cut
off the king uh the queen from the King
side or the move Bishop takes D5 at
least gaining a pawn back maybe trying
to take on B5 in the next move keeping
up the pressure because the G6 Bishop
would be hanging at this point and this
Knight does a very important job of not
allowing the queen to go to the king
side after Rook takes B5 in instead we
had Rook takes B5 followed by Queen E4
well Queen E4 defends the bishop so that
seems to make sense to me uh is there
any other move that looks good let's see
maybe Maurice has some insights for us
in this very crazy
position wow talk about a turn of events
magnus's move Bishop G6 was absolutely
brilliant beautiful move and then he
missed a win that when I was looking at
it I mean I didn't see it let me tell
you straight when the computer first
suggested it I was like what are you
doing and it turns out he was completely
crushing giri and his move now seems to
have only equalized the position it
still is up in the air but let's take a
look at this after the move Rook takes
B5 you wonder what Magnus had in mind
and queen E4 is the most natural move
that's the move that was on my mind I
was wondering about the tactics
beginning with Bishop D5 does it work
the engine immediately screams Bishop F7
check bizarre move it does defend this
pawn and prepar to play Queen E4 but the
question is what if I just take your
bishop and way too deep for human eyes
even for Magnus Carlson's to move Queen
E4 and now the threats of Queen F5
Knight G5 and simply mating the king are
overwhelming coming just like that just
like that it's over the engines are
trying to defend nothing to do it's
already up at four points for those of
you who know engine speak four plus four
is crushing it's over all variations
leading to disaster because of Simply
this queen and this Knight sneaking into
the position with the black Army on this
side now it's up to five it's almost
probably calculating Ms soon okay that's
a bit much but here come the pieces the
Queen's coming in the knight's coming in
with Jack it's too much to stomach and
this would be over Magnus would simply
win straight but Bishop F7 is
paradoxical as ever to see that move you
sack your bishop and then swing your
queen into the act crazy but it turns
out instead he played the move Queen E4
in this position uh after Rook takes B5
instead he played Queen E4 that kind of
sets up the same threats except there is
a move and giri has found it the move
Rook f8 stopping that check controlling
everything on this side and now aiming
for the D5 pawn and it looks as though
the engines are giving better for though
just slightly better for white slightly
better for white is the analysis this is
just crazy white is up two pawns You Can
Count him two pawns D5 Pawn looks like
it's going to drop but Black's energy
has Consolidated itself instead of being
shifted too much on this side black has
brought two pieces to bear on this side
of the board it still looks like maybe
white can do something tricky but I
don't see it the engines don't see it it
looks as though Magnus Carson has blown
the win and giri is back in the game
guys Bishop F7 blows my mind there's I
mean that's an amazing move to find but
you know what I think Magnus will be
upset no it's one of those I think even
though you're like
2900 the computer says Bishop F7 you
throw your hands in the air you say well
I was never going to find that Bishop F7
check is something but I would just
qualify that with Magnus obviously when
he played Bishop G6 and queen E4 he he
was he had the idea of threatening
Bishop F7 so right but playing away
seems so crazy especially because after
Bishop F7 I take on F7 Queen E4 I don't
even think you have an immediate
checkmating threat like if I just take
on D5 yes your queen and Knight they
look very powerful but are you actually
mating me I don't see anything if we
analyze that position uh because this is
just such a huge
deal Bishop takes G6 Rook takes B5 he
wants to play Bishop F7 check first of
all a check that it's very unclear what
it does by itself it's just it's a crazy
move no doubt it's a crazy move it just
doesn't come with any ideas and after
Queen E4 I mean if I take on D5 and I
calculate I don't well Queen F5 in that
position Queen F5 check actually picks
off The Rook on on C8 so so this is
that's one very important point the
problem the Brook on SE is hanging so
okay so there are some issues but still
I think that this would have been
incredible to find I think it would have
been absolutely incredible that's why
he'll be upset CU it could be it could
be like it could be I mean could you
imagine coming back for Motu with that
this is that would have been definitely
a good boost to his uh self-confidence
but man Bishop F7 I think after Magna
celebrates finding that brilliancy
someone is goingon to have to sweep the
room for computers Bishop ofan I just
don't think I would have ever considered
this
move and it was the only move to obtain
a decisive advantage of all the great
players past and present which one do
you think would be the most likely to
find this move
tall tall for sure I mean he's the
player that's like oh how can I lose a
piece on purpose here no Bishop F7 that
seems to be hanging something and then
he would calculate it out and figure out
it
works
Maurice uh yeah T's my favorite player
of all time but boy take a look at the
variation that you would have to find to
win this game according to the engine so
far there's a lot you could keep looking
and let them look and look and maybe
they find wins but look at the main line
the engine's giving King takes F7 Queen
E4 all right now you got this queen F5
idea coming so you can't just play
Bishop takes on D5 so the variation King
G7 stopping the queen from coming into
the H7 Square Knight G5 doesn't come
with check all right Knight G5 I'm
looking to play Queen H7 right wrong
Bishop takes on D5 Queen H7 is
apparently just a draw how can that be
right Queen H7 King to F6 and the engine
is saying I don't see the win like I'm
solid black is okay what then why did
you play Knight G5 well the reason he
played Knight G5 after Bishop takes on
D5 is to play Queen
F5 what like why there well the point is
now when The Rook moves you're
threatening The Rook it moves now you
play the beautiful Knight E6 check
clearing the G file for the rook and now
the game is over the Rook is coming in
It's Made in four being yelled out
instantly by the engines come on that's
ridiculous I don't think Magnus is going
to kick himself over not seeing this
maneuver Bishop F7 Queen E4 Knight G5
and then the cool commom Queen F5 to
calculate that followed by Knight E6 no
that's insane that's that I don't
suspect at all this was a spectacular
way to go but now the reality is the
game has turned around and the position
they're in is even more explosive as
Magnus has sacrific a knight on E5 got
to take a look at this guys I'll put it
back in your hands Alejandro what a
crazy turn of events but no I have to
agree with Maurice Bishop F7 looks like
a move that even if you put it on a
calculation book I'd be like no way that
that's not something I'm going to find
maybe doki's books yeah but doki's book
hurts my head and hurts everybody's head
so kn5 has just appeared on the board
and quickly giri said well I cannot live
down that many pawns I'm going to go
ahead and take the Knight and ask where
your com can't live with that night on
E5 no of course not so Pawn takes E5 was
played and I don't see the continuation
let's see Rook G3 seems to be the normal
idea here in this position I would
assume however I don't think that you
have a particularly powerful uh discover
attack here of course a very tricky
position for both players but if I'm
cheeky and I just grabbed the D5 Pawn is
there anything going
on so now let's analyze we have Bishop
Bishop E8 check would be possible of
course course I wanted to move my king
over to h8 and I guess the rook's going
to be hanging after Queen E5 check seems
very powerful so that's going to be an
issue I cannot take on D5 I have to find
some kind of way of moving out of this
uh problematic discovered attack we
could be looking at the move King h8
immediately which or Rook takes D5
perhaps or Rook takes D5 also a
possibility so much to consider here
keep the E5 Pawn under attack indeed M
has 16 minutes to actually come up with
something in this position but it's not
it's not clear I'm also has to come up
with something right is night H3
work ooh when now is uh KN H3 and idea
in this
position the problem for well that just
gets a little too crazy he because he
might you don't have to take you don't
have to take it you move the King right
my idea was to do something along the
lines of this this and check and then
the Rook on G3 is hanging but you can
just move the king and you can play like
Bishop Bishop takes D5 this is
absolutely insane we can spend hours
calculating this VAR yeah this this one
will will give us plenty of fun for
today
Maurice well yeah you could spend hours
all right the engines just break this
down in seconds it's incredible this
position you thought the other positions
were crazy take a look at this next one
this is absolutely this this goes in the
way of yeah right whatever we don't even
want to look because it's too insane to
believe after Rook to G3 which we
suspect will be magnus's move and he has
played it there is only one move to save
himself one move can giri play right now
and that move Rook takes D5 that's it
Rook takes D5 do your worst you have
nothing you could do here the Eng by the
way are giving triple zeros it's equal
why do they say that now white has no
real powerful moves here the best move
for white there's no discoveries that
work they don't matter there's no way to
organize a mating idea the move for
white now is Rook to B1 Rook to B1 and
now black can play this discovery Rook
D1 check to the king attacking The Rook
attacking the queen so therefore you
can't touch the Rook on
D1 cool Cal no problem have my queen or
Rook whatever you want because I have
this recovery still now if you play
Bishop takes on e4 white is winning
after Bishop takes with check and
suddenly he's going to take this piece
he's going to be up two pawns when he
wins the queen so that line is out you
cannot touch the queen so after King to
H2 it's still Black's move black now
must play Rook takes on B1 all other
moves according to the engines lose Rook
takes B1 and now it's White's turn and
white has the move Bishop to F5 with
check the king Moves In in the corner
and now Queen takes E5 with check I mean
craziness now you must block with the
queen cuz your king is being encircled
Queen over now it looks like you're
hitting the bishop possibly the queen
and now Queen C7 is he down a rook and a
knight for three pawns insanity but
apparently this position with the mate
threat sitting here on this Square
forces black well black has a couple of
ways to draw now but one of them is to
play Rook to F7 Queen B8 check Rook f8
Queen C7 and we get a
Perpetual nobody's calculating that at
least nobody without some silicon
running through their veins this is
insane amazing line and the players are
going to have to work this out just
madness has erupted on the chessboard
and we have to see how these humans
handle themselves as they try to
calculate themselves through this morass
guys that's right so will he find I
don't think yeah I think he is going for
it that's right that's right he played
it Rook takes D5 was play Rook takes D5
and he's made his 40th move so very
importantly he's actually also uh got
into time control so any further
calculations that he needs to do he will
have more than enough time to do them I
was worried about him in this particular
situation where well he only had 15
minutes to calculate everything but bam
he actually played that really quickly
he took like what four minutes to take
the pawn on D5 he still had another 12
to use up in this position to calculate
different variations
I I just think he did it by um process
of elimination yeah I think just
everything else lost very quickly let's
show some of the variations first of all
I'm actually curious on why this king h8
move lost but I have the feeling that it
involves this idea of Queen E5 Queen C7
that Maurice was showing us I just
cannot figure out how to make it work
exactly perhaps oh no there's something
a lot simpler you just check Queen F6
takes takes and you check on E8 right
and after King G7 I have this bishop D3
discover attack and the bishop will
defend the Rook at the end got it right
right I me the bishop was defending the
Rook yeah this is winning okay so king
h8 is not possible uh the other move
that we considered was Bishop takes D5
which was refuted by uh Bishop E8 so it
seems like yeah Rook takes D5 was just
the only move that didn't lose instantly
I guess that's why he played it other
your knight H3 yeah the other one it's
Knight H3 and we refuted that with the
move King H2 so it seems like
everything's covered and Rook takes D5
was that that was it that was the only
move I can come up with that's not this
now the idea of playing Rook B1
though that's
crazy because then you have to allow
Rook D1
check it's funny because in this
particular position Rook d1's not a
threat because it's not check but it is
when you move the from E1 to B1 so that
looks extremely illogical uh is there
something else in the position that I
can try it doesn't seem like it Bishop
F7 doesn't quite have the Firepower
needed to finish black off and that'll
be just too much material loss so it
does seem like giri is defending his
position he's currently up a piece for
two pawns though and even though there
is a lot of pressure on that King on G8
I cannot find anything that makes the
king too worried at the
moment even the Rook Rook B1 is very
difficult to find and once you calculate
it out it's actually white that has a
little bit of a miraculous Perpetual in
one of those positions to be able to
hold on to the
draw so despite a really inspiring play
for magmas now that the dust is cleared
not so clear you know um we've be
getting some uh feedback on Twitter and
um it was Lawrence tread who who said
that the engine suggestion of Bishop fan
is it out of this world suggestion that
could never occur to a sane human
operating word sane operating word sane
I think there's more than one chest
player that might have found it but
saying would not be a description any
living player maybe but they're still
alive so I will not name names come on
tell us it's a compliment I think
there's a couple of players that
actually have the capacity to see moves
like this um instantly you want think
sheir off right you're reminded
mentioned that I think yeah you're
reminded of his move Bishop H3 that he
played actually against topalo in the
end game in the in that very very famous
end game by many people think it's the
best move ever played perhaps Bishop F7
check would have surpassed it but uh you
know this was a little bit more of
concrete calculation but still I think
it's very strange for somebody so sh
Sher of T I'm G to stop there oh I think
American I sorry American are you think
he an American I mean hikaro once upon a
time I mean I was always surprised by
his consistent and amazing calculations
and of course I'm reminded of his Queen
takes F2 check against cenov I believe
that sacrificed a queen checkmated his
opponent brilliantly but I mean as a
Grandmaster I would have never
considered Bishop F7 check to be
playable but of the people in this
tournament you think Nakamura would be
the most likely to find it out of this
tournament well it wasn't Carlson
because he didn't play it but uh well he
could still be the most likely to play
it and not have played it that's a good
point but perhaps either Nakamura or
talo would be some of my favorites to be
able to find such a move it's just out
of this world completely out of this
world position and then we had a funny
comment from Roshan Patra who says come
on you keep moving to the bad news board
and neglecting on anoun
playing why just thought it hilarious
comment when Magnus is like sacrificing
all of his pieces it's like that's a Die
Hard fan it's difficult for us to look
at the at that game though we do have to
switch at at at now we because we play
time control we have made time control
so yes mace actually it's worth watching
guys it remember we said it was one of
the interesting positions we didn't
expect magnus's game to get that insane
that's going to be one of the more
memorable games you'll ever see that
game with Magnus and giri this has
really made uh Norway chess 2015 one of
the Epic tournaments to watch and it's
just three rounds in after what's been
going on and particularly focus on that
Wonder Boy Magnus Carlson who is just
having a Topsy Turvy tournament all the
excitement and going straight to this
this young man amazing chess but other
players are playing Amazing chess as
well the game right here we see Anan
versus grischuk take a look after Rook
f8 we were at this point F takes E5 Rook
takes E5 and a queen trade was offered
grischuk said I'm not trading Queens are
you crazy and after Rook to C4 look what
he did he put his Bishop back on the D7
square and Anan played Rook to F3 and
allowed a move which by the way is not
even the computer's first choice Choice
surprise surprise but still Bishop takes
on B5 snapping back a pawn and now pawns
are equal on the board if you take on
B5 Rook takes E2 with check and why
should black feel like he's much worse
here of course this D Pawn exist this
King looks a little funny maybe white
has a slight edge here after a move like
King to H3 but certainly this game has
gone a bit crazy and they're not
anywhere near time control this is only
after NX B5 move 30 gisu has 7 26 left
to play in the game I believe he has
moved yes it did happen Knight takes B5
Rook takes E2 cheze is on the board
gisik with 726 on out with 2044 no
increments at all so lots of excitement
going down to the wire at least the
first time control in this game guys wow
what a crazy development here in the
grch game it does seem like there might
be a couple of trades in store for us
and that would make whiteking feel a lot
safer uh I think that here Anan is
calculat the difference between Rook F2
or King F1 different King moves but it
does feel to me that King F1 should be
the more forcing move in order to trade
off stuff let's see King F1 I'm worried
just a little bit about Queen E7 perhaps
I can't actually play King
F1 there are some pressure on the E file
I'm not entirely sure if it's decisive
but it feels a little bit uncomfortable
for sure uh on the other hand how do you
trade pieces if Rook F2
we have this situation where uh Bishop
E3 I thought was a
move I don't know if white would be
worse after sacrificing the queen with
Rook takes C2 notice that I cannot take
on F6 because of this intermediate Rook
takes F two
check uh so you have to I believe take
the rook and after takes I might even
take with the Knight and I'm not even
sure that White's necessarily that much
worse in this position but I would
prefer
black and if not these moves what is
what exactly else is V you're
considering can he just put the King on
H3 and say well so what my King's on H3
but you can't get to it and I'm going to
trade off pieces and you have some
vulnerabilities on F5 this Pawn will be
passed in an endgame perhaps some
problems with this position here for Guk
I don't know still a very complicated
game and Guk uh as usual has put himself
in time trouble so he has I'm not too
bad not too bad for gruk standards of uh
a little bit over seven minutes to make
nine moves but nine hell moves yes those
very important nine
moves crazy developments here in Norway
2015 man this game simply exploded out
of nowhere yeah yeah great games and one
decisive game already that happened so
quickly so quickly and so unexpect
expectedly as topalo mentioned to us it
was not so much that he didn't expect to
win because well too if you want to play
for a win every game but the way that
happened it was just so unexpected NV
pretty much crumbled on his own he
didn't really have to do anything to
said he didn't have to make that many
great moves no he prep development win
man I wish I won't G us like that so
maybe a little bit tired definitely
tired he's been playing a lot he just
came from Leon where he had a tough
tournament that was a tournament that
just happened after the French league
he's been playing a lot not with the
greatest of results uh I think he may
have overestimated his his and even
playing a BL tournament against all of
these guys oh that's extremely tough and
he did must be really tiring he did
amazing I mean he actually won the blitz
tournament which a lot of people did not
predict and he showed his strength but
that has to be taxing absolutely taxing
on his
body let's see we'll take a quick look
at the other games see if they've
actually developed into something the
Americans have gone through massive comp
simplifications here huh right um I'm
not sure what's happening structurally
it feels like white better in this
position yeah before you lights black a
little bit but now it looks like with
the Queen's off the board he car just
played Rook to
H1 right it depends if I can just
simplify everything here with the move
F4 and try to trade everything off if
this works then the game is still just a
draw for example after takes takes takes
I can play Rook D4 I don't see a good
way of defending the pawn because if you
play Rook H4 well you're never going to
really make progress in this position I
can just play
A4 well yeah you can't move anything you
can't move anything you're up a pawn but
it's more symbolic than anything else
this should end in a draw so unless
there's good idea prob you just could
just move that four now it does seem
like this should be headed towards the
draw but I still think White's position
is more pleasant well maybe instead of
capturing twice he can do something else
here play G4 I I think G4 is okay but
I'm liking taking taking and playing E4
in order to try to wrap around this Pawn
and play specifically Rook H5 F5 that to
me seems like the most dangerous
variation for black um if this happens
perhaps there are some chances for
Nakamura to win I don't know how this
happened because that end game seem the
other thing is we don't we don't even
have to play this F4 move couldn't we
just wait for you to play uh Rook H5 and
we can always meet that with
F6 yeah you could there's actually no
need uh for you to do much in this
position and it's possible that my overe
eagerness to play F4 might land me in a
difficult position well you just also
you just have to check it because it's
the most forcy move but then once you
start showing me the takes an E4 line
I'm starting to say well I absolutely
agree with I absolutely agree with you I
think that your approach of passive
defense just play F6 put the Rook on D6
and ask well so what might be able to
hold I'm still going to be worried about
the ideas of Rook H5 and F4 trying to
get to my F5 Pawn so I think it might
still be a little bit unpleasant and I'm
actually not sure how we got to this
position yeah let's go back and take a
look because we've
well yeah so we left it off around this
scenario and after Queen F4 a trade of
Queens occurred and okay I don't see why
black should be worse in this
position the pawn structure is only
slightly worse but the rook's very
active we got some moves in Rook was
kicked back King came in and it seems
like Fabiano himself gave him uh the the
problem on G5 I me he didn't have to
play G5
actually I don't know why he played
G5 why didn't he just play H5 in this
position on hold if I play H5 I don't
see how white makes any real progress
maybe he was worried about D4 creating a
pass Pawn but it doesn't seem like
there's going to be any easy way to make
progress in this position I can probably
just Shuffle back and forth until you
create a real threat this looks okay for
black actually G5 is a little strange to
me after which it not only weakens your
position on the king side it basically
gives up the H file at least if the Rook
was already on the H file I would
understand this move but G5 looks very
strange definitely not something that I
expected in another game that we haven't
seen in a while also an endgame we have
the battle between leevon aronian and
John ludic Hammer and we have again a
bad Pawn structure for black side but
only one weakness and it seems like I
mentioned earlier when there's only one
weakness on the board it's very
difficult to make progress in this case
that weakness is on
D4 uh you can see that white has both of
his remaining pieces attacking it but
the problem is what else are you going
to do how are you going to bring your
king in to try to create some threats
how are you going to do anything
basically in this position it's almost
seems like at some point that Ronan is
going to have to play E3 to break
through but but that doesn't seem like
an easy breakthrough to organize and
even if you do it I don't think it leads
to that much so perhaps Hammer can show
a good way of holding this position
without too many problems but even but
erroneous position is of course to be
preferred for sure and you've been
saying that all game and I agree right
and in the game aan versus gruk we have
a couple of new moves King H3 was indeed
played and Guk said hey look at that
that's a free Pawn so I took it Rook
takes B2 attacking the Knight on B5 and
it seems like well Anan has the choice
of taking on F6 after which you have to
recapture and I'm a little scared about
Black's Pawn structure in this position
uh there's the issue that the knight's
hanging on B5 so I probably have to move
it and that this Pawn on D5 is also
under attack but I'm not so sure that I
have to go Knight C3 or Knight C7 to
defend it I'm kind of wondering if I can
play Knight D4 since after Rook takes D5
check on
C8 King G7 there are some ideas of
playing Knight E6 check or Knight takes
F5 check and I think Knight takes F5
specifically looks really really strong
as the only move that defends the bishop
without sacrificing The Exchange would
be king G6 but after Rook G8 check
that's all she wrote the move King F7
runs into Knight takes H6 and the Knight
also no you got to show us King H5 and
then okay I have to show of course King
H5 with our first Pawn checkm of the
tournament but not the last well let's
hope not the last Pawn G4 and that would
be game over so it doesn't seem like I
have to worry about the pawn on D5 which
means that after the queen trade I can
go Knight D4 and follow up with Knight
takes F5 and this leaves me very worried
about G's chances of holding on to this
position materal is currently in favor
of black actually he's up a pawn but
after Knight takes F5 I'm going to be
able to recover it ideas of f4 I also
can ignore I can even play Knight E6
again you cannot take on D5 because
after Rook C8 that's just check my next
move so I I don't know I I feel like
anan's better there might be chances to
hold but we're not going to see this end
game as Anan might have thought that he
had a better idea by actually forcing
grischuk to be the one to exchange the
Queens himself and this is a very
interesting idea the point is that after
Queen takes D4 I take back of course
with the Knight and instead of
shattering your Pawn structure on the
king side I'm making sure that you don't
give your king a LT which means that the
Rook on d8 is stuck to the eighth Rank
and the problems here persist for
chrisuk he needs to find some clever way
of getting out of everything I'm
imagining he wants to play G6 and try to
stop the pawn somehow but it doesn't
seem easy to do again the move Knight E6
would be a huge problem I cannot take on
D5 because of Rook C8 Checkmate but if I
move the Rook anywhere random then the
move D6 uh comes with full strength
crushing crushing also possible Rook C3
or Rook D3 look very very strong even
ifan wins this game he won't catch up
with the leader right no he won't but he
will be in a really good position for
sure
right well we have a very special guest
in the studio in St Louis we have the
chess club founder rexing field he's
with Maurice
Ashley yes we're with Rex singfield the
Visionary behind the chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis Rex
welcome to the show thank you very much
Rex it's been crazy this Grand chess
tour has kicked off with a bang followed
by another bang and again in round three
just insane I know how do you feel about
what has transpired so far you hate to
certainly don't want to wish ill will on
anybody but the fact is we all know when
the presumed leader loses in the first
round and then loses in the second round
you got nothing but heart attack chess
from here on out I mean he's got to win
he's got to do anything to win and even
now in this game he's not clear you know
it's a very unbalanced position it makes
for exciting chess and think what it
does to the other players they say
Carlson's available you know he's
disposable imagine how they get up for
him that's got to be tough for him every
day knowing that the guy that's going to
play him is up for him more than
anything else in the world absolutely
they smell blood like sharks oh
absolutely in the water the way these
guys play and the two Americans hikaro
Nakamura and Fabiano Carana they're
doing quite well how your feelings about
that I I I'm happy to see they're doing
well I notice in this game it's the
essence of
quietude you know you almost wonder if
it's illegal to continue the game you
know yeah it is kind of boring are you
are you uh as excited to watch this as
you would be for your your own singfield
cup uh you know I have to admit that
this has made me as excited because of
the way it's unfolded obviously there's
a huge home bias as there is for anyone
uh but this is remarkable and frankly
with our people over in Norway and with
the best broadcast team in the world
right here in St Louis covering this
tournament live it's sort of like being
at home I think actually that Missouri
and Norway should consider a merger what
do you think of that I'm not going to
get into you heard it here first
ideas I know you have quite a few of
them I do so the the Triad of events
what's the vision behind this to have
these these events be a grand chess tour
what's the purpose as you see this get
kicked off I think to create the premier
chess series throughout the year
analogous to what happens in tennis and
what happens in golf everybody follows
those major tournaments and at the end
of the year who's the best it's the one
who's done the best over a series of
events you recall last last year when
these players were here in St Louis and
we were having dinner at my house
actually and I asked Magnus what's more
important to you being world champion
are being considered the number one
player in the world and he said easy
being number one he says because that's
you got to do every day a championship
just last a couple weeks but number one
you got to do it every day you got to
you know be ready to go every day so
it's much harder and he likes it much
more that makes enormous sense now we
only have three tournaments right now
are there intentions to expand it to
even more events I believe there will be
more I think we can go to four next year
I'm not sure how many ultim my guess is
ultimately we might get to six and then
there'll be an option for the players
not to have to play in six but just to
play in five so they could opt out of
one but none nothing is cast in stone
yet yeah that'll be quite a number of
tournaments Gary kasparov's role in this
he's he's also a Visionary chess player
certainly uh world champion number one
for many many years uh how are you
working together with him to make these
happen well you know Gary's really
providing the intellectual leadership on
this this was as we started talking
about this in Norway the day after the
Fay elections and you know quite
honestly Gary was understandably quite
down from the election but boy did he
bounce back fast and we started talking
about some event and then after the the
singfield cup here we really started
talking about it because when I got the
feedback from the players that yeah
success in a series of tournaments is
more important than success in one that
that sort of just sealed that tells you
what the whole Chess World is waiting
for and what they think is important but
Gary's crucial this he's the C Quan n
this wouldn't be happening without him
and the future of Chess here in the
United States certainly as you mentioned
there's a there's a home bias but we see
some young players who are rising stars
it's incredible what Sam seon has done
uh Jeffrey jeang has now become a grandm
the tender age of 14 and we see Awan
dang who's also playing Amazing chess
the future seems bright for young
American Stars it really does it's it's
really gratifying now let me tell you a
personal story in that regard about
Rising Stars about 2 or three years ago
in the St Louis open I happened to play
in it and I will confess and I know that
Jennifer's here and I'm going to be
excoriated because I haven't played
enough over the board chess and I
haven't played enough 10-minute chess
and Jennifer Shah is your coach Jennifer
shahat is my coach and she is uh my evil
coach she punishes me severely but she's
wonderful but but hear from her when I
don't do exactly what she wants so I was
playing in this tournament and who do I
play but Matt Lawson who was rated all a
1450 in that event now you talk about
playing a rising star when his true
strength is way above his actual rating
I mean it was brutal I went down in
flames we played some Queen Pawn opening
and I have no idea what you'd call what
I played you
know well the young players definitely
are powerful I know they're in town for
the the Kasparov chess school is it the
the Kasparov chess Foundation the rising
star school and it's two floors above us
in this very building taking place right
now incredible events happening all the
time here in St Louis thanks of course
in no small part to your generosity we
appreciate your coming it's anytime well
thank you but you know let's give credit
where credit is due we have an amazing
staff Joy Bray Tony Rich all of you
folks coming in not just doing the
broadcasting but lending us not lending
but giving us your ideas this is clearly
a team this is a corporate event there's
a no one person here if there's ever a
team event and let's face it we've been
blessed with Good Fortune it looks like
everything we've tried has turned out to
be a good idea I mean that's just an
incredible run of luck and I hope it
continues well luck goes to the prepared
and there's a lot of preparation and
intellect that goes into forming such a
wonderful event and club and series of
events thank you so much Rex for joining
us pleasure indeed Rex singfield the
founder the brains behind all of this
that has happened here we appreciate his
time back to you guys in studio thank
you absolutely great things happening
around the world with this chest tour
and I like that point that it's not just
a two we event or a two- we match uh
that is a spear point where everything
falls on it no it's just a tour and it's
a performance throughout the year that
really determines who the best player in
the world is and I'm glad to hear that
Magnus Carlson also shares this opinion
that that's more important than the
world championship title and it's spaced
out nicely too right so oh very nicely
yes absolutely the fact that we have
tournaments in uh now in June which
going to end in December players have
enough time to rest between events and
prepare for each other and rumors are
we're going to have early next year
another participant on the grand chest
tour yeah you're going to want to stay
tuned to Grand chest tour's website and
Twitter page to find more details on
that and of course we'll probably also
have a lot more details when the
singfield cup rolls right down here in
St Louis in a couple months absolutely
all right let's get back into the action
of what's going on in the games so
Carlon is still thinking after5 we've
got 25 minutes well I'm not surprised uh
how funny would it be if he actually
thought 25 minutes in that Bishop F7
position he might actually have found uh
the move Bishop F7 too bad that wasn't
move 40 that was not move 40 uh but
unfortunately for Carlson this is a
little bit too late it doesn't matter
how much he thinks there is no forced
win but there's more than one way for
him to push too hard in this position
there is a couple of variation in which
he tries to Checkmate disappoint it
doesn't quite work
and well he could overpress and you
might notice that despite the fact that
this is a very sharp position GE is
nowhere to be found he hasn't been on
the board for quite a while and the
reason is that he's currently resting
playing chess is not easy especially at
this level you're consistently
calculating you're consistently
evaluating there's so much that you need
to look and think and you need rest
during games and this is the perfect
spot to do it he just hit move 40 it's
up to Carlson to define the next move
there's no use for giri to start
calculating now he's simply saying I got
an hour and 13 minutes I'm going to wait
for my opponent to make a move before I
start calculating any variations don't
let me fry my brain
unnecessarily um Maurice do it another
game actually I want to say on this game
talk about frying your brain there is so
much to calculate here and Magnus
Carlson is in the tank trying to figure
out exactly what to do well let's take a
look at this position he has a number of
moves it turns out that he shouldn't be
afraid of actually losing the game
that's critical when you're in a
position like this maybe he thought he
was winning actually maybe he knew he
was winning when he first played Bishop
G6 and he'll kick himself when he finds
out that he was in fact winning although
I don't know he'd find that variation
with Bishop F7 and queen E4 Knight G5
Queen F5 that that was all crazy but in
this position here he has a couple of
ways to go why do I say you know let's
reset everything what is the material
situation on the board that's first
crazy as it is it's one night against
two pawns this night against these two
pawns all right so it's a KN for two
pawns that means as far as Magnus is
concerned he's okay because even if you
traded some things off it's going to be
hard to prove any advantage for black so
that's the first thing you can relax
around that and now say now do I have
way to win the game and he's going to
start looking at the board quite some
time he could consolidate the position
with this move Bishop H5 check King h8
Bishop F3 that's very solid the engines
like black here but the point is White's
not going to just lose Black's a little
bit better because of the extra KN for
the two pawns but white is super solid
now maybe black can try to mess around
but I don't think with this pressure on
this diagonal that that's going to
happen so he has that alternative so
let's not make Rook B1 spectacular Rook
B1 out to be the only move but if he's
going to try to win he will look at Rook
B1 and now white but black has to find
Rook D1 check black actually after Rook
B1 could play the move Queen to C7 this
is legal white could then play Queen E3
a very unusual move threatening some
idea of moving the bishop and keeping
the pressure on this King the bishop
landing on e4 would be a very strong
piece so that's a line worth looking at
but certainly gir's going to look at the
move Rook to D1 check King H2 must be
found the queen is under attack and he
needs all the pressure he can and now
Rook takes B1 now again Magnus has a
moment to stop and think he could play
the move Bishop 87 check why is he
playing this well take a look at this
line King F7 Queen F5 check Queen F6
Queen D7 check and now Queen E7 now you
get to play this Rook check all forced
King takes Queen E7 now Rook to F7 this
looks like it might be curtains for
white but it turns out white has this
wrinkle Queen to E8 keeping an eye on
this Rook preparing all sorts of checks
possible Queen G8 queen h8 queen d8 all
kinds of nonsense could happen here and
also the bishop is attacking The Rook on
G8 sorry on B1 crazy line there that
could happen as well so that's one line
black is still okay in that line uh by
moving The Rook away so let's go back
again Rook takes B1 the line we looked
at Bishop F5 check
Magnus might go down this line giri will
have to find the right move because King
F7 in this position King F7 looks
potentially attractive but the engines
go crazy and say queen takes E5 it's
over White's winning suddenly Rook to G7
mate is on tap and you can't do anything
about it if you play the move Rook to G8
guarding against that mate now Bishop
takes on B1 quite calm threatening the
Knight with check as well so suddenly
black is without a move because this
Knight is under attack this this uh Rook
is still potentially hanging Bishop A2
check is coming into the game if Rook
takes G3 now Queen takes F4 check and
with a series of checks white will pick
up this rook and guard the bishop you
got to calculate all of that you still
with me it's crazy Magnus is human he
might be almost 2900 but to calculate
through all these variations will be
quite taxing so he's spending his time
now to make sure that he plays The
Logical line and he seem he has played a
move and instead of playing Rook to B1
he has played Queen to B1 another
alternative extraordinarily logical
move well let's not call it
extraordinarily logical the point is
that he knows he can go into an end game
where he's slightly worse he knows that
because he'll have the two pawns against
the Knight and it looks as though he's
just decided that all those other
variations don't work Rook B1 is too
crazy and he's played Queen B1 and
that's really an admission that he's
trying to draw the game more than
anything else after this move so Magnus
realizes that he is no longer winning
and it's giri who's starting to think do
I have any chances here guys well I'm
wondering actually after Queen B1 how do
you keep the extra Pawn here on E5 for
black because you have to be very
careful still after Queen B1 which was
played if you decide to just trade off
the queens and I put my king I don't on
F7 for example well on F7 I wouldn't
want to play it because this pin looks
ugly so I'm going to go ahead and put it
on h8 and I was wondering after Bishop
E4 what exactly you do to maintain that
pawn on E5 alive for example after Rook
B5 I exchange and I take on E5 and this
should be pretty much a dead draw I
don't think that three pawns can
possibly beat the Knight so this should
be extremely
drawish I don't know it it feels like I
don't think Carlson has any real chances
of being worse uh unless I'm missing a
way of keeping the pawn here for black
it seems like Queen B1 is a safer
approach to some other things that could
have been
played Queen B1 looks more logical and I
think that from a human point of view I
can explain and understand Queen B1
there are some things in this uh day
this round that I haven't been able to
understand uh first of all how badly mvl
played his game and second how badly
caranas played his game I mean oh yeah
so it looks like Nakamura actually has a
big Edge now well what what's strange to
me is that Nakamura didn't do anything
Nakamura didn't like put pressure it's
just Kar didn't like his structure so he
played G5 destroying his structure and
giving a free file to his opponent's
Rook what was he thinking I don't
understand G5 whatsoever I understand it
was the 40th move but he had plenty of
time to make it G5 is just so strange
and so committal to making the 40th move
after Pawn takes G5 Pawn takes G5 Rook
H1 it's all white White's the only one
that has chances of winning Rook A7 was
played and I wouldn't be surprised that
this is close to losing for the black
pieces there's ideas of Simply
penetrating on H5 and look at this
delicious line in the fifth rank that I
can just start munching pawns on how do
you defend everything here if I play F6
suddenly F4 is ready annoying I'm not so
sure how you keep everything intact no
something clearly went wrong here for
Karana and what bothers he should try to
generate some play with Rook A7 so that
he can play
A4 right but I mean even if you play A4
I don't know what you're doing with that
move I just take it and you're way too
slow to do anything on that side of the
board you don't have any real threats
yeah I know it's just strange because at
Lea Rooker was able to protect the pods
on D7 well to me it's completely
baffling like why he go went for
something like this his position was
completely safe and then he decided to I
don't know play G5 it's just this move
G5 is to me completely
incomprehensible yeah you're right H5
looks so natural even if you don't play
H5 just don't play anything why why are
you giving up the H file for free to
your opponent this looks I mean to use
Maurice's word ridiculous G5 is a
ridiculous move in this position
let's see uh let's take a look at GIS
Chi's game let's see if we missed this
time yeah he's not in time pressure
anymore okay we have actually a result
in this game we can see that a n and Guk
have agreed to a draw a very interesting
game for sure ESP C had its maximum
expression and we left off the position
here after Rook C6 after Queen takes D4
Knight takes D4 Rook D2 was played I
like this clever idea of making sure the
Rook controls the squares behind the
pawn in order to prevent it from moving
forward after Knight F5 Rook E8 was
played Rook takes F5 regain material
parity but after that G6 was bled and
that allowed chrisuk just about enough
time to consolidate his position he
doesn't have that much to be worried
about here because the only testing move
for black which is the move D6 runs into
Bishop G7 what black pieces are okay
this ones are awkward D7 cannot be
played because of the a beautiful
positioning of the rook and since this
Knight on E6 is hanging this Rook cannot
move from its defense Knight takes G7
was played King takes G7 Rook F4 and now
after King G8 there's simply no way of
making progress in this position I
believe the threat is also to play Rook
E6 and Rook C7 was met with Rook takes
D6 Rook F7 and despite the powerful
Rooks on the seventh rank all they're
really going to get is a Perpetual check
there's not going to be anything else
besides wres that so an interesting and
quite fascinating draw in my opinion
there was a lot of attacking chances for
both sides but at the end it kind of
fizzled out into a fighting
draw yeah a fun game for sure it was a
very fun game I think that even though
this was a draw that ended in a rook end
game the way that they got there was
really really interesting I thought it
was a lot of
fun so Magnus still in the tank at well
after Queen B1 well it's giri that's
thinking at the moment right and uh as I
said giri probably will spend some time
here because he wasn't calculating
before Magnus moved there wouldn't make
any sense to calculate before Magnus
played so now that Queen B1 is on the
board we're going to try to see if uh
gear recalculates something that's not
the queen trade however it does seem
pretty risky to do anything that's not
that I don't see any good moves common
tricks for example include playing Rook
B5 and any time you put something on a
light Square you have to be really
careful ful this would instantly lose to
Bishop D3 check we're even taking on B5
first uh I don't see either Knight takes
H3 or crazy ideas like Queen takes F2
immediately coming close to working so
that's not going to happen it becomes
the question what can black do that is
not simply exchanging the queens and
going to what seems to be a pretty
drawish end
game I think this I think this position
if I was gir I would probably just snap
that Queen and say okay I have a knight
your three pawns are not going to beat
me I should be okay and the only
remaining game that we haven't seen in
some time is the aonian game against
hammer and I will remind the viewers
that this king that's currently sitting
on B3 was actually on G3 only a few
moves ago and Aron decided to move it
all the way across the board and he went
from G3 this is actually the exact same
position which is funny Bishop B5
checked and then he simply moved the
King around to the queen side the
question is what did he gain from that
the answer I'm not sure uh obviously the
king doesn't have any penetration
squares on this side of the position
because of the B5 Pawn holding onto the
C4 Square so aroni is going to have to
prove why exactly he maneuvered his King
all the way there that's right so some
solid defensive efforts here by Hammer
yeah I don't think he has anything to be
worried about immediately I'm sure aroni
will try to create further threats but
for the time being it seems like
Hammer's holding on without that many
problems this should end in a draw with
good play we're going to see if he
continues his defensive
efforts that's right so what might be
the longest game today is Nakamura
Carana well I expect this game to go
rather long and whereas the Nakamura
Karana I mean if Karana keeps playing
the way he's playing this is not going
to last long Nakamura is just going to
take all the pawns and win which to me
is incredibly surprising the way that
Carana played so brilliantly yesterday
effortless technique fantastic PE
placement and then he plays like G5 is
this the same guy and then good
preparation arounds one and three is
black yeah he had no problems in the
opening today either it's not like it's
not like he got what I feel outplayed or
he had a difficult position he just
committed suicide and it's I don't
understand how this happened he's not
completely lost yet there's still a lot
of chances for uh hikaro to go wrong and
for karon to create counterplay so
there's definitely it is definitely not
a dead position but I mean why's
Advantage is huge it might just play
Rook to H7 so instead of Rook H5 kind of
tickling those pawns right away he
started with Rook H7 and uh this move
makes sense he does have the direct
threat of Rook G7 EXC absolutely direct
thread of Rook F Rook G7 which would
Target the G pawn and if it moves
forward I'm going to invade on G5 anyway
and then suddenly the pawn on F5 will be
completely defenseless so already we're
seeing a couple of variations in which
uh Kar can simply not hold on to his
phone so what's what's this all about I
mean the structure is so weak I don't
really understand R K7 that much that is
strange I don't
understand I mean what what is what is
Kon
doing G5 Rook
A7 I don't know he's headed towards just
a
loss Yik
right well if Nakamura were to win this
game he would join
toala the top of the Sammy yeah
absolutely and he has everything served
uh to take this game which is not
something I expected considering the
opening but to be fair I also didn't
expect Kar to just say I don't care
about my structure I'm going to make it
as bad as possible and just allow a free
file for my opponent's
Rook yeah it's much easier to play this
with with white as well there's
something that has to happen for karon
to actually create counterplay but I
don't see it he's slowed down
tremendously he's down on the clock by
so much I mean I I don't know what's
happening what what happened to this guy
in the last
hour let's take a look at the uh
standings after two rounds and think
about how they may shake up after three
so yes we had a five-way tie for first
and it looks like nagamura has got the
edge in his game while tapala is already
won so two and a half points for velin
and perhaps sore will join
him umash gra definitely not joining him
Carana looks he's just playing for a
draw giri also unlikely to drain
so nakam more
might end up being in the sole lead
after this round toal right they will be
sharing the lead at the top with two and
a half out of three which is a fantastic
score for both of them uh although both
of them got there in kind of a strange
fashion I mean toal of winning one game
completely out of luck I mean you can't
call it anything but that another game
was simply gifted to him today by MBL in
a series of Mistakes by the Frenchman
from opening preparation to just bad
peace placement well Nakamura it seemed
like today he didn't try anything
special he didn't do anything out of the
ordinary he shuffled pieces around for a
little bit and thear is the one that
decided hey here have a
point murus has some news for us on a
game well I'm still studying that game
between car between Carlson and giri
that position that you know if you think
about this position you mentioned this
Alejandro give the this position to
someone and say solve white to move and
win it wouldn't even be fair because
after Bishop F7 check King takes Queen
E4 you don't even know what to suggest
for black there's so many moves that
you're going to say so what what should
I say black should do now just take a
look at this sacrifice Rook takes B5 the
queen is hanging instead of playing
Queen E4 you hope to play Queen E4 and
play Bishop F7 on the next move but
instead the right way is to play Bishop
F7 first king takes and this is the
position I'm talking about you say okay
so what are Black's defenses black could
play the Queen back to d8 to stop a
knight from going to G5 black could play
Rook G8 black can move the king to G7
and all these lines you have to
calculate and all of them are just crazy
uh well not all of them but most of them
are crazy let's take a look at one Queen
d8 bringing the queen back to stop the
knight from going to this Square you
want to know what the immediate response
is the Knight goes another Square
sacrifice give me this guy and then I
don't touch this one I check you here on
AG s and now suddenly your king is being
encircled by just these three pieces
alone and the rest of the army has to
watch this night is not going to affect
the action in any way after King to f8
you can play this check and now the King
has to go to E7 because it can't go on
the G5 because of Rook G3 and of course
this is just going to be a crush the
Queen the and pieces are going to attack
so quickly we'll start just with Queen
F4 and threatening some discoveries you
got four pawns for the bishop but this
discovery check is menacing this one the
king is is caught in a crossfire that's
lights out so if we go back to this
position here after the check and King
F7 and queen to E4 other defenses for
Black Knight takes D5 as a defense uh
that's not going to work for a number of
reasons well Knight takes E5 is still in
the position as a winning move that's a
a killer uh other moves as well will
work like Queen H7 is too much to bear
after King up again Knight takes E5 we
see this sacrifice because the rook and
queens are going to just crush the King
again look at these four pieces five
pieces excuse me a cluster meaningless
cluster on this side while all you need
is a naked King and three hungry pieces
chasing it beautiful beautiful finish if
Magnus had found this move he would have
won in fantastic style yasan talks about
the legend of Magnus Carlson growing
that would have been the start of a
legend Bishop F7 but let me tell you you
can forgive even a world champion for
missing such a spectacular line as
Bishop F7 guys although it's funny
because I the reason I think Magnus
might be a little bit upset is only
because in that game with singfield Cup
against aonan that complicated end game
where he could have won and uh leavon
put up a brilliant defense MH Magnus was
so upset at himself and it really it
didn't seem like Mortals that it was uh
obvious by any respect well yeah and
also that Leon really played well to get
earn that draw right but then again the
win wasn't um something brilliant it was
just like technique here technique there
he missed a couple of defensive
resources and it was well within reach
whereas I don't think anybody would have
said give Carlson an infinite amount of
time to figure this position out and
yeah he should have done it but he was
under under time pressure he missed his
chances a couple of times and he and
Leon played quite well and Leon played
really really well to draw that with a
vanura type of idea but this position
man I don't know he's just I think he's
just going to laugh about it like how he
might laugh how can that be a move show
it laughter seems like a you you can't
you can never be
wrong I mean you always have a good
chance of being right if you predict
that Magnus is just going to laugh at
something because he applies his dark
humor to everything even his first round
lost that's true well we do have a
couple of moves gir decided to swap
queens and after King h8 which seemed
forc the move Bishop E4 with what we see
on the board Gary's currently thinking
where he's going to hide the Rook or if
he is going to hide the Rook at all he
actually doesn't have to he could play
Down um what would be considered two
Rooks against two pieces and a rook but
a bunch of pawns for the side with the
two Rooks for example he could play
something like Rook D1 which is probably
not the best but just as an example Rook
D1 here and take on e4 it's a it's a way
of defending the position I don't think
that most Rook games are going to be
winning anyway if I sacrifice my Bishop
on G2 at some point to be fair this more
pleasant for white uh on the other hand
he might just play Rook B5 allow takes
takes and takes on
E5 after which again I expect that there
must be more than one way of making a
draw here for black you have a full
Knight here and even though the three
pawns seem to be dangerous they should
be able to be controlled uh with certain
Precision some news on Nakamura
Karana
some really big news actually in that
game and the engines are saying that
it's only a little bit better for white
not enough to win but I think the rest
of us looking at this position say
you've got to be kidding this looks like
black is getting steamrolled he played
the move did Carana F4 after Rook to H7
and now G takes F4 G takes F4 four is
possible for Nakamura and now this is
the key move right now instead of taking
back and shattering in the structure
what about the move E4 and all of a
sudden this F Pawn is simply dead just
dead the rook's going to H4 is going to
take the pawn it's going to keep
pressure on this line and then he's
going to try to work the guy over this
looks like a really bad position uh the
line the engine's giving A4 B takes A4
Rook takes A4 giving away the F7 Pawn
that looks like engine just not knowing
their end games that just looks stupid
to have to play Rook A3 check King D2
Rook A2 King E1 yeah and now I've
Consolidated and even if you go after my
Pawn with Rook to A3 even this Pawn I
might give you this Pawn in some cases
and just take here and have two
connected pass pawns but he could also
play this move if he likes this looks
like technique time and Nakamura I think
smells blood Kanan has really blown it
you were right Alejandro the move G5
earlier is like what you just
intentionally open up the H file for the
other guy and now you suffer crazy
development from a player who's a really
strong player at that for him to play G5
is is just hard to believe and we see
there these two players are playing
Magnus and giri they're seemingly going
towards a draw one of the more exciting
draws we've seen in a while right
definitely a very exciting draw and a
very strange position in a Nakamura
Karana game and even the engines believe
that it's only a little bit better it
does seem like sometimes they still tend
to Mis evaluate ran games we're going to
have to see if they manage man to find a
way to defend here for black and in that
scenario we do go back to this idea of
Pawn takes F4 Pawn takes F4 E4 which was
what we had considered uh Jen and I in
this position bringing back the rook in
order to take the pawn for free in order
to not have to shatter my own Pawn
structure after the move which seems
forc to me A4 takes and Rook takes A4
how else can I justify putting the Rook
on the a file Rook takes F7 check here
check I don't want to give up the F2
Pawn I must go back to E1 I mean it does
seem like in most scenarios this is uh
this is pretty much lost I don't know if
King C3 gives me enough chances to
create counterplay but to be fair I
would sincerely doubt it in this
position it doesn't seem to be enough
after for example Rook takes and the
simple Rook F3 holding everything
together I don't know I'm very baffled
at this position I expect Nakamura to at
least test Kar for a while the
continuation is very obviously going to
be Pawn takes F4 Pawn takes F4 and E4 I
can't see Nakamura taking on F4 because
at this point why would you why would
you shatter your structure like this and
make your winning chances so much more
difficult when you have the chance of
going simply E4 and putting the pressure
on the Pawn With The Rook this looks
really really bad for black there might
be some miraculous save karona I would
usually say plays very well and has
great technique I might find some
resources but the way that he's playing
this end game just completely baffles me
we have a couple of moves on the board
as we can see and yes they actually did
follow the variation that we were
considering well I don't think I
expected anything
else we have uh people thinking in
different games we have three remaining
games without results uh the game that
we just saw between Nakamura and Karana
we also have Leon aronian playing
against J l b Hammer trying to press for
a position that seems very drawish I
don't see how aronian can really try to
penetrate this Fortress that the
Norwegian has it up there's plenty of
ways to try too hard especially with the
King on B3 is uh if you try to break
open the structure at any point you have
to be worried that when this Pawn
exchanges itself for this Pawn on E3
that this Pawn is going to be rolling
down the board I'll be worried about
that in certain variations so and that's
going to be completely out of the
picture since uh Ronan did play the move
F3 but after the move F3 is is I mean
it's almost like giving up there's no
way to break through anywhere and yeah
it just seems like a draw I don't see
how he's going to take advantage of the
fact that this pawns are Superfluous
since B7 is not really participating in
the position but I mean I don't see
anything to do at all after F3 I think
that hammer exited good defense and it's
is going to end in a draw after a couple
moves I just don't think that Aron can
really try for that long he already took
his King all the way down to the queen
side from the king's side what else is
there to do yeah want to try
that and meanwhile uh Magnus Carlson and
Anish gir seem to be moving pretty
quickly well yeah this is the obvious
ideas of Rook D7 or Rook B5 they didn't
really matter takes on B7 takes on B7
and of course from takes C5 uh this is
all something that we had considered and
uh there's several options here for
black there's no Checkmate threat on H5
because my Knight's covering and so I
don't have to worry about it for the
time being that being said why not go
ahead and trade off a couple of Rooks
with the move Rook G7 and I think that I
mean three pawns should not beat a
knight in this
position Jen would you be worried here
with black even if you're playing Magnus
Carlson no no not so much looks pretty
dryish
we'll see how the players proceeded of
course this is not a complete draw
perhaps white can try some tricks if I
had to choose a side I would be white
but I wouldn't expect to beat anybody in
this position not unless they made a lot
of
mistakes as these games wind down let's
take a look at tomorrow's
pairings well we got Alexander Guk
versus John lewi Hammer we've got topala
versus
K vers Max
vashi versar Nakamura
and versus 9 far so the rematch again of
the World Championship uh cycle of the
past two years that's going to be an
interesting game to watch we're going to
have to see some of the leaders if they
can defend their strength and definitely
talo with the tough choice of going for
the kill against aronian or trying to
solidify his advantage by playing it
safe against the aronian who's just
incredibly strong when he's on shape the
question is is he right
now well I think we're actually going to
see a lot more play today
though from aronian no in general yes in
general I think this is going to go go
quite a while this will this will go for
quite a while absolutely I mean even
aonian I think will try to play press
for some time and the big one is a carse
Nakamura will go the big question will
be if Nakamura can break Karana in this
position and he as I said he didn't have
to do anything Karana already gifted him
uh most of the tools that he needs to
create some kind of decisive end game
it's up to Coran to see if he can dig
himself out of this bad situation this
one will take will go the distance I
think not is going to try to squeeze
every drop he can out of this position
right and as we mentioned earlier this
was completely unnecessary for Karana if
he manages to save this by some miracle
or another he will still be kicking
himself for playing so badly in this
position oh yeah oh yeah and for having
to suffer right and I'm not saying that
he's going to achieve it I mean he might
just as well lose I don't I don't think
he can draw if white plays absolutely
perfectly you think it's more likely to
be a win here than a
draw I think it's 50/50 I'm not sure
there's so many variations in which the
C Pawn can become good even if white
obtains the this for example uh this
Pawn on B3 disappears for this one this
pawns on F7 and F4 are taken and all we
have remaining is somehow this Pawn
going forward once I eliminate
D3 uh trying to create counter place so
for example in the line that M was
showing us takes takes check here check
here and maybe something like uh not not
this move uh Rook A3 and taking on D3
perhaps you can try to make this into a
draw it's very similar to the ideas in
the gidi versus Anan game from yesterday
where Anan had two connected past pawns
but his King was very weak and this Pawn
just created a lot of counterplay but
this obviously seems a lot worse than
that position where giri had the one
Pawn here karan's king is not nearly as
active his rook's not as well placed
this Pawn is very very Speedy I think
that here Nakamura definitely has much
better chances than Anand did so I don't
know if uh this is something that Kar
really wants to go for but on the other
hand I don't see anything
else well as these games start to uh
shape up into the second time we're
going to take a break and be back and
see if K can survive here absolutely
that's going to be a big question for
the
[Music]
standings
o
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
e
hello St Louis we're here in Norway with
five-time World chess champion vishy
Anan
vishy how how are you
feeling fine I mean today was um game
where I think both of us were scared at
some point and uh we're just very
complicated I mean I'm really dying to
get back up and figure out what what
exactly happened but um sure I'm fine
yeah I it seriously it was a a great
pleasure watching the game I mean for me
personally I thought it was a tremendous
battle and as usual he gets into his
time trouble but he finds all the moves
he needed to to hold the game you were
putting pressure on him I felt through
most of the game yes but he's very
resilient I mean um the thing is time
pressure doesn't particularly phase him
so he uh he's kind of cool and I've
learned to ignore also him and vasil
I've learned to just ignore their time
pressure because um you're the one most
likely to blunder if you try to take
advantage of that but um I felt we both
stepped up when when we needed to I mean
there was a moment when I felt I was
getting into trouble I mean King G2 and
F4 looked good and then I Sly wasn't so
sure mhm but 5 I didn't like and um I
think later on he also played some very
good
moves uh just SW switching to another
note for a moment uh the next event of
course in St Louis in CA and I'm sitting
there thinking in my history uh when was
the last time you played in a tournament
in the United
States that would be a New York 1995
that's what I yeah you have to well that
was the the match that was the match but
I meant to tournament actual tournament
well it could have been one of the grand
pris but you you want a classical
tournament as opposed to the Intel maybe
I've never played a classical tournament
in the US that's what was going through
my mind I was really having a hard time
placing you in the United States in a
classical tournament yeah but we haven't
had Rex for a for a long time I mean we
have had Rex only since recently
otherwise I would have probably played
before we're looking forward to your
visiting the United States in St Louis I
wish you good luck in the rest of the
tournament okay thanks thank you that
was five times World chess champion this
wathon Anan sharing with us uh what I
found to be an absolutely superb battle
here in round three of the Norway 2015
chess tour back to you in St
Louis Cardinals in chess fanatic at the
world-renowned chess club in Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame St Louis status as
the chess capital of the nation is on
Full display with a welcoming
environment and Scholastic outreach
program that works with over 100 Schools
our goal is to teach play and promote
the sport so whether you've played for
years or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to
offer
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor
louis.com
2014 was a great year for chair chess 24
brought you live interactive broadcasts
from Top tournaments a Play Zone where
you can take on opponents from all
around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your Chess By solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos chess 24 on mobiles
and tablets most features are free but
limited for registered members chess 24
is offering a a special premium
membership for just $999 per month or
$99 per year see you at chess24.com
[Music]
welcome back to round three of the grand
chest store we've got three games still
going and you know it seems that Carana
is in trouble against Nakamura the other
two seem steered towards the draw
but when hard to say well it is
difficult to say absolutely aronian I I
don't see him finding any way of
penetrating the solid position that John
Lamer has come up with the noran doesn't
even have any problems with his Queen
side structure anymore it's not like he
can play for a win either but I don't
know how they're going to agree to a
draw or how it's going to work out but
they just can't push beyond their
boundaries they can't penetrate their
opponent's position so this does seem
like it's going to go towards equality
in the game between Carlson and giri
finally have a unusual end game between
uh the world champion and giri where
white has three pawns for a piece and
obviously because even if the three
pawns disappeared this is still a draw a
very basic one at that Rook cannot beat
uh will not lose against rook and Knight
under most circumstances well it's very
unlikely that white can do anything
either because actually there are many
scenarios if which even if black loses
the Knight for just the G Pawn some of
those set games are still drawn and it's
very hard to believe and it's almost
impossible to believe that's going to
happen so yeah this is pretty basic draw
uh they probably just have to figure out
a way to do it uh in the rules you have
to either do a three-fold repetition or
aspiration from the Arbiter who
determines that it's a completely drawn
position and in this case it's not
completely drawn so I could see the
Arbiters making them play a few more
moves but I have no doubt that this will
end in a draw that's right so Carlson
will get on the scoreboard well that
leaves nobody with zero points I don't
think we expected anybody with zero
points well we didn't expect uh Bagus to
have half out of three either definitely
not he still would be at the bottom of
the standings uh since chrisuk drew his
game so and Hammer I don't think will
lose against aronian that's right so
he'll still be at this whole he'll still
be in the basement where he will hope to
maybe bounce back with a win with black
against thean tomorrow well we
definitely won't be betting him on the
basement in the final of the tournament
definitely not betting for that but
still it looks like the position here is
hopeless but they have to go through the
motions and the only game that is of
Interest still at least in my opinion is
the Nakamura versus Karana game in which
we have all the moves that we had
predicted would be played uh F4 break
happened and then E4 A4 in order to
bring the Rook back to life Nakamura
captures on F7 also threatening this
idea of Rook takes F4 which is very
powerful check King D2 check King E1 and
we had analyzed all of this before we
went uh for a commercial break and I
still think that even though karona has
some slim chances for drawing this seems
closer to a win than it is to a draw
that being said Rook are always very
very tricky so I'm not entirely sure if
there are some resources here for Fabian
to hold on to the position I agree with
you though I'd put it at
6040 yeah I don't see how Corona can
force
6391 I guess there's always a chance
that why can lose this we were Lear we
learned we learned that weird things
happen maybe Nakamura will also forget
that he doesn't have additional time
after 60 moves and he waste his
remaining 1 hour 13 minutes and some
seconds that he has left yeah well nak
didn't show a ton of sympathy for his
nesis in that game it's hard to of
course and it's uh a think many of the
players v a lot of
sympathy well because Magnus you know
he's the guy to be he's a HomeTown hero
I think it was a bit of a maybe shot in
forid right I I just think that not
knowing the rules doesn't really inspire
a lot of sympathy among anybody so in
this case I can't say that I don't know
because I feel like if it was one of the
lower rated players in the tournament
like if it was hammer or something
people would feel sympathetic perhaps I
can see that but even then I think
Hammer being so excited to be this is
explain the grand chest to I think he
knows the rules I think he knows the
rules pretty well I don't think that he
should have told his buddy
well again this is one of those things
that you just assume the world champion
knows but Al last this is where we are
and Magnus Carlson finds himself with
zero points but will'll probably draw
the game
today and uh I I can't my Spanish is a
little rusty but uh somehow pacoo is
saying G5 double question mark by
Fabiano
Carana he was not impressed by that move
pako the strongest player from Spain
tweeted at us in Spanish actually saying
the technique of Grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura is much better than what people
seem to think but that being said Mama
Mia B5 and G5 from Fabiano
OMG I got that well this is basically
the reaction that I had upon seeing
those moves it's how can you make your
position so bad in the quickest amount
of time possible and he found them he
found the
way he's going to be suffering here for
a while and he's actually also running
out of time he only has 18 minutes for
the remaining uh 11 moves wait psych
just kidding he doesn't have any more
time at 60 so he actually is dropping
very rapidly in time and he has to play
CH I he he needs to start making moves I
know his position is difficult but there
are certain variations where he'll need
to calculate very accurately if he
doesn't have the time to do it in a
complicated Rook end game he's just
going to
lose and Maurice uh your thoughts on
this battle will Cara go
down well it looks awful and if you look
at the position when he played this move
G5 this Rook on C1 it it's doing nothing
it's a just a random piece sitting there
it's move 40 in a grandmas game these
two players if they were playing without
uh the rules and by the way very
specific drawing rules uh in effect in
this tournament that would actually
prevent them from accepting a draw in
this position so apparently the rules
are that first of all it's got to be a
dead draw or I mean a dead draw or you
cannot take a draw or it's got to be a
three-fold repetition of some kind uh
Perpetual they can find the players uh
can certainly repeat moves in a position
like this but if it was just a plane
let's get to 40 moves and you accept the
draw if he had made his 40th move any
sort of Rook move nondescript move
Nakamura and off of the draw Nakamura
said of course this is this has been
drawn forever what did he do on move 40
the dreaded move 40 by the way since
it's the move that makes time control
often mistakes happen there he decided
to activate White's Rook on purpose why
don't we just play G5 and give white an
open file after capture capture and Rook
to
H1 why would you it's it's even hard to
conceive that he would make such a move
that's incredible that he would just
gift white an open Age file regardless
of even if that was a draw doesn't make
any sense at all that he played that
move again at move 40 he's going to have
to explain himself certainly one of the
worst moves he played in a couple of
years no question about it maybe even
longer than that so he's suffering for
sure will he make a draw in that
position I really don't know but he
looks looks like he's going to suffer
and I would bet he's going to lose the
game we'll see if he can come up with a
miraculous way of saving himself now
that
said when we started this tournament we
we have to look to see who's on form in
the event who's the guy you should be
watching who is who's the guy you think
is playing the best of everyone after
the first two rounds without question
you'd point to fabbi I mean after all he
had that beautiful draw well solid draw
at least against Anan and then he
crushed no way of footing no other way
of footing it crushed Magnus Carlson you
would have thought he was the one to
look at after the first round as the key
guy playing well mexin Vash lra would be
running a close second as a matter of
fact although he had a little bit of
trouble against L uh against hammer in
his game but VRA that first game he
played looked wonderful it wouldn't have
been it wouldn't have been topov giri
was a little shaky uh on this list and
Nakamura himself was playing so okay
although he suffered yesterday against
topalov what do you say now about round
three after three rounds topalov is
sitting pretty the guy who should have
lost round one is sitting pretty Karana
who looked like he was doing great now
he looks like he might even lose giri
who did didn't play well in round one
should have lost well let's not
overstate that but yeah he was much
worse against Carlson it's hard to point
at a player and say that's the guy he's
running away with it right now they're
going to have to solidify their play
these players but I think of everyone
Nakamura probably feels the best uh
maybe toala feels a bit lucky he he was
basically given two games but Nakamura
probably feels more like I'm playing
okay I maybe not be playing brilliantly
but I'm not losing and I'm holding down
the fort and I'll see if I can win these
games so still no clear favorite
emerging after three rounds of the
Norway chess 2015 event guys that's
right Maurice and I like a comment that
ECM just made on Twitter he said that
carolana is scared of Nakamura and
Nakamura is scared of Carlson and
Carlson is scared of carolana no that's
sure I agree with that but that makes me
think that chess players should now use
rock paper scissors with Carlson Carana
and Nakamura I'm very sure that that's
not the case at all but yeah it's
interesting how I mean in terms of like
the differential ratings and performance
at least you could say that um Karana is
Dawn pretty poorly versus Nakamura
especially if he loses this
game well again it depends on your
definition very poorly but I see in the
same sentence that you're comparing
karan's performance bad performance
against Nakamura to nakamura's bad
performance compare that I mean that
would be a very kind of comparison is
that that would be an unfair game of
rock paper scissors now yes life is
unfair but I like I like that it's a
good way to settle thing what would you
throw what would I throw here no would
you throw Nakamura Carlson car no of
course I mean Carlson is the strongest
player in the world and even though he
has bad tournaments he has bad games
Corona beats him once in a while I mean
he has a positive score against the
other two right so what is there to talk
about well no I'm not asking you who the
strongest player is oh in this case no
Carlson Carlson Carlson Caron of course
of course I mean the ratings don't lie
li no they do not lie and in this I feel
like you wouldn't be very good at rock
paper scissors me no horrible at rock
paper scissors I can tell because that's
what we're playing here and you don't
get
it I you can understand it's rock beats
everything now he'll choose the rock
that's the rock paper scissors I'm
playing here exactly that's what I'm
saying
Maurice well I don't know about rock
paper scissors but uh Karan is getting
his head bashed in right now you take a
look he just played the move Rook to D2
uh let's just start here Rook A2 check
King to F3 and now Rook to D2 and simply
Nakamura has to find the move Rook to D7
and this is going to be painful why
because after King C6 Rook to D5 black
doesn't have anything to do if Rook
moves down to D1 then just simply King
takes F4 and if you're and after Rook to
D5 if the Rook moves away well let's say
a move like Rook to A2 then now white
can just trade this guy off and the game
starts to just simplify itself where
white simply has a big Edge he's going
to bring his Rook over and pick off the
F Pawn that's an easy win and another
line after Rook to D5 is if you move
your king away to the B6 Square well
guess who's going to start marching down
the board this E Pawn and the game is
just about done this is over Rook D2
does nothing at all Nakamura just has to
find Rook to D7 and he's still sitting
on the move right now let's go back to
this position after Rook to D2 Rook D7
and if he finds this it's going to be
simple easy way to win the game he'll
just be about four moves away from
proving that he has an overwhelming
Advantage if he didn't believe it
already if the rest of us didn't believe
it and was wondering what was going on
we all can see very clearly after that
move and Nakamura looks trained on the
position I think he's going to find it
and he's going to move into the
leadership board onto the leadership
board with topalov at two and a half
points a great performance for him a
great result anyway and for Fabiano he's
going to remember that move G5 uh for a
long time he's gonna have nightmares
about that tonight for sure guys
absolutely it does seem like Rook D7 is
a very strong idea just keeping the
pressure on the position uh I don't
think that karon would play King C6 in
that case I think he would at least try
to go forward even if it doesn't work
but I guess here in this position just
the advance of the pawn is too strong
after E5 yeah this SS completely such a
strong PA such an awkwardly placed Rook
for for carolana right exactly there's
just no tricks here unfortunately for
him the move C4 doesn't work trying to
at least get some counter playay based
on the pin but I mean Rook B7 check
seems to just be completely decisive in
this
case yeah this is just really easy so I
don't expect any of this to
happen but yeah Rook D7 has Maurice SS
to point out would be the final nail on
the coffin for Karana who played just a
horrible how do you play so well one
game and so badly the next well we're
going to have to ask Arana that one
because I really don't know let not
asking like that man I think a brutal
brutal commentary you know I I
personally think he's going to say it
himself I think that's what he's going
to say that he'll come out you won't
have to ask him he'll say how could I
play so well yesterday and play like
such garbage today how is that possible
that's exactly how these guys talk about
themselves so I don't think it's a
question of us being brutal you look at
Nakamura when he wins games he talks
like that himself so I play like garbage
I won the game but I play like crap so
they're very objective about their play
and you know you don't become a strong
chess player like them without being
able to take criticism and being able to
criticize yourself and bouncing back
from it well I would say that fa looks
like he's turly red but I feel like he's
that color what he's winning
also like I saw him kind of look he
actually kind of has a poker face he
looks almost the same as he did against
yesterday when he was crushing Magnus
Carlson yeah but I think he knows he's
busted here yeah of course he does but
unlike Nakamura you couldn't you
couldn't really tell by his body
language right and his face Kamura just
making some quick calculations about
what's going on I think he's as
surprised as anybody that Karana got
himself into this I think but what's he
GNA say after the game I wonder he's
going to say pretty much the same thing
that he thought it was equal and then
suddenly I was winning along the lines
of topalo topalo said well today I did a
little prep I developed my pieces and uh
somehow I won and this is exactly what
Nakamura did somehow he won it's very
unclear how because he didn't do
anything his position was okay but his
opponent was the one that just gifted
him the
point so now were on move but actually
looking away from the board right he's
probably just calculating hour on his
clock you know just goes to show that
Fabiano exhausted the possibilities he
knows he's winning he doesn't want to uh
let go of the win he doesn't want to
make some kind of silly blunder that
allows counterplay he just wants to make
sure that he finishes this game well and
think about it this way I mean if Karana
managed to blunder like that so greatly
why not you know why not be a little
careful and finish this up in the
correct way meanwhile in the other games
Anish Ki still has the Knight against
Carlson this this game's not going
anywhere we have another draw Aron and
Hammer have officially drawn their game
Aron and Hammer after a series of moves
of and here we see
them nothing happened well there was
about 30 solid moves of Chess where
nothing happened in this game so it was
also another the most interesting but
you really like the Ron's chances to win
but Hammer played some good defense
Hammer played excellent defense he
bunkered down in the best way possible
and it was impossible for aronian to
find a way to break through the defenses
the D4 Pawn which was what Black's only
weakness held on strong there was simply
no way for him to make progress and
aronian had to admit at the end hey this
is not going anywhere I tried for 57
moves and let's go home let's rest up
for tomorrow did you say bunkered bunker
down bunker down can you say that down
hunkered and then there's a bunker yeah
maybe you can say both
Maurice he could hunker down in the
bunker something like that okay anyway
the the reality is that for Norwegian
fans Hammer is actually not doing so
badly after all he is on only minus one
he lost his first round against Nakamura
but for the players when they see him
you could you could guarantee especially
the ones who have white they're thinking
this guy's like 10 120 in some cases
rating points below me actually in some
cases 140 rating points uh they're
thinking I'm supposed to beat this guy
no matter what and if you don't win
there's a feeling inside like I'm not
I'm must not be playing well because the
guy I'm supposed to beat the easiest
player in the field I did not defeat who
gets to say that will aronian today for
sure and he knows he's not playing well
but the other guy Maxim vashi Agra who
gets what was up against it against
Hammer goes now against topolov and
loses like a child there's something
psychological people F just kind of fake
themselves out when they think they're
supposed to win because of rating and
you still have to play the player you've
got to play the game and Hammer is
showing that he's nobody easy to just
walk all over despite his first round
loss two draws to follow it up and he's
probably at his expected result right
now if not even a little bit better to
get those couple of draw draws against
absolute World beaters some of the elite
players on the planet so representing
Norway quite well is Hammer so far in
the competition
guys yeah I think M just can be quite
proud of his success not only qualifying
to this event but the way that he's
played so far I mean he did had that
opportunity against uh mvl to put
pressure and it's not something that a
lot of players can do where they can
grab a 2700 player with the wide pieces
and put pressure put pressure and try to
destabilize him that's what Hammer did
was he successful at the end not quite
but still it was a very good showing and
today he had no problems defending the
position against aronian even though
optically it seemed like he was slightly
worse he's had a good showing so far
we'll see if he can continue he has a
lot of tough rounds ahead of him but I
think that the Norwegians can be quite
happy that Hammer's representing them
well in stavenger that's right I I think
that he shows he gives off the the
feeling that he belong yes absolutely
nobody can say like this guy doesn't
belong at all and it seems like the
local Norwegians have been doing a good
job I remember that Ausin last year did
done a fantastic job in the same
tournament Maurice your thoughts well
speaking of the top Norwegian Magnus
Carlson himself we would have taken this
position as a draw a long time ago just
stop the game but because of the rules
of the tournament which I personally
love the players have to keep playing
and prove the draws and it's the Arbiter
who has to step in and say okay I agree
this is a draw or if it's there there's
a three-fold repetition but for the fans
who want to see the games the fans who
don't understand this grandm level they
want to see you play it out look at this
one that's starting to be a little bit
more interesting even though players
wouldn't have continued we got to this
end game that looks fairly even King H2
King H7 it's a knight for three pawns
made a couple of moves Here and Now
Knight H5 offering up a trade of pieces
trade of Rooks now rookie to and after a
couple more moves the I just Dro back
you know easy enough for Magnus to say
let's take the draw just put the The
Rook back on E2 Knight on F4 Rook D2
that would have been a draw it's pure
and simple Magnus said no I'm not losing
why why bother doing that so instead
after Knight to H5 he played G3 that's a
clear sign to his opponent I'm not
playing for a draw anymore maybe it is a
draw but we're going to keep playing
let's make moves so Magnus trying even
though he knows it's a draw to win the
game potentially at least to keep the
competition going keep the game going so
now after Knight F6 he play King G2 Rook
D7 offering a trade of Rooks again
trying to get toward a more simple
position where there would be a draw
Magnus said uh-uh we're still playing
we're going to see what happens in this
game Rook moved to D5 Rook went up to A4
and after Rook to E5 G4 now I'm not uh
mailing the win in or anything I'm not
going to jump up and down and start
start saying Harrah we're going to see a
victory but it's clear that Magnus is
saying I can't lose so why not just keep
trying and I'm sure his fans who were
really happy to see him get a great
position then dejected when they found
out he was no longer winning and they're
thinking keep trying Magnus you could do
it you could do it and so he's sitting
there trying to make some moves meantime
G's just making moves and saying really
seriously no I'm going to make this draw
here and uh we'll we'll just play a few
more moves but it's not going to happen
guys we actually have a um a a trade
here about some change here um Gary
decided to force a trade of Rooks and
played Rook E4 Magnus quickly captured
on e4 and now Knight takes E4 right of
course uh so the question is what can
you do here in this position and it
doesn't seem like it's much for Carlson
the three points are dangerous but uh if
I remember correctly the three- points
should not be the knight in this kind of
positions so we'll see if Gary's able to
hold that well he certainly seems
confident technique yeah why wouldn't he
he's a grandm after all you would expect
him to hold on to this end game but well
he confidently played rookie forward he
uh without you know without a lot of
thought so he's clearly pretty
comfortable to this we also have draw a
lot of moves in the game between
Nakamura and Karana we're down to our
final two games and Nakamura actually
did play the winning continuation Rook
D7 Rook D5 as Maurice had pointed out
Fabiano has just played the move uh King
B6 but I think even E5 here in this
position position is winning I believe
because after E5 King C6 E6 this Rook
cannot be taken because the pawn would
promote therefore E5 should be
completely winning and Nakamura will
joining the with two and a half out of
three this will be a big day for
Nakamura and he's going to be jumping
back up on the live rankies list we do
have a special guest with our grandmas
yaser Saran he is with Grandmaster Leana
Ronan
hello St Louis once again greetings from
Norway I'm here with leavon aronian
leavon uh what has happened in your game
today I thought I had an advantage and I
definitely had a very very nice looking
position and I thought I would convert
and but then I've played the wrong idea
putting the Rook on e4 I mean it looks
nice but probably black is not getting
in the
in the sank I I've actually what I've
missed that he can just play King G6 at
any moment and Rook entering to E6
doesn't lead anywhere so this what I
what I forgot and I mean when I was
going for this position on a move 20
something so very early on so from a
from a long distance away you thought
you had a a winning idea only to realize
that when you got to the position in
fact he can hold by just moving his King
back back and forth yeah although it's
not so easy because uh I always have
this E3 move takes and Rook to E6 but
somehow in the variations it just didn't
work so uh it was a kind of a mirrage
and I should have uh played something
more natural than Rook G1 and Bishop C1
I guess did you see any of the other
games for example for me the game that
uh vesselin too l one today you don't
see Maxine after 24
[Music]
minutes almost being in a lost position
with white pieces he won a a game I
would describe as too
smooth yeah somehow it doesn't feel
natural when your opponent puts the Rook
on E8 and then you you kind of play
Knight D5 so I think that's where uh
Maxim uh overestimated his position and
uh we have to talk about Magnus because
he's lost his two games and today uh
looks let's say that it will be a draw
of course there's some practical
problems for black still to hold but it
seemed uh that this was a game that
Magnus had to win to get back into the
tournament and it looks like he's not
doing it any thoughts as to what's
afflicting Magnus at the moment I think
there are many rounds but certainly uh a
a loss instead of a win in the first
round can actually upset anybody oh that
goes without question and now you know
the time control right yes very good
leavon thank you for sharing thank you
that was leavon aronian uh here in
Norway for round three back to you in
the studios in St Louis thank you leavon
and yaser what a treat yeah absolutely
it seems like um hiar didn't find the
move E6 which I think would have sealed
the deal but he should still will be
winning somehow I'm assuming um after
the move King C7 instead of playing Rook
D5 to repeat moves forcing King C6 then
E6 we already analyze so this Pawn is
Unstoppable in case that the king takes
the Rook so cute yes a very nice
something that Naka would see in a blz
game he have simply found a different
approach and after Rook D6 he I mean I'm
sure that White's still winning it's
also difficult to find a move here for
black
indeed so watching even waiting in this
game nak War Carana the future of
American
chess the present of American chess and
the future but we got some more future
of American chess In This Very chess
club that's right with a young Stars
program going on right now lots of
rating points up there and a couple of
floors above us that's right you
remember Jeffrey Chong um not only did
he earn his grandm title but he also won
the Chicago B right that was remarkable
yeah that's not easy it's a very very
strong tournament full of 2600 Grand
Masters and it was uh I am from the
Dallas for Worth area that's only 14
years old that managed to outplay
everybody Jeffrey JX
JX we don't seem to have a move here
from Nakamura just or from Fabiano just
yet after Rook D6 meanwhile charson will
be pushing with the three points against
a knight although I expect that should
be a draw at some
point uh Gary could still lose I
wouldn't put it completely past him but
okay it should be a
draw now which of these youngsters do
you think is most likely to be an elite
player well American youngsters I think
they're all going to become elite
players but when I say lead I mean like
top five top 10 they can't all be on
that right that would be hard for all of
them to me well there's three of them
they all get into the top five they have
something to say no
perhaps uh I mean it's not something
that I would venture to say now I think
they're all very very talented and I
think it's the coming years that's
really going to decide which one becomes
part of the elite it's not going to be
so much and you're thinking seavan Kaden
Sean Kaden Jeffrey a Wonder a Wonder
less a Wonder not so much because of his
talent but because he's younger than the
others so it's too early to say it's a
little bit too early to say but the
others are in a position where like they
need to start traveling a lot they need
to make sacrifices in order to just play
chess and they need to really really
dedicate their lives to it if they want
to reach the elite and we're going to
have to see if they're willing to commit
those sacrifices in the next few years
it's uh difficult to be part of the
chess Elite and well go to college or
something like that right and Maurice
your thoughts well Sam seon is just
amazing obviously youngest grandmas in
US history he is showing that he is
extremely talented you got to watch out
whoever you are the way he's coming up a
couple of years from now I think we're
certainly going to see him emerge 2600
player maybe even start to be a 2700
player and Jeffrey Jong last year he was
miraculous in the millionaire chess open
the way he started off that competition
beating dreev okay was on time but then
he beat uh Chinese Grandmaster in that
game in in that tournament he didn't
Trail off a little bit at the end but he
had put everybody on notice that he is a
baller and he's coming to play so I
wasn't totally shocked to hear that he
had gotten his grandmas title especially
the way he played last year in the
millionaire chess open and Awan D young
I mean he's just he's he's a Wonder
that's what he is extremely talented
player very gifted no question about it
I believe he's World under 10 champ but
that usually doesn't mean much except
the way he's starting to play now he has
tremendous potential great upside so
those three it's hard to say which one
of the three I would say sam Sean is a
almost given and the question is whether
or not the other two will join him as
they get more experience as time passes
along we know it's easy to be a prodigy
I know that sounds like a bit of a a
oxymoron but to actually sustain it in
later years and be among the elite now
that's where you separate the prodigies
from the heart workers so we'll see how
time goes but hey you're getting to
tutored by Gary
Kasparov that's kind of cool that's kind
of cool you expect them to go far with
that kind of tutelage that's right and
on a regular basis thank to the young
Stars program it definitely partnership
between the St Louis chess club and the
Kasparov chess Foundation it definitely
doesn't hurt so we'll see if Kasparov
can really work with them it's not only
jaspar they have a whole team of coaches
basically behind them that are making
them stronger and stronger every day so
we'll see if they can use all the
resources that is given to them that
well very few players actually get uh to
increase their level to the elite as we
would like to see them but I still don't
think you can say it's a given that
anyone is going to be in the top 10 no
of course I mean there's a lot of
competition around the world yes of
course there's a lot of competition
around the world and when you think
about it you got you're talking about
the top five right how many spots five
that's not a lot and there's a lot of
competition I mean Sean Jeffrey Kaden
they're between the ages I believe 13 to
15 who's their competition we and we
we're not wondering if he's going to be
an elite he's basically Elite give him a
couple other tournaments what is the guy
up to 2730 2740 that's their competition
and they need to well catch up with him
in what one or two years we'll see if
they can do
it I think they get more than one or two
aleandro that guy that guy is insane guy
he's a kid uh we is
unbelievable and many people are talking
about maybe he's going to be challenging
Magnus a little too early to talk about
that but actually maybe not I mean
you're that young and you're already
2730 that's pretty insane he just just
came like a shooting star out of nowhere
to show how much of a dominant player he
is but I think that the question of
whether or not a player will be top five
that's you can never answer that
question ever that's just that's just no
way you know the that that's going to
happen some people might not even
thought Fabby was going to get there
years ago and it seems as though the
game has actually concluded talking
about Fabiano the game has concluded in
nakamura's favor he has won the game a
shocking development after you saw 39
moves but move 40 certainly one of the
worst moves Carano has ever played and
Nakamura now tied for first here after
three rounds in the Norway chess 2015
wow um what to say about about this game
you know we're going to see these two
play more and more over the next few
years because we imagine the US
Championship the singfield cup the grand
chest tour and right there's G to be a
lot of more opportunities for Karan to
face against Nakamura not a good game by
car this is just about the worst move
I've ever seen in such an elite
tournament by Favi and by Favi yeah it's
I just don't understand it there are
there are miscalculations there are
hallucinations there are a lot of bad
mov I've seen I've seen people blunder
pieces but I'm this is strategically but
this is the Strategic basic let's look
at let's open a book on end games and
understand what an open file is type of
mistake so for me it's more
incomprehensible than anything I have S
in these kind of events so these are
like the two polls of today's round
Bishop F7 and G5 yeah the stratospheric
move that even Grand even super Grand
Masters can't find and then the move
that you would expect him not to want to
play to be fair I would I wouldn't
have I would have never found G5 either
I would have thought it was
illegal he would have F B7 he would have
F
G5 which one would you be more likely to
fine Bishop F7 definitely Bishop F7 over
G5 humble
brag Maurice yeah nobody nobody's going
to play the move of G5 G5 is is uh
Madness it's just mad like why would you
make that move it does nothing to
Black's position it doesn't help Black's
position at all we go back to that
position in the game we we'll see it and
see it again I would argue by the way
guys that this was not a bad game by
Fabby it wasn't a bad game it was a bad
move everything about the game was
normal everything just going along it
was it was a good game actually but you
know the famous I believe it was T who
said it often takes 40 good moves to win
a chess game and only one bad move to
lose it it that's what happened here he
played just fine throughout the entire
game everything about it was cool he
played well played solidly there was
even a point we thought he might be
slightly better but okay not enough what
is he doing and then in one moment this
move appeared on the board gave white
the H file and now was like what did I
do like what happened here so again not
a bad game just a howler of a move that
he will be kicking himself about his
coach must just just like can't believe
it who is this guy how did you make that
move please explain I think it will be
inexplicable for him to to made such a
move and allowed his opponent to so
easily win the game maybe he wasn't even
losing after that but it looks it looks
horrible so no explanation really none
yeah absolutely I don't think chof will
be very happy today with Fabby he's
gonna be saying incredible incredible
how can this happen I'm sure that wasn't
part of the preparation something tells
me wasn't part of the preparation but
trov doesn't only prepare his openings I
know that they work together in
basically every aspect of Chess and well
if this are his end games I think that
fa is in for a for a deep preparation
camp in that part of the game oh poor
Fabby I can just imagine studying in
games for eight hours
today well as long as stop playing moves
like this that's what it takes that's
not that's not an end game I'm sorry
that's not an end game that's not a
middle game that's not an opening that's
just dumb that's it you just don't give
up an open foul why would you do that I
I'm that's that's what he's going to say
there's no there not an endgame you just
why would you play G5 and give the guy
an open file it just doesn't make any
sense and he's going to have to explain
himself because he knows it there's no
question we all know it he knows it why
did you play this move he's gonna he's
gonna have to be the one to answer that
because it's
just he's probably like I said it's
probably the worst move he's played in I
don't know how long have you can you
think of a worst move Fabiano Carana has
played than this move where he just
donates a free fou and a huge Edge to
his opponent for no reason it's got to
be one of the worst moves he's ever
played well how would you explain it
that psychology if it's not a chess
error and then obviously it's some kind
of psychological
error I think he just forgot how to play
chess for a moment and then he made a
move and then he's like wait why did I
play that that's the only explanation I
I mean most blenders are moves that
people are way too good to play but they
happen anyway so the explanation is very
complex and we do have Grandmaster yeser
sarahan standing by with for a special
guest I bet you might be able to guess
who it is well it's definitely not going
to be
Fabiano well I don't know Fab is a
really good sport that's true he's a
very very good sport especially in the
singfield cup well he was winning every
game but you know sometimes sometimes
being a good sport is about winning
gracefully too he was a very graceful
winner as well he was very honest about
what he thought went right what he
thought went wrong even when he was
winning all his games and he said at
some point well it's true that I'm in
good form but it's also partially luck I
got lucky in certain games and people
would compare his result to to Fisher
and he would joke and say I don't
deserve that yeah he was very humble he
was very humble and well even he makes
mistakes as well
and here they are we've got Grandmaster
hikaro Nakamura leading the grand chest
tour along with topalo he's with cath
ter hello St Louis and welcome back to
Norway where we're with American
champion America's number one Hikaru
Nakamura now leading the vent hikaro
congratulations for your win today
thanks AER it was uh I mean not not the
way I would have expected to win but uh
you know I just ke kept playing the
position I think in many ways is having
the Sophia rules helped me I'm pretty
sure somewhere around move 30 I would
have offered a draw if not for that so
worked in my favor um I mean the
position throughout was pretty equal I
think up until the point when Fabiano um
exchanged these Rooks on D4 I felt if he
kept two sets of Rooks on the board
there was almost no way for me to do
anything but but once we got down to one
side I mean I I saw this idea of just
like uh putting this Pawn in A4 bringing
the king to see through and and I saw
that he had he had no entry Square so I
I knew that it was uh I mean little a
little bit better I don't think it was
much better but there there are some
rather serious practical problems for
black so uh things I mean seem to work
out at least in your game today I
recalled your conversation that you had
with Jennifer shahadi on in St Louis
long time ago where you where she was
talking about your style and you said
that you really enjoyed endings and she
was like shocked and it seemed to me
today you basically outplayed him
completely outplayed him in a drawn
ending and just pressure pressure
pressure made some slips and you
won yeah pretty pretty impressively yeah
but I mean okay it's easy to play End
games when you're on the right side
precisely much easier when you when when
you're better as opposed to being worse
but but I mean I I I just felt the Fabi
onor didn't sense the danger and then
kind of like he didn't sense it when we
got to The Rook ending and then he like
panicked with this B5 which after that I
mean it's very hard I think I think it's
losing objectively but uh it's just I
mean sometimes people uh I mean there's
pressure and it happens right there was
a sharp intake uh of breath when we saw
both B5 and G5 and when I said hikaro is
going to win this game I mean that was
really you you you said it very well
yourself once you got Rook on H1 you're
feeling really really good uh two and a
half out of three yeah very nice you're
sharing the lead I thought the game
today with topof was too smooth I was I
mean you don't see Maxine who's known as
pretty well prepared to be lost with
white in 24 moves yeah but I mean okay
Maxim lost I think four in a row in
haunty just a month ago so hopefully
it's not a sign of things to come um for
him but okay vaselin seems to be getting
all the luck in the tournament so far um
okay it's it'll turn it some point I'm
pretty confident of that absolutely hi
Caro keep up the good work and much
success for the rest of the tournament
thanks AER all right well there we are
America's Hikaru Nakamura number one
leading the tournament with topoff here
in Norway and wow uh big big surprises
in this the third round back to you in
the studio in St Louis yeah Gotta Love
nakamura's interviews Gotta Love uh yeah
his yes so we have a a couple of more
moves in the Carlson giri game this the
final game of the round that's right so
Magnus the only one who has a chance to
win this game of course considering that
right wait we can we make some kind of M
we can I guess if Carlson does forfeit
in time it still does count as a loss as
you can set up a helpmate exactly but uh
well we have a couple moves this end
game as I was mentioning uh with Maurice
soon to make jokes about Magnus losing
on time is it no it's not too soon so
here actually black has to find the move
King F6 to retain the draw and the
reason is that you can't allow White's
King to go into E5 and then into E6 so
you have to play something also the king
doesn't want to move backwards and allow
more space king F6 was played almost
instantly so it seems like a niche even
though he might have given white more
chances than he deserves still has the
draw on hand we'll see if he's able to
not mess this one up but considering
what Karana did with B5 and G5 what you
think it's like osmosis like it like
it's a it's a cold or something it just
like is contagious one person makes a
plunder the other one does too maybe
there's something going on in Norway I
don't know it's very hard to say but man
Karana playing B5 G5 is just very
strange of course I don't agree with
nakamura's evaluation with the position
that after B5 uh Karana was lost I think
that still the position was probably
okay but definitely after G5 it seemed
like everything just went downhill
topalo said that I mean Naka said that
topalo is getting all the luck in the
tournament so far perhaps not is that an
insult or a
compliment I'm not so sure coming from
Nakamura but I mean he also suffered
quite a bit against topalov and he
survived so I mean it's not like topalov
hasn't played his share of Good Moves In
This positions and put pressure
himself yeah that's
right so and it seems like okay so we
have we do have a couple of moves in the
game right we have the moves King F6 F4
Knight D6 check which still should be
okay King D5 King D5 and I'm assuming
you have to retreat with the Knight to
F7 perhaps I think knight8 might also be
okay Maurice any analysis from this
position yes what I find fascinating
about this position I have an exercise I
do with my beginning students I put a
three pawns and I put a bishop on the
other side just three pawns just like
this I put a bishop and I say okay see
if your Bishop can fight against the
three pawns and then after they work
with that I say okay now let's try three
pawns against a knight now the Bishops
are able usually able to fight against
three pawns but a knight just loses
immediately a knight cannot deal with
pawns marching down the board by itself
of course now you can drop Kings on the
board and the Kings have a big say in
what can happen next because of course
if a knight sacrifices itself for a pawn
and then a pawn takes back well the king
can take and that's two pawns and now
the question is whether or not the king
and pawn ending is actually a draw or a
win incredibly giri has given black
given white more than he deserves by a
long way after that Rook trade and he's
in a situation where actually he has to
find only moves and fortunately for him
he found the move King F6 natural move
to be sure but a move like Knight D6 the
engines already saying it's over bye
you're dead uh this position now after
King to D5 the king penetrates Knight to
F7 and here because this king is just so
active white is able to march down the
board he can play King to E6 and even if
you start checking white it's very easy
to get get out of these checks King here
and now this move and now he can just
relax the Knight has done nothing and
here come the pawns coming down the
board and this Knight just looks like a
flaky piece so there are maneuvers you
have to be careful for but of course gir
is a very strong player he played the
move King to F6 and now after F4 he
played Knight D6 King to D5 and now
natural was King F7 he's still in the
drawing Zone though with the move he
played Knight to B5 but he's going to
have to be a little bit careful Magnus
is probably probably looking at him and
thinking is there a blunder in you just
waiting I'm going to I'm going to just
just going to make some moves and see
you know who knows what could happen now
we've seen very strange things happen
already uh in Norway at this event
seeing how Magnus lost on time seeing
how badly Fabby played this endgame who
knows what could happen here but it
doesn't seem as though giri thinks uh
he's in any trouble at all and he's just
kind of relaxing while there he goes
starting to think again getting into the
position Magnus definitely will try to
win here but it looks for all R like
this should be a draw well I really like
the approach that he did with putting
the Knight on B5 and it looks illogical
at start but the idea is that you want
to swing the Knight around so that you
attack the pawns from behind and it
forces this King on D5 to make a choice
either I come and help my pawns or I try
to go forward and penetrate with them
but it can't do both at the same time
and the knight's going to make him
choose what he wants to do the idea is
that you're going to go Knight C3 check
and white is in no position yet to
advance his pawns that it would create
pockets for the king to hide in and
blockade them for example G5 the simple
King F5 already blockades pretty much
all of the pawns it's not something you
exactly want to do and if F5 you no
longer have the possibility of pushing
your G4 Pawn so it's not a very pleasant
Choice here and that's why the game
should be a draw in this position still
a little bit of work for giri but I
think he's figured out more or less how
to handle the situation that's right it
looks like Magnus Carlson's going to try
try to squeeze up out of air well
there's nothing to fear he's GNA he's
GNA just uh yeah there's no reason for
him not to play right of course I mean
in this position I think that there I
why not play until black only has you
know nothing left here there's three
pawns maybe a mistake from guy will give
him a win he's risking nothing so we're
going to sit him see him sit here for a
while and uh you know push this position
even if it doesn't actually lead to
anything now we've got a few interesting
pairings tomorrow um gik vers Hammer um
topala vers Ronan Fabiano Carana vers
Maxim bashier lra so both players coming
off a tough loss going to be playing
each other that's kind of interesting
Anish giri versus car Nakamura huge game
and visan versus Magnus Carlon so our
two tournament leaders right um
obviously I'm interested in those games
toala versus ran and G versus
interesting the game between vishan and
Magnus cars and uh you know two of the
people that actually haven't won a game
right playing each other and you would
think that they're probably at the top
of the leaderboard if you saw the game
the games uh from the beginning of the
tournament but here we are and it's
going to be topalo and Nakamura leading
the event they play against very tough
opponents and well every every opponent
is tough but but I think well playing
aonian so such a solid player gir with
the white pieces can always be quite
dangerous he has some very specific
preparations that he likes to throw
around so it's going to be a tough task
for Nakamura with the black pieces while
topalo well if he wants to increase his
lead he might as well try to pre on Le
who's not in the best of shapes when it
comes to his chess career but we're
going to see what he can do with it
meanwhile K might try to reassert his
form from the early in the tournament
against Maxim vasher gra because MBL is
also down Fabby has white pieces right
not only losing uh today's game in such
a bad manner but as Nakamura pointed out
in his interview he lost four games in a
row in the Grand Prix hunting man
something that is very rare at the top
level of chest Reon he's fallen so much
from the top 10 exactly so we're going
to see if he actually recuperates
mentally and see if he can I don't know
try to get on the scoreboard again it
will be important for him
psychologically but man playing kwana
with black it's not an easy spot to do
so so we got some interesting tweets
from some of our viewers uh Jonathan
tisdol said that he's impressed by hiar
Nakamura you can see him getting
stronger in every phase of the game
recently and thenan he actually played a
bit Carlson today I think we call it
Carl carlones carlones that's the word
well I don't know I don't really feel
like his position was the type where
you put more pressure here and there an
almost equal position your opponent
collapsed and he was just simply given
the point but to be fair uh he did set
up the position so that Karana made
mistakes and we have to give him credit
for that
no you don't you don't have to give him
credit he got lucky thanks just
kiding h no he I mean obviously you
pointed this out before that Nakamura
has lately really been showing his class
and all sorts of different types of
position absolutely it's not that old
Nakamura that just went crazy played
Kings Indians all the time tried to kill
his opponents from the get-go he's
played a lot more patient chess a lot
more I'm not going to lose chess I'm
going to play solid and it's really
paying off so at some point we have to
stop being surprised by this or can we
continually be surprised every time he
wins like an end game grind or I think
it's also his personality and he's like
attitude at the board even if he wins a
positional grind he still comes off as
this kind of like swashbuckling
character that's very true it's a it's a
and also it's just history right he's
been uh doing this for so many years
that his Sudden Change I mean it takes
some time to get used to you know we've
got a very important comment from Maria
emana who said says that she really
likes our matching glasses ties shirts
outfit combined with the colors of the
commentary today well of course that was
highlight of the day yeah of course we
we we we have a group Skype chat where
we talk about what we're going to wear
the next day man I wasn't
invited it's not of a Skye chat then is
it no we just get lucky we we run really
well with
outfits that's one way of putting it we
have move from uh call and he just
pushed the pawn from H4 to H5 and I'm
going to assume that there is more than
one way to draw against this uh
immediately the move Knight C7 to REM
maneuver back to E6 jumps to mind as
Maurice pointed out there are certain
variations in which if you give up a
knight for a pawn or two pawns it
depends on the remaining positions if
the opponent game is winning but very
clearly this one is not as I'm able to
capture the pawn on H5 immediately and
if I force the blockade here
on F5 I highly doubt that there are
winning chances in this position of
course I may be blundering something but
I don't know this looks pretty
drawish there's also the way of playing
Knight C3 check which might be perhaps
even more exact to go back towards E2 I
don't know I think Gary has a couple of
choices to draw and he did choose Knight
C3 which looks logical enough to
me and as I said earlier here Carlson
has to make the decision between going
forward or retreating to defend the
pawns neither of which should Grant him
a win played King D4 actually pretty
quickly so Maurice um you're thoughts on
whether Magnus is uh going to get
anything going
here this game is drawn for sure it
would it would be like a bolt of
lightning uh coming and just smashing
the chessboard in half maybe to make
anything interesting happen out of this
position it is clearly drawn interesting
though I was thinking about the round
and I'm thinking what's the move of the
round right you you like to do I like
sports center they do top 10 plays
what's the move of the round and from
from a positive side it's very difficult
to figure out exactly what that move is
because in fact in this round there's
just so many mistakes the move of the
round is probably a move that was not
played Bishop
F7 check that move that would have been
amazing unfortunately it was not played
and we see in multiple games that move
of the round were just bad moves mvl
playing the move Knight to D5 what was
he thinking from that position he's not
he's not winning but he's not much worse
or he maybe even not even worse then he
just puts his Knight on D5 and he's dead
like one move dead which one's worse his
Knight D5 or Fabiano's G5 both moves
horrible moves clearly Big Time mistakes
and of course we go back and we say
again Magnus Carlson missing the move
Bishop F7 so it really was a round of
bad moves and misses not to take any
away from the players who won their
games but still it was players feeling
the nerves and playing
uncharacteristically bad moves that
caused this round to be what it was guys
yeah it's interesting to see that the
best move of the tournament of maybe
even history which just was missed today
Bishop F7 I think would have gone down
as as just a fantastic opportunity I
think Magnus would be sad even though
even though it's ridiculous just because
it would be so historic yes absolutely
but here is where we are with Nakamura
winning his game against Karana due to a
terrible move topalo winning his game
against mvl due to a terrible game
overall from the Frenchman and we have
actually now uh Carlson after a very
entertaining and moved game against giri
probably having to concede the draw at
the end it that's way test is though
that a lot of the most beautiful
variations are not actually played yeah
that's actually very unfortunate in this
case sometimes the misses are just as
important as the
executions right but I mean everything's
like that right it's true in life as
well but a lot of times though in chess
the be when we say the beautiful
variations are the ones that are not
played it's usually it's usually like
well we're playing the good lines
unfortunately you won't play the the
crazy crazy variation that loses or the
the so-called best variation that loses
I remember getting this quote from from
uh Alexander Yin right he used to say or
he did say once he hates the fact that
his opponents plays stupid defenses
because it's like gee that one's so easy
I'll just beat you in that one why don't
you play that other one so I could show
how much of a genius I am right so yes
even though those variations don't get
played and we they're only in the notes
at least the it's only because the
player was winning anyway and his
opponent didn't allow those pretty
variations to show up those great Queen
sacrifices and the like in this case it
wasn't like that in this case it was
only one move wins he was clearly
winning and he didn't play the winning
move so it's it's this is just a case of
just missing a move completely unlike
those variations where the player did
see it but it just doesn't get played on
the board so that move Bishop F7 though
it's hard to even categorize it when you
think about it what what category do you
put it in Bishop F7 check like if you if
you really study that game that move
let's get to the move uh where was it
right right here what is the what do you
call it it's is it a clearance really no
I mean for what uh is it a a a decoy
bringing the king to
F7 what what is it it's just a move it's
just awesome is what it is and it just
wins and computers look at forcing moves
all the time they look at this forcing
one I mean if you thought about it you
might be inclined to think here that
Bishop 87 makes more sense right I mean
that one at least when the king takes
your queen ends up on this square with
check matter of fact that's hilarious I
didn't even think about that I didn't
know that this was the case but King 87
is actually a blunder Bishop 87 works if
you take it the computer is saying don't
touch this piece play the move King to
h8 because if you play King to H H7
Queen E4 does have him a check and all
the things are the same well Bishop H7
makes more sense but King h8 great
defense wow who knew that but Bishop F7
uh doesn't allow for that Bishop F7 now
if you play King to h8 you're in deep
trouble because guess who's going to
show up the Queen's going to show up
around here and the the attack is going
to be monstrous so Bishop 87 that's
human if you're going to even find it
Bishop H7 makes more sense Bishop F7
that's just mystical fantastic move and
will be remembered for a long time I I
think if you had to categorize it I
think it's a combination like many
tactics are combinations between two
things I'd say clearance and move order
move order I mean that's not really a
tactic but there should be there should
be a a word for a tactic that just
exploits it different move
order because you know once you play
que4 now where obvious that you might be
threading Bishop F7 but there's Rook f8
right I guess that's true yes so it's
like a tactic that explits move order
and
clearance yeah for me it's always
difficult to categorize tactics because
it seems to just U make them so you know
into a box into a box right but actually
I think it makes maybe for somebody is
strong as you it doesn't help and I
think for a lot of players having names
for things helps them no I have
appreciate when it's somebody's learning
about tactics maybe to give them names
and see the different examples but I've
never thought that solving positions
that were uh inside a chapter was a good
idea because you're in instantly biased
towards looking for a certain type of
tactic I would agree with that but I'd
also say that even for pretty strong
players I think that having names for
things could be helpful because so what
are we calling this one at the end did
we make a consensus we don't have a
property name for it yeah we still don't
have a good name awesome awesome what
kind of tactic was this awesome that's
what it was all right we're going to go
with that but um just having names for
things I think often makes people better
because like even even if you have a
name for something like the ver
vancora it's just like easier to find it
because you have that categorized in
your brain I see what you're saying and
you can like pull it out more quickly
that makes sense yeah like a reminder of
exactly what the situation is and
associated with something that you can
remember more easily yeah kind of like
monics or chunking that kind of thing
the memory tricks that's a good point or
I don't think any memory trick would
have helped Magnus unfortunately Bishop
F7 because this is so out of the world
it's not typical to anything else and
there's really no name for it that's
that's true Al we're grasping it all
right we're going to continue to see
we're grasping it SP the next time for
the next time this happens I don't think
that we're going to see anything like
this for quite a while this was very
unique I think that I don't think we're
going to see it in this grandchester in
the next grandchester a move like Bishop
F7 wow look at that posture right Magnus
well he's thinking he's he's like a
bishop right now he's not a perfect
diagonal strong Bishop
indeed Maurice I'm actually
impressed this guy there's no question
this position is a draw I I say there's
no question there are some losing
possibilities but look how hard he's
working you know he could just give up
the pawns like okay I'll just give it up
and just leave now instead of pressing
and pressing and pressing using energy
that could be safe for tomorrow's game
and then for the next uh six rounds
instead he is really focused and this is
typical Magnus we he takes positions
that everybody else says this is just a
draw dude why are you still playing and
Time After Time After Time he finds a
way to imp oppos his will his opponent
helps a little bit by making a mistake
and then he wins the game and he's
showing it right now look how hard in
and intense he's looking at the board
intensely He Is Us in it like maybe
there's something what is the thing
where's the trick how can I keep this
going how can I somehow create a m the
conditions even for a mistake by my
opponent just really impressive and in
order to do that you got to be super
determined you you've got to be focused
and alert for any possibility and you've
got to be in tremendous shape because
you can't do this round after round
we're on move right now we're on move
66 in the game and he looks about as
fresh and alert as if it was mooved 26
very impressive characteristic of this
player again even if he only draws the
game he can say he gave it his best
effort and I think that's a good sign
for him you know play a little bit
calculate a few variations so that he
can start to get back into his flow and
and possibly try to make a comeback
being two points down after this draw
here in this
tournament yeah absolutely it's
interesting how he tries to find moves
here even though his choices are so
limited if he goes to D4 it's
immediately a draw because that's a
three-fold repetition after Knight B5
check uh so I think the only move that
he has to try to press is King
D5 I don't think King C5 is a
particularly good idea allows Knight E4
check followed by Knight F2 but perhaps
he's looking at those variations so it's
interesting how he tries so hard no
matter what the position is definitely
not King D4 I think in this game but
anything else is still up in the
air yeah Gotta Love magnus's uh fighting
Spirit right and in terms of Athletics I
me he just loves every sport yeah it's
definitely something that helps him in
in ch is that he never runs out of
energy somehow or another it's wor were
well in the what fifth hour of games of
the games today and he I'm not going to
say he's fresh as he started but he
definitely doesn't seem to be afraid of
calculating variations and expending
energy we actually passed five hours
already right we're in the sixth hour of
play and again he seems quite fresh I'm
sure gir is thinking dude GE whiz I mean
we know it's a draw we just finish up so
we can go rest it's still a big game
tomorrow before the rest day but no rest
for the weary uh certainly Magnus is
going to keep trying and it will be a
draw in due time when he says it is
right so we have the move King C5 being
played now I suggested a knight E4 check
but Maurice has of course the answers uh
with the table base I believe you're
using to see if this is a correct move
or
not well pretty much everything draws so
it's uh it's still very easy for for
giri to play this game and and make a
draw the white king is just too far away
and the black king is standing perfectly
guarding everything so nothing it seems
is going to win here for Magnus he's
he's making moves but he knows it's a
draw fair enough so we're still GNA have
to see how giri exactly does this there
are a couple of Tricks I'm assuming that
uh Magnus Carl is going to try to set up
against the Dutch player
but I think he should easily avoid
them what kind of tricks do you see well
I don't know putting his Pawns in some
kind of formation that's going to be
complicated for the Knight to get
to I mean I'm trying to create something
that gir might fall into but even doing
that I'm having trouble
doing after King C5 I wanted to play
Knight E4 check then I'm assuming I
don't know King D5 yeah sure and I don't
know here Knight G3 is probably a draw
I'm guessing Knight F2 should be a draw
Knight C3 check looks like the most
obvious move though just to keep
harassing the King again King D4 is just
a draw King C5 transposes to what we
were just seeing the king if it goes to
D6 might be too far away and we have a
couple of
moves uh after King C5 actually King E6
was played instead which also makes a
lot of sense as the King on uh C5 is
further away from the action why bring
him back in if for example H6 then uh
probably Black's going to go back with
the Knight to F7 if that it concretely
draws the game then that would be the
end of the
struggle the strong grandm David how
said that there's non-stopping
excitement in Norway chess and it makes
him impatient to start playing
again that's right I haven't seen him
play in a in a super tournament in a
while actually David David how one of
the strongest players from England and a
very active player from his very young
years I had the pleasure of knowing him
for a very long time I think I met him
in the world juniors in 2008 fun guy as
well right yes yes very fun guy very we
so many of the Brits are though yeah
that's true they're they're a Fun Bunch
sometimes
and we've also got uh Claudia Munos who
is the the first US junior girls
Champion um and a great promoter of
chassis AR America she says that she
loves the thousands of GM chatting about
how giri missed this move or Carlon miss
that
move uh I mean of course she's referring
to the fact that people use their
engines to critique these super Grand
Masters right and of course any engine
that you use will beat the grand Masters
but that doesn't mean you understand why
why these moves are being played and for
you as somebody that wants to be
increasing their level it's not so
important to use your engines and try to
use your brain to understand what's
going on in the position yeah that's
what Magnus
does and it worked out pretty well for
him well so far so good not this
tournament though not this tourament
Maurice well personally my opinion about
engines is not that you use them to show
what the the GMS missed actually I think
most often you use engines to show just
how great these players are I mean the
fact is we would not see half the moves
these guys come up with I mean you know
okay as Grandmasters myself Alejandro
we're going to see quite a few of the
moves but there's some moves that they
see and they avoid that you don't
realize at all if you don't use an
engine you're thinking oh let me just
use my mind and and there's stuff that
comes up and you go wow they saw that
that's amazing and the engines are able
to reveal to us the Real Genius of the
players of course the players make
mistakes also and that's why we also use
engines to infuse the game with that
drama we say wow they could have play
that move and they themselves are Keen
to use engines to learn how to play
better chess the reason why chess has
risen so dramatically the level has
reisen has risen in the last 15 years is
my opinion because of engines because of
databases because of the internet making
all these games accessible
instantaneously in commentary so that
these things can be explained quickly
for people who are fans or the young
prodigies out there who might live
somewhere in the boonies but can just
flick on a computer and get right all
the great data that they want to get so
engines are absolutely useful it's not a
way of showing how bad the players are
because they miss moves like Bishop F7
which nobody would see frankly or people
would rarely see instead you use the
engines in order to illuminate what's
going on in a better way and that's
that's why we think it's an important
part of any broadcast
guys yep I think that I think it's a
balance yeah yeah you have to strike a
balance as with anything if you use
engines too much you're just gonna not
understand chess if you don't use them
at all well then your your chest is not
going to make any progress compared to
people that know how to balance their
study yeah the ster the player the more
they know how to wisely use it exactly
it's like a conversation that you're
having with the engine about what's
going on in position and we have uh the
concrete King C7 we have a couple of
moves King C7 the concrete Knight H6 G5
Knight here and I think that gir's
torture is close to being over notice
how this King cannot actually go towards
the king side right now so he has to
make some kind of pawn move I'm assuming
uh G6 simply does not work as I can park
my knight on H6 then go ahead and take
this guy take this guy and that should
be the end of the game and if you play
H6 I think that I can go King F5 Knight
H Knight G6 that should be okay yeah I
don't see anything wrong with actually
going King F5 here just going for a
blockade yeah just playing for the
blockade well you cannot play H7 because
I go and capture it but otherwise what
are you going to do I'm threatening to
capture you don't want to lose I'm
capturing on F4 well not going to happen
but yeah I think this just pretty much
seals the draw King F5 is
incoming yeah I don't think that's going
to last too much longer I think it's
already squeeze anything out of this
well I think it's concrete really a draw
not something like it should be a
draws tactics are there the tactics are
there the calculations possible to make
this into an insta draw so I think that
yeah this will not last to still the
intensity look at that I mean we could
be seeing a future world championship
match here now personally I I love
Magnus and and he seems like a great guy
but uh I'd like to see an America
involved in that match but still these
two are are potential contenders as well
absolutely Nish kir as you have
mentioned the youngest participant of
the Grand chess tour and he's one that's
going to make his Mark in the leite of
Chess even more in the coming
years for sure and and very it kind of
reminds me of Magnus and he's very funny
in his interviews as we saw today in the
one word descriptions where he was
giving some of the most colorful answers
he is a pretty funny guy Gary is very
sharp a very sharp mind not only over on
the chessboard but outside of it as well
that's rare for chess players to be
Sharp outside Common Sense waight
sarcasm but okay we have G6 I'm
expecting Knight H6 to be played almost
instantly
because I mean that move seems to draw
easily right the only other move I can
think of is Knight D6 but that doesn't
make sense Knight D6 King d8 was played
King F5 was played and as I said this is
just going to be and now they're moving
so quickly we're just they're just going
to munch the pawns um finally the
intensity has has gone and it looks like
Magnus is actually even a tiny bit bored
look at that well I mean this is
obviously just a draw I don't know why
they're taking so long but finally we
can say that this will end in the next
couple of I would say in the next minute
so King E7 was played King takes F4 I'm
expecting something like King F6 or
whatever then King G4 and I get to take
your final pawn and that'll be that'll
be it King versus King well I think
there's going to be a
knight yeah well King versus King is
going to happen there we go and we're
done hardfought draw very hardfought
draw could have gone to carlon's way how
he found one of the most brilliant moves
that I have ever seen in any analysis or
anything I don't think Anish is is
mentioning it now because of course he
he didn't see it either I don't think
Anish has any idea that this move
existed yeah um final thought from
Maurice on today's
action well I think that I think that
the game was certainly uh this game was
certainly a game that would be one of
misses and the round will be one of
mistakes as well the two critical
mistakes in the game with Fabiano where
he just played a move that we could not
imagine that he would play the game
against with topalov just getting a gift
from Maxim vashi lrav after the move
Knight to D5 and just falling apart so
quickly was the Frenchman there and then
Magnus Carlson as great a player as is
of course missing the move so this round
despite having a couple of games that
were really exciting the game with Anan
and giser certainly quite a game to to
take a look at just insane chess and the
solid game with hammer and aonian but I
think it was really marred by Mistakes
by the top players but still it's a
thrill to watch mistakes as well they're
only human and after three rounds we see
a lot of Victories more than we could
hope for well we actually we could hope
for a lot more victories but certainly
in this kind of level of competition
often you see five draws happen in
rounds so far we've seen a lot of
excitement and I expect to see more
excitement tomorrow in round four it
being the round before the rest day
definitely the players are going to come
for blood especially one Magnus Carlson
who can be happy he's sitting on half a
point so I'm thrilled to see how this is
going and let's hope for the best
tomorrow thank you Maurice and tomorrow
we see two guys headed into round four
with the lead veselin TOA and hiar
Nakamura it'll be interesting to see
their games they have very different
matchups but we're going to have to see
who is able to retain the lead or if
they have uh mistakes tomorrow don't
count anyone out and you're going to
want to join us for more action of the
grand chest or we're in studio St Louis
I'm Jennifer jti signing off for Grand
Masters Alejandra Ramirez Maurice Ashley
and yaser San over in Norway thank you
for
watching
[Music]